improve your node.js skills by building
four projects
this course is taught by john smilga the
wonderful instructor from coding addict
what's up everybody this is john from
coding addict and welcome to another
nodejs video
and in this video we're going to make
four node js projects while working on
the projects amongst other things we'll
cover what is mongodb and how to set it
up in our app how to get up and running
with mongoose how to set up error
handling in express and eventually we'll
deploy our project to heroku and
implement swagger documentation as well
just like my other videos we'll start
with the fundamentals and slowly but
surely move up to more complex
functionality this is the second part of
node.js tutorial video so my assumption
is that you're already familiar with
nodejs and express basics if you're
interested in the first video
node and express tutorial you can find
the link in the description in order to
follow with a project you will need a
starter and the fastest way you can get
it is by navigating to johnsmilk.com
again the url is johnsmilk.com
and once you hit this lovely site look
for the projects more specifically
node ones
and then all of these three links lead
to the same repo
so you can pick any of them and once you
click you'll navigate to the repo node
express course and essentially in here
just pick your weapon whether you want
to download zip or if you just want to
clone it i think in my case i'm just
going to go with download option
then go back to your computer look for
your downloads
then crack open the zip file
and
right away open up your favorite editor
in my case that is visual studio code
i'll drag and drop
and during this video will work on
following projects
so we'll work on zero three task manager
store api
as well as
jw2 basics and jobs api
and for all the projects you'll have the
same structure where there's going to be
a final and a starter so final is a
complete project and starter is where
we'll do all of our work now keep
something in mind where for the final
one
not only you'll need to install
all the dependencies basically run npm
install
but you'll also need to add some
additional info what info well that we
will cover during the project so don't
be surprised if you just run npm install
and npm start in the final folder
and you get back bunch of errors
that's about it for overall setup and
when it comes to
project specific setup i'll cover that
right after each project intro video so
once you've got the repo in your text
editor feel free to continue with the
video awesome and welcome to our first
project task manager api and before we
cover the features let me list the main
goals of this project and they're
following with the help of this project
we will learn how to set up and connect
to the cloud database
so effectively we'll learn how to
persist our data to the cloud
and not only that we'll also learn how
to perform all the crowd operations and
crud stands for create read update and
delete on our data which is fundamental
fundamental to any application also let
me mention that since it's a node course
we'll only work on a back end so
essentially the front end app you see
right now is already prepared for you
and it's only there so you get the full
picture
and the same is going to be for the rest
of the project
i'm probably not going to make front
ends for all of them
but if i'll see that a matching
front-end app can provide more clarity
i'll definitely whip up one as well just
so you can see the entire request and
response cycle not just post my
responses as far as the first project on
the front end we've got a form analyst
and by communicating with our backend
meaning by sending requests to our api
the user can create read update and
delete or destroy tasks again let me
stress something this is not your
typical to-do list app that stores
everything in local storage what's
fundamentally different is that we're
going to be responsible for setting up
the api that communicates with the cloud
database and persist the data to the
cloud and as far as the functionality it
goes something like this where we have
the form
and of course i can enter a new task
that's exactly how i'll call it we press
submit
so we send off the post request and
since we're successful we get back all
the tasks and the newest task is added
to the list
now we can also delete task so if i
don't want to walk the cat i just
removed from the list and then if we
want to edit we click over here and
first we'll see only the specific data
about that one task and then if we want
to edit for example if i want to set it
up as completed and if i want to rename
it as
old task then of course we just press
edit then we send off the request and
now if we navigate back to all the tasks
now as you can see it is completed
and the name is different as well and as
far as the task manager setup
like i already previously mentioned we
have
final folder so this is where you'll
find complete project
however not only we need to install
all dependencies but also if you take a
look at the readme you'll notice a text
where it says in order to run the
project you need to set up dot env and
set up the [ __ ] uri connection variable
and essentially these are the things
that we'll cover during the project so
in order to spin up the project yes
you'll have to watch some videos where
we actually cover that and only then
you'll be able to do that now as far as
the setup
a lot of things should look very
familiar so in here we have the public
and of course in the public this is
where we have our app again everything
is already prepared for you and just so
we all are on the same page i actually
created that with vanilla.js and then of
course we have the app.js and here i
simply have one line task manager app
and then if you take a look at the
package.json as far as the packages we
have express something we covered in the
second part of the course and then you
see two more packages dot env
and mongoose and of course these ones
will cover during the project why
they're there and what is going to be
the use case
now in order to make our dev setup
easier i also installed nodemon as a dev
dependency and as far as the script well
you just need to type npm start
and that essentially will spin up
nodemon with app.js and then we also
have git ignore which we're going to
cover a little later once we create the
env but long story short this is just a
file
that prevents specific files being added
to the source code and essentially with
this setup these two things will be
ignored if we decide to push this up to
the github so we'll ignore node modules
because usually they're pretty big and
then dot env because this is where we
want to keep our secrets and of course
we will cover this one later in the
project
and once we're familiar with the setup
let's kick things into gear and actually
start working on project
and first thing that you need to do
is to navigate to the starter folder
again you're looking for the third
project the task manager and then more
specifically the star folder
and i think the fastest way to navigate
there is by just typing cd
and then grab the star folder
and drop it here
and then once you're in a starter before
you do anything make sure that you
install all the packages and of course
we do that by running npm install and
then once all the packages are in place
in order to spin up the nodemon we need
to go with npm start unless of course
you want to change it to a different
command if that's the case then make the
changes and then use that command
instead so in my case i'll just wait a
little bit i mean it shouldn't take too
long there's not that many packages in
there and then once i have all the
packages in place then of course like i
said we're gonna go with npm start
and if you see task manager in the
console
we are in good shape
and now let's set up the most basic
express server which essentially is just
going to be listening for one route
forward slash hello
and it's going to be on port 3000 now if
you want to jog your memory and test it
up yourself just pause the video and
resume once you're done
if you don't want to do that just keep
on watching the video and the way we set
up the most basic express server
is by setting up a variable by the name
of express then we'll set it equal to
require and that's going to be equal to
our express package then we need to
initialize it so we go with app and that
is equal to express and we invoke it
and then unlike the previous examples
we'll actually set up a variable by the
name of port and for time being we'll
hard code this to 3000 but eventually
there is going to be more code and i'll
talk about the reasoning later so for
now just set up the variable and we'll
be in good shape and in here we need to
go with amp.listen of course and first
thing we pass in is the port and the
second is the console.log so we go here
with some kind of text
and i'm going to go with server is
listening
on port and then of course we pass in
the port value and i always like to add
those three dots as well so i'll do it
in this case and then i'll open up my
console the moment i have server is
listening on port 3000 which is just
awesome so now let's also set up that
one lonely route so above the port
i'm going to go with my comment routes
and then we'll just say app.get so this
is going to be a get request now what is
going to be the url well we'll go with
forward slash and hello so that's going
to be the path and then of course we
have the callback function
once the user hits the route and we're
looking for iraq and res so request and
response and we simply want to go with
reg dot send and then we'll pass task
manager
and app so i'll save it here i'll
navigate to the browser and i'm looking
for port 3000 of course
and then we'll go with hello
and if we see task manager app displayed
in the browser then of course we are off
to the great start
beautiful and once we have the bones in
place
next let's take a look at our
application so we can decide what route
eventually we're going to have
and i can see that i'm getting all my
tasks
so there will definitely be a get
request that gets me all my items now i
can also create a new task
so there will be a post request that can
create a new task now we can also delete
one so there will be a route for that
and if we click on edit we open up a new
page
and in here we get info about specific
route so there will be a get request
that just gets me info about one single
task and also
we'll have the ability to edit so if i
change the completed from true to false
if i successfully edit that then if i go
back to the tasks of course in here i
don't see the check mark which means
that i successfully edited the task and
what that means is that there's also a
route
for the update and in summary our routes
are going to look something like this
where there will be a get request on api
version one and then tasks so this will
get all the tasks then there will be a
post request on api version 1 tasks
again the same url however the method is
different so total different
functionality in this case we'll create
a new task
and then we have guest route
with params so with the id of the task
that gets us that single task and of
course one for update and one for delete
and since there's a lot to unpack over
here i'll spend the next video on the
reasons behind such api structure
all right so let's go step by step and
probably your first question is well why
do we go here with forward slash api and
then version one and essentially that is
just a convention we need to understand
that on the server we also might have
different routes not just the routes for
the api
so for example you could be serving a
index page here
on a forward slash meaning there could
be a nice index.html page that you're
serving up over here and then also
on the same server you have the api
routes so convention is effectively just
to signal that
all of these are the api routes now as
far as the version well as you're
setting up the api eventually you might
want to change some things so it's
easier if you have this version because
that way when you create a new one then
you can just direct everybody to api and
then version two three or whatever and
while we're still on that same note
why don't we navigate to a hacker news
one the one that i showed you previously
with algolia and you'll notice exactly
the same setup more essentially they go
with domain and then forward slash and
then api and then version number one and
that leads me to my next point where if
you're ever in doubt or if you're just
interested
on different setups just check out the
different apis there's tons of apis out
there and you can just look for one
then take a look at their setup and then
decide if what they're doing makes sense
to you then of course you can implement
in your project if not then just move on
to a different api
and eventually you'll find a setup that
makes the most sense to you
after that you're probably wondering
okay i understand the api high-end
version that kind of makes sense but why
do we go here with get and then tasks
then we have the post and
the same tasks and then for get patch
and delete we go to the tasks but then
we're looking for the colon why isn't
this written in a different way where
we're just looking for a single task or
something along those lines
and to give you a short answer that is a
convention but since there's more to it
i want to actually cover that in a few
videos
so i want to set up the basic routes
with just some simple responses
then i want to open up the postman
and do a little bit of setup over there
and then right before we start setting
up the database i actually want to spend
one video on just talking about the
convention and then lastly if you
remember in tutorial we worked with put
and now for the update we're using patch
and i know that this might be a little
bit frustrating to you but that's also
going to be something that we will cover
a bit later
once we have already a working
application because that way i believe
that i can give you a
solid example of the differences between
the put and patch that's about it for
the general route structure so now let's
start implementing it
not bad that bad i think we're good with
the general structure
so now let's start implementing it
and i want to right away set up the
router
as well as the controllers
and if you remember at the very end of
the express tutorial i covered why is
that necessary
and essentially the short answer is that
as our application grows bigger it's not
going to be very sustainable
if we'll just start dumping everything
in the app drives and for time being i
just want to create this one route now
as far as the response it's just going
to be a simple string that says hey
here are all the items or something
along those lines and then once we have
that one in place then we'll add the
rest of them and then we'll test it out
in postman
so let's get cracking
and i'm going to go with new folder so
here
will be all the controllers and in this
case i'm going to be looking for tasks
and i also want to set up a routes
folder
so in the routes folder
we'll go with new file
and same thing we're going to go with
tasks js
and then as far as the setup in the
routes we need to look for the express
router
so say const express and that is equal
to require
and then again we'll look for express
and this should be a refresher because
we did cover that at the end of the
express tutorial
so just to jog your memory if we go back
to express tutorial and then more
specifically we'll look for the final
one
the file 13
the router people shows a basic router
example
and essentially we have two options we
can either go with route or get
and then add all the controllers one by
one
or we can actually change them together
where we go with router and then user
route so this is going to be the main
route in our case api version one and
then tasks and then we chain
get and post and i think i'm gonna go
with this setup so first let's start by
setting up the router
and that is equal to express and then
router we invoke it
and then eventually we'll import
controllers but for now of course we
don't have any so let's just leave that
one blank and we'll go with router
router then route like i said then
forward slash and then i want to go with
get method and for time being i'll just
hard code the response over here so say
wreck and res
and res dot and send and like i said
we'll just start simply so say all items
now let's save that one and then all the
way in the bottom we want to go with
module exports and that is equal to our
router so now back in the app.js we want
to import the router we want to import
our tasks and we want to set up the
middleware so in here
let's just go with const and then routes
and that is equal to require and then
like i said we're going to be looking
in the routes folder and then more
specifically we're looking for tasks
and then right after this hello and
don't worry we'll change that one a
little bit later for time being it can
just stay the way it is we'll go with
app.use and then of course what route
are we looking for well we want to go
with api
then version one and then tasks
so that's going to be that root route
for the tasks router and then we just
want to go with our routes and you know
what let's just change the round but for
some reason i went with routes
let's just call it tasks
i believe it's going to make a bit more
sense and since we'll be sending json
from our application
for example when we're creating a new
task
and since i want to access that data
in my routes what we need to do of
course is get middleware that is built
into express and that middleware is
express json so above the routes we'll
go here
and i'll try to spell this correctly
since that is always an issue hopefully
this is correct middleware and then
we'll just go with app.use and
eventually we'll set up the static one
as well
but since at the moment we have barely
any routes i'm just gonna go with
express
and json if you remember if we don't use
this then we won't have that data in
rec.body
so i'll save it here
and i'll leave the comments just so we
all are on the same page
and before i test it out in the browser
let me just double check so i'm using
the middleware
where i'm saying that i'm looking for
api version one and then tasks and then
i pass in my router my tasks router and
then in the router
effectively i have this root path
which just matches whatever i pass over
here so again i go with api version one
and then tasks and then i set up a get
route where i manually pass in my
controller and here i just say res.send
and i pass in a string of all items and
looks about right so
let me go here and we're going to go
with localhost 3000 since it's a get
request of course we can access it then
api version 1
and then tasks and we should see a
string of all items and if we do then of
course we're heading in the right
direction so the last thing that i want
to do in this video
is to first close my express tutorial
one
and then in the controllers we want to
create a new file and we'll call this
tasks.js
and again just to jog your memory the
whole deal
why we're setting up separate routes and
separate controllers because if i'll try
to jam everything in app.js
it's going to get messy pretty fast so
what i want to do right now is take this
logic and place it in a separate file
because eventually of course there will
be way more logic than just res dot send
so i'm going to go to my controllers
and effectively i want to create my
function
the controller function and i'm just
going to go with const
get all and then tasks and i'll set it
up as an r function i'm looking for rec
and res
and functionality will be exactly the
same whereas dot send
and we're just going to go with all
and then items
and then we're going to go with module
exports and since i'm going to add more
functions in here i'll right away export
it as an object so say get all tasks
that's when i'm exporting and then back
in the routes of course i want to access
it so i'll say here that i wanted the
structure get
all tasks from and of course we need to
require it
and in this case we're looking in the
controllers so i'm going to go two
levels up i'm looking for controllers
and then more specifically task so
instead of hard coding this value of
course i'll just pass it in and i'll say
get all tasks and if i go back to my url
and if i can still see all items then of
course
we are in good shape and let me just
test it out where i'll change this
around and i'll say all items
from from the file
and then if we go back yep we still have
the correct result and with this in
place now we can set up the same basic
structure for rest of the routes as well
beautiful and in the same fashion let's
set up the rest of the controllers so we
have the get one now i want to create
one for the post
one for get but that's going to be a
single item and we also have one for
patch and one for delete and pretty much
in all of them
the setup is going to be exactly the
same as far as functionality i'll just
send back and i'll say what the
controller is doing since of course we
haven't connected to the database or
anything like that and i just need to
come up with a name in my case i'm going
to go with create task and again we have
rack and res
and then we want to copy and paste since
i want to speed this up and i'll just
say create
task create task and why don't we change
this one around and we'll say get all
tasks
now we want to copy and paste and we'll
have three more we'll have one for
getting task so get task and here we'll
say get
single task then we'll have one for
updating
and that's exactly how we'll call it
we'll say update task
the same is going to be over here and
then the last one of course will be
delete and then task and you guessed it
we also need to change the text
and now of course we want to place that
in the same object so let's go with
create task
then get task and we have update task
and last one is delete task and then
back in the routes of course we want to
import them so say here create task
get task
then update task and delete one and now
we just need to set up the routes if we
take a look at the app.js
these two
the get and post are gonna go to api
version one and then tasks
and then the rest of them are going to
be wii d id params
so
same initial path but then we'll just
add the forward slash and then id
and that's of course is where we're
going to pass the id of the task
so where i have the get request to get
all the tasks i'll chain
dot post and of course
which controller are we gonna use of
course the create task one and then we
can simply go to the next line and we'll
go with router
then route and like i said we'll go with
forward slash and then id
and then we're looking for
get route and that will be equal to get
the single task then we'll set up our
patch and that will be equal to update
task and then lastly we have delete one
and now we'll be equal to delete task
now since we know that we can only
really test the single task and get all
tasks because that's the default method
the browser performs we'll stop over
here and in the next video we'll spin up
the postman to quickly test all of our
routes because trust me you don't want
to go any further without knowing that
at least the basic setup works because
you can set up whatever logic you have
over here
if there's a small bug and you cannot
access these strings then you'll spend
way more time later searching for that
bug
nice job and once we have the basic
structure for all of our routes
now let's test them out in a postman so
i'm gonna head back to my desktop i'm
looking for the postman and since in
this case we'll spend way more time over
here i also want to cover some
configuration options so for starters i
want to switch to a dark mode because i
think you'll appreciate that more so if
you want to do that as well just go to
the cog and then you're looking for the
settings here
and then in the settings just look for
themes and of course we have a dark
theme as well so that's the first thing
that i'm going to do
then we want to create a collection
now why would you want to do that well
since we'll be setting up multiple
routes
and they'll reference the same
application which is going to be easier
as we create more and more applications
and in order to create that collection
we go here and click on creating the
collection and for starters i just want
to change the name so i'll click on
these three dots over here
and of course we're looking for rename
and then i'm just going to go with 0 3
and we'll call this task manager now if
you're not happy with this name of
course pick your own one and once i have
the task manager then we want to start
by creating a request
so we create a new request it's going to
be a get request and instead of typing
all the time manually here local
and then host and we're going to go with
3000 and then of course api version 1
and then tasks what we want to do is set
up a global variable
now there's multiple ways how we can do
that you can actually set up the
environment so think of this as a dev
environment and then you can have
production environment but in our case
we'll just set up this localhost and
then 3000 api and version 1
simply as a variable and you can do it
from here as you can see they even give
you a suggestion on all that but i'm
just going to go the long route where we
click here on that eye
and then notice i have already won for
the url i have localhost 3000 and then i
actually changed it later to forward
slash api
so now what i want to do i want to
showcase how we can remove it so if i go
over here
and if i remove it and i set up a new
one in this case again i'll call this
url and then as far as this value well
i'm just going to take this whole thing
so i'm going to go with localhost and
then 3000 and of course we're looking
for api and if you want you can also
include the tasks but in my case i'll
stop right after the version one so
let's copy that one again i'm setting
this up as a global but you can set it
up in the environment as well
and then
once we add that we should be able to
right away access it so now of course we
just need to save it and then in order
to use it
we need to go back and you know what
i'll remove everything for now and if we
go with these double curlies this is
going to give us access to those
variables and all the way in the bottom
we have the url and of course as you can
see it is global so in here i'm going to
go with url i'll close it and then i'll
go with forward slash and then tasks and
once i save i should get back get all
tasks and of course that means that our
basic setup works and before we continue
and do the same thing with the rest of
the tasks now of course we want to save
it and not only want to save it we want
to save it in our collection so let's
click over here save as and let's give
it a more meaningful name and in this
case again i'll say
get all
tasks
and of course we're looking for task
manager
so this is going to be saved in this
collection and we simply click on save
so if i take a look at my task manager
now of course i have get all tasks where
we use the global variable and we can
successfully see our string and i'll
close few of these tabs because it's
getting quite busy and let's do the same
thing for the rest of them
so in this case i'm going to be testing
the create one the one for the post
that's why we need to change the method
that's the first thing you want to do
then we'll go with our url again we'll
close it out forward slash
and then tasks and remember now we want
to send some data correct now we're not
doing anything with that data on a
server but just for the kicks why don't
we send it i'm going to go here with
body then we're looking for the raw
and of course we're not looking for text
we're looking for json we just need to
make sure that we use the correct syntax
and in this case i'll say name and that
will be equal to testing
and we just click on send and if we can
see create task we are in good shape now
since i also want to test out whether my
middleware is working
i'm going to go back to my controllers
i'm looking for
create task
and in here instead of just going with
send we're gonna go with json
so now i'll be sending back the json
and i'll pass in reg.body
so if you want of course you can log it
on a server but in my case i think it's
going to be faster if i just send back
whatever
i'm getting from the client so if we go
back and if we change this around and
we'll say here shake
and
bake and if we add a comma and then
completed
we set to true once we send
that should be our response and of
course the only thing that's left to do
as far as the create route is go to save
as
and then we'll say create
task
save it
and now let's continue again i'll close
these ones
just so it's not that busy and in this
case i want to go with get route
then we want to go here with the url
again
and of course we haven't set up the
database so there's no real id but we
can definitely test it out if we just go
with tasks and then whatever gibberish
so in this case i'm going to go with
hello so that's going to be my id so
we're not sending anything as far as
data but we are using the params again
if we take a look at the routes we can
clearly see that we have forward slash
and then id
that is going to be our param
and if we want to test it out where we
have get task of course we have the
request and the id is sitting in the
params so in here i'll do the same thing
i'll say json
and we'll just say id and that one is
equal to rec
params and the id so if we save here
and then go back and just use the get
route and click send we have the key
with the name of id and then the value
is hello so if we'll change it around
and if we'll say peter of course the
value will be peter again same spiel we
got save as
and we'll name this update task or i'm
sorry get single task my apologies get
single task
we'll save it and then we have two more
we have one for update and one for
remove
and in order to speed this up i don't
think i'm going to do any testing
anymore we simply want to open up a new
route we want to go with patch in this
case and again we're going with url and
then forward slash tasks whatever value
you want to pass in over here so i'm
going to go with one two three send and
of course i have update task beautiful
let's save that one
and we'll write here
update
and task
and the last one of course
is delete so let's close these two
and again your request we're looking for
delete method
the url is going to be exactly the same
and then we want to go with forward
slash tasks and then any of the ids that
we have already used since we'll change
that later anyway and once we send the
response should be delete task now if
you don't want to go with save as you
can simply click on command s
that's going to be a shortcut and we go
here with delete
and then task and of course we save it
in the same task manager
and once we can clearly see that we can
access all our routes correctly
then we can move on to our next topic
okay
and once we're done with the postman
before we start setting up our database
let's quickly talk about our routes more
specifically why we use such structure
long story short it's because we're
building a rest api
and since these days the term api is
used pretty much for everything let's
just all agree that in our case since
we're building a server essentially we
want to create a http interface so the
other apps most likely front-end ones
can interact with our data that's how we
view api in the scenario
and when it comes to rest it stands for
representational state transfer and
arguably the most popular api design
pattern and essentially it's a pattern
that combines http verbs route paths and
our resources aka data so effectively
rest determines how the api looks like
now let me emphasize something it's a
pattern not a strictly enforced set of
rules
so nothing stops you from setting your
own api
in totally different manner in fact if
you have used apis on your front-end
apps you know that some of them have
totally different structure i guess the
best advice i can give you is this
whatever pattern you decide on stick
with it or in other words be consistent
otherwise it's just going to be very
confusing for your users and this is a
common approach where you have the main
list
so that could be orders that could be
customers
that could be items whatever and of
course in our case it is tasks and in
order to get all the items we go with
get method and then if we want to create
one it's going to be the same endpoint
but we just go with different method and
of course in this case it is post and
not to be redundant we already discussed
this before
but just because they have the same url
the same endpoint since the methods are
different in this case we have get and
of course in second scenario we have
post these are two totally different
requests please keep that in mind
and then for individual item
you have the same path pretty much so
you have api and then tasks orders
customers or whatever and then you just
use the params to point to that one
specific item and then if you want to
get the item then of course it is a get
method for update you'll use put or
patch and then to delete one you'll use
the delete method instead and since json
is a common format for receiving and
sending data in rest api we'll use that
approach as well so even though at the
moment we use send method in our routes
eventually we'll switch to json method
instead
also i'd like to point out that rest in
general is somewhat fuzzy
in fact oftentimes you'll deviate a
weight from straight up rest
since that's what the setup will require
one more thing you can probably notice
something essentially our api allows our
user to perform a crot operations on our
data and crud stands for create read
update and destroy and it's a common
approach where the api interface is
built around crud since those are
usually or typically operations that
users or apps want to perform on a given
data whether it is again users orders
customers or in our case of course it is
going to be a task and we'll return to
credit a little later when i can
actually show you how it relates to our
data lastly there's obviously more to
rest
and some of that we will discuss in
later projects
but since i'm not a big fan of long
slide videos and i believe we covered
all the major points we'll stop right
here
and move on to our database setup if you
remember in express tutorial the route
setup was extremely similar to that we
have right now with one big caveat
we used basic array to store some list
of items on our server and based on the
request we performed some kind of
operation on the list
and then send back the response and of
course that is not very serious approach
to store our data and therefore starting
with this project we'll set up and
connect to a proper database
and pretty much for the remainder of the
course we'll use nosql or non-relational
database by the name of mongodb now i'm
not going to dwell on differences
between non-relational and relational
databases as well as pros and cons for
each of them but the major difference is
that unlike traditional database where
we have rows and columns in mango divi
we can simply store everything as json
and basically it doesn't care how the
data relates to each other instead of
tables we have collections which
represent group of items and instead of
rows we have documents which represent
single item
and a document is a set of key value
pairs and as far as data types we can
use strings numbers arrays objects and
many more it's very easy to get started
and even though you can set it up on
your local machine as well we'll right
away go for cloud option since that's
something you'll probably end up doing
anyway we'll use mongodb atlas which is
a official option basically it's created
by the same people who created mongodb
and since they offer generous free tier
you'll just have to create an account
and you'll be good to go and once we're
familiar with mongodb let's set up and
configure mongodb atlas so we can host
and manage our data in the cloud
i have the account already but since i
want to cover all the steps in detail
i'll set up another dummy account
together
and remember we can set up the entire
thing for free so don't worry your
credit card can stay nicely tucked away
in your wallet
if you get stuck or confused in any of
the steps we're about to take here's an
awesome resource you can use just google
create mongodb atlas
and follow this link which actually
brings us to official docs
and here you'll find a checklist which
we're going to use as a roadmap for the
following few videos
and what is the first thing they want us
to do
create a new account so let's do this
people
i'm going to open this up in new tab
and then of course you can find bunch of
useful info in here yadda yadda you keep
on scrolling and i actually want to
navigate to a login page and i'm just
going to pretend that i don't have the
account and we're going to go for sign
up and here of course you just need to
provide
all the necessary info
and once you have filled everything out
and as i said no don't worry this is not
my real phone number then of course just
click on sign up and up next they're
going to ask for organization
and project name
and in my case i'm gonna go with node
and express
course
then i'll pick javascript we'll click on
continue
and we probably can actually skip this
but let's just leave it there and up
next they want us to set up the cluster
now if you take a look at the checklist
actually cluster is already second step
so let's go back here and
pretty much you always want to show for
a free one unless of course you want to
start paying them so in here we'll just
go with create cluster that's going to
be the free one then it's using aws okay
awesome as far as region i'm going to go
with this one
then we have cluster tier and additional
settings and we'll leave them both as
default and lastly i just want to change
the name
and i think i'm going to go with node
express
and project and once we're done we just
need to click on create cluster
and we'll get ourselves a new cluster
now as you can see over here they say
that it's going to take a little bit of
time which is usually the case so i'll
stop the video here and i'll see your
next one where we'll continue with our
steps
and once our cluster is ready to go
before we start messing around with data
so with collections and documents and
all that
there's a few things that i want to do
first
and i'm going to start by setting up the
database access
so effectively in here we'll set who can
access our database now i'm not talking
about the atlas account
no i'm talking about the database and
collections we're about to set up
and we simply need to click on add new
database user
and we're gonna go with password
and if you get some default values just
wipe them clean
and i'll simply go with john
and as far as the password i'm just
gonna go with one two three four please
please please do not do that in your own
setup the only reason why i'm doing that
because you'll be able to see my
password anyway and don't worry once i'm
done setting up this project of course i
will change my password so it's not
going to be one two three four and once
you're done with the user and password
notice we have database user privileges
and this user can read and write to any
database so i'll leave it the way it is
and we'll add a new user
that's good i'll close this one
and then we want to set up the network
access
so we want to set up from where we can
access our database
and you can already imagine that of
course once we deploy the project then
of course we'll set up that ip address
but for time being while we work locally
we might as well set up access from
anywhere now if you want you can set up
your own ip address here so you can just
add the current one but in my case i'm
going to go allow access from anywhere
and i'll just click on confirm and
lastly i want to get the connection
string
that we're going to use once we connect
our database to our application and in
here what you're looking for is connect
so you want to go back to the cluster
then connect and then you want to go
with connect your application so not the
compass one not the [ __ ] shell actually
the second one here connect your
application
and then i'm gonna go with 3.6 or later
that's about right and then you just
want to copy this one and then navigate
back to our project
now eventually we'll set it up as the
environment variable yes that's going to
be the case but for the time being i'll
simply create a new folder in the
starter and i'll call this db
and then instead of the db there's going
to be a new file and we'll call this
connect gis
and then i want to create a new variable
and i'll call this connection
string and i'll set it equal to that
value now we'll have to add some values
over here but we'll do that later once
we're actually ready to connect our
application to the database so just take
the string copy and paste set it up in
the db and then connect js
and now we can start exploring the atlas
setup
as a quick side note while working in
local setup essentially while working on
your computer you can use any of these
two options so either access from
anywhere
or our actual ip address
but once we go to production
more specifically once we deploy our
project to heroku
you will need to use
access from anywhere option otherwise
you'll get an error and you won't be
able to connect your app to mongodb
now this is specific to heroku
for example when it comes to
digitalocean another popular option for
hosting your node apps
if you're using your local address while
developing once the project is hosted
you just swap the ip address from local
to production but the way heroku setup
works you'll need to go with allow from
anywhere option otherwise you'll get an
error and once we have set up database
access network access
as well as the connection string now
let's actually explore the data part
and we want to click on collections
then we're going to go with our own data
and then we need to come up with a
database name now the first one will be
a dummy one and of course once we
connect to our application then we'll
create a task manager one so the first
one i'll just call store
and then they ask us to create a
collection and don't worry i'll cover
what actually our collections and all
that but for time being i'm just gonna
go with product
and then we'll create one
and once we have everything in place we
are ready to start creating documents so
whenever we talk about mongodb
we'll have the database so that
essentially is going to be that
application again in our case eventually
this will be the task manager one
and then
inside of that database we'll have
collections
now if you're familiar with regular
databases you can think of them as
tables and in our collections we'll have
group of mongodb documents so if i name
my one products you can probably already
guess that here i'll have list of
products and if i'll decide that my
store will also have users of course i
can go here and create a new collection
and as a quick side note we won't have
to do this manually i'm just showing you
the general setup manually of course
eventually all this is going to happen
automatically once we connect from our
task manager so i have a list of
products and then of course i can also
create a list of users or list of orders
and hopefully you get the gist and once
we have our list
now let's talk about the individual
items so i can go to any of my
collections
and then once i'm here i can insert a
document
and document in mongodb effectively
represents that one single item and
what's really cool that just like
javascript object effectively it's a set
of key value pairs now by default the
moment we create a new document we'll
get this underscore id which is going to
be that unique id
so we don't need to worry about the ids
and then of course we need to set up a
type so what is going to be the type
for our document what is going to be
type for the item and if you click over
here as you can see these are options we
can set it up as an array binary boolean
and yada yada and i'm purposely not
going to spend too much time on types
since eventually we'll set it up from
our server anyway
and at that point the setup is going to
be a bit different
since we'll use tool called mongoose now
in our case what are we looking for well
we're just looking for the string i'm
just going to go here with name and then
i'll set it equal as first
and product so here of course i can
insert
and now not only i have the product
collection but i also have my first item
my first document
and here comes the biggest gotcha in
mongodb documents have a dynamic schema
and what that means in plain english is
the simple fact that documents in the
same collection don't need to have the
same set of fields or the structure
so if i were to go to insert document
and instead of string
i'm going to go with array
and i'm going to call this colors
and then i'll set my first one to be red
then second one blue
and if i'll save it as far as mongodbe
is concerned
they're still the same items in this
product collection so nothing stops you
from doing that now just because you can
does not mean you should and therefore
we will use additional library by the
name of mongoose which will set up that
structure for us but as far as straight
up mongodb yes both of these documents
are still part of this product
collection
even though their structure might be
totally different
few videos ago while discussing arrest i
mentioned crud
create read update and destroy or delete
and now i want to quickly show you how
is that going to look like
with our current
manual setup
i fully understand that some parts might
look really silly especially the read
one but in my opinion it's important we
start with the basics
and hopefully that way we'll have a
better understanding of overall
principles when we need to implement
crud in our rest api
so what does crud means in our manual
setup well first we want to create an
item correct so in here we just find any
of the collections and in this case i'm
going to stick with products since i
already have some items over here and
then we simply go with insert document
and again we just come up with a type
and then some kind of value and my case
i think i'm gonna go with another name
and i'll just leave it as a string
and i'll say test
crud
i'll insert the document
and i'm done
so we're done with the first part where
we created an item now the second one
reading them well we simply stare at the
screen and we can see that we have three
items so i can see that i have three
products again in our application that
just means that we'll be able to read
the documents that we have in our
database when we're working with gui
it's very straightforward where you're
just staring at the screen then we want
to update them
and then with the manual approach we
just look for this little pencil and we
say that we want to change some values
around here so in here i could go with
another item and i'll say green so now
of course i have successfully updated
the array as well and you know what
let's also add one more and i'll call
this
orange then i update and i'm done with
that part as well so not only we can
create read but we can also update and
then last one delete well we simply look
for another icon in this case we are
looking for the trash icon so we just
click here and now of course we remove
the item so that's the basic approach of
crud in our manual setup all right and
once our database is ready to go
now we need to connect to it from our
server and we can definitely use the
native mongodb driver and i believe the
package name was just that mongodb but a
very popular alternative is to use
package by the name of mongoose
instead which is a object data modeling
library
and essentially the reason why it's so
popular and why we're going to use it in
this and rest of our projects is because
right out of the box it comes with bunch
of goodies that make our development
faster now i'm not going to list them in
this video since you'll see them in
action in all of our projects just let
me repeat that yes you can set up your
apps with just native mongodb package
but the reason mongo's is so popular
is because it has extremely
straightforward api and it basically
does all the heavy lifting for us when
it comes to our project i already
installed mongoose so we can start using
it right away but if you want to use
mongoose in your own future project the
command is npm install and mongoose and
one last thing in this project we're
going to be using mongoose version 5
something
so if by the time you're watching this
if they have a higher version pretty
much everything starting from six
so if you have five point i don't know
14 15 or whatever you'll be still in
good shape but if
by the time you're watching this they
already have version six their api might
also be different and at that point you
have two options
install this particular mongoose version
or just use the latest one and utilize
their docs as a quick sign note since i
recorded the course mongos did come out
with new version version number six
now the good news is that as far as i
checked the only change that affects our
project is the lack of deprecation
warnings which we're going to cover in
the next video rest of them don't really
affect us now i still suggest using
mongo's version that's already installed
in the starrer while working on these
projects but as far as i have tested and
the current student feedback you'll have
no problem implementing the knowledge in
your own project with version 6 instead
all right
and once we're familiar with mongoose
let's kick it up a notch and finally
start using our database on our server
and the first thing we need to do is to
set up a connection and at least a basic
setup is going to look something like
this
where we're going to import mongoose and
of course we're going to do that in
connect.js so i'm looking for db folder
and then more specifically for
connect.js and then here at the top
above the connection string i'm going to
go with const mongos that's the name of
my instance and then that is equal to
require and of course i'm looking for
the markers
and once i have the instance then the
method name is connect so we go here
with
mongoose.connect and the first thing we
want to pass in
is the connection string but if you
remember
i said that we'll have to make some
changes take a look so this is going to
be my username correct but then what is
the value for the password of course
that is some dummy value so in here we
need to pass in our actual password so
in my case of course that is one two
three four but i strongly suggest using
more secure one for your application
and then here at the very end we have my
first database
so this is what they set up by default
and that's going to be the name for the
database if i don't change it
and you're probably wondering well wait
a minute i mean we didn't set this up on
the atlas so why it's here you see if
it's not going to be there it's going to
be created for you
so here you have two options either you
can just go with this one or in my case
i'm going to remove it and again just
make sure that you don't remove more
than you should so you want to remove
everything starting with the forward
slash
all the way to the question mark and in
here of course you need to come up with
a name and in my case i'm going to go
with the same name as my application
so since i have 0.1 for no tutorial and
then task manager is 0.3 that's exactly
what i'm going to set up over here so
i'm going to go with 0.3
then hyphen and i think i'm going to go
uppercase so i'm going to go with 0.3
task
and manager again this is going to be
the database name and if you haven't
created that database already
they will create for you and once we add
these changes our connection string is
ready to go so now we simply need to
pass in as a first argument now the
second argument is going to be options
and effectively
this is where we'll pass in some values
just to avoid some deprecation warnings
and you'll see what i'm talking about in
a second but for time being we'll just
leave it empty and then this returns a
promise so we simply can go with dot
then and since i want to see whether i'm
successful as far as the connection i'll
just pass in the callback function and
i'll say log and of course i'll remove
the semicolon and i'll say connected
connected
to the db
dot dot and then since there might be an
error as well we also want to go with
catch
and of course we'll just be looking for
the error so we have our callback
function and i'll say error and we'll
simply cancel log the error so we'll say
here cancel log
and i'm going to be looking for the
error and once we save nothing happens
and the reason why nothing happens is
because we're not executing this
function yet
but if you remember during tutorial one
of the first things that i covered is
the fact that if we have a function
in a module
where the function is effectively
executed there and then
we only need to import meaning require
the module and will right away execute
the function so i simply want to
navigate to app.js and then this is just
temporary because we will change this
setup around this one we won't leave it
this way i just want to get the
connection up and running and therefore
i'm just going to go to app.js and then
we go with require and notice i'm not
assigning this to any kind of variable
simply go with require then we look in
the db and then more specifically we're
looking for the connect and once you
save you'll have tons of deprecation
warnings and don't worry we'll fix them
in a second but all the way in the
bottom if everything is correct over
here
if you pass in the correct password and
you grab the correct connection string
then you should see connected to the
database
and if i want to test out the error i'll
simply remove the four since i know that
that is going to be a wrong password so
once i save now of course i'll have this
error so i'm just going to keep on
scrolling and notice here it's going to
say atlas error and of course i already
know why because my password is correct
and if we'll take a look at our
graphical interface in the atlas once we
refresh we're not going to see any
changes because again we haven't set up
any kind of logic so you're looking at
it you're like okay i still have one
database what's happening don't worry
once we start adding the items that
database will be created for us in my
case 0.3 task manager and even though i
will refactor this in the next video
because there's some gotchas that i want
to talk about before we do that i'll
show you how we can remove those
deprecation warnings
in a console and if you remember we just
need to pass in the second argument
which is going to be an object and in
here we just need to pass in following
key value pairs and we'll start with use
new
url parser and we'll set it equal to
true then we'll look for use create
index we'll set that one equal to true
and then we'll go with use find and
modify that one will be false and then
lastly we want to go with use
unified topology and that one will set
equal to true so once i save now i don't
have any of those warnings i simply see
server is listening on port 3000 and
then i have connected to the database
and if that is also something that you
see in a console you are in good shape
and we're ready to move on to the next
step nice we have successfully connected
to the database
and life is great
but before we start messing around with
the data there's something that's
bugging
and simply the fact that our server and
database connection don't work in sync
now what do i mean well let's take a
look at the console so first i have
console log
that our server is listening on port
3000
and only then we're connecting to the
database
but if we think about it
what is really a use for our server if
we are not connected to the database
whatever we're about to do is going to
fail anyway
so what i'm trying to say is wouldn't it
make more sense
if we try to connect to the database and
only if we're successful
then we spin up the server if not well
then we'll just kill the application
and in order to do that we need to
restructure our code a bit where i'm not
going to invoke mongoose connect
in the connect.js
i'll refactor the code and i'll set it
up as a function and instead we will
invoke it in the app.js
and in order to do that we'll just
remove this dot then and catch
now options of course stay we're not
doing anything with that
and here let's create a function we'll
say connect
and db and that is equal to our function
so essentially we're setting up the
arrow function and eventually we'll set
up the env variable and effectively
we'll pass it from the app.js and
therefore i'll add the parameter here
the url for time being we won't use it
we'll do the same thing what we did
before where we just passed in the
connection string that's coming up in
next video
and then i want to grab this mongoose
connect
cut it out and then from this connect db
i just want to return that result so
effectively what we're returning we're
turning a promise correct and then all
the way at the bottom
we're going to go with module
and export so now of course we want to
export it and where we want to export of
course connect
and db so once we have this setup then
we'll just have server is listening on
port 3000 because now of course we want
to assign it to some kind of variable
and again the order is really up to you
but i'm just going to put it below
the task so i'll just move it over here
below the tasks and i'll say that that
is equal to connect db
so effectively i'm just getting that
function over here and i'll set it equal
to the required one
and then once i have access to the
function then all the way in the bottom
i want to set up one more function by
the name of start
and in this function we will invoke
connect db
and then only if we're successful
then we'll spin up the server so let's
go somewhere here in the bottom
and we'll say can't start again we'll
use the arrow function and since i know
that my connectdb returns a promise
correct
i can set this function as a sync and
that way of course we can use the await
keyword and every time we have a
synchronous operation it's very useful
to set it in the try catch block so that
way if there is an error we can handle
it as well
and in try block we'll pass in a wait
so since i know that it returns a
promise i'll use my await keyword then
i'm going to go with connectdb again
eventually we'll pass in the string
coming from the env file for time being
we just have hard coded e and d connect
js and then only if we're successful
then we'll spin up the server so i'll
move this line of code right below the
connectdb and again we'll just spin up
the server if the connection is
successful if not we're gonna go with
console.log
and then we'll just look for the error
so once we save nothing happens we don't
spin up the server because of course
now we have a function so all the way on
the bottom i'm just going to go with
start and then you'll notice that
there's a console log for the server now
of course we don't have the console log
for the connection because we removed
that in connect js but if you really
want to test it out again go back over
here
and just mess with your password and
you'll right away see
that we'll get that error in console and
in here it says bad auth authentication
fail so we know that our setup works so
if of course we will have a wrong
password then we won't be successful
however if everything goes smoothly then
we should see that our server is
listening on port 3000 not bad not bad
we have set up the connection we have
refactor code and we're almost almost
almost ready to start tinkering with the
data but there's one last thing that i
want to do first
and that is simply setting up the dot
env file now why we would want to do
that well let's think about it
eventually we might push this up to the
github correct
and what do you think is going to happen
the moment i push this up to the getup
of course everyone who takes a look at
my repo
can nicely grab the string
and then tamper with my data and how we
can avoid that well the solution is to
set up dot emv file where we can keep
our secret
and then in our application we'll have
to use a package
by the name of dot env and of course i
already installed it for you and then
we'll be able to access those secret
variables anywhere in our application
and once we push this up to the github
if we add git ignore so dot git ignore
file and then in here we specifically
say which files we want to ignore and
make sure that you add dot env now i
also added node modules because that is
common practice since that folder is so
big but as far as keeping secret secrets
make sure
that not only you set up dot env
and of course use the package because
otherwise you won't be able to access
the variables but always always always
the moment you set up dot env
also set up dot git ignore and that way
we'll just push this up to the github
and then dot env will be ignored so when
people come and see your repo they won't
see this
secret connection string so let's start
here by creating dot env and in my case
i'm going to do that in the root so i
also suggest you do the same so i'm
going to go to the starter i'm looking
for new file and i'm going to go with
dot and then env and in here we have
again key value pairs however we don't
need to use the quotation marks
and i think i'm going to go with [ __ ]
and then uri in this case so i'm not
going to go with long name the
connection string and then you simply
want to take this value so cut it out
from the connect js
go back to dot env
set it equal to my [ __ ] uri
and then where i have connect js i can
simply remove it and then remember
when we were setting up the function
i said that i'm going to be looking for
the parameter but of course initially we
were not using it now of course i want
to use it so i'll remove the hard-coded
connection string and i'll say url and
we'll just save now there's going to be
an error don't worry because of course
we're not passing that connection string
notice over here we have the parameter
blah blah blah is undefined okay that
was expected now what we want to do
is go to the app.js since over here we
invoke start
and then we want to pass in that value
from the dot envy into the connect db
and in order for us to access those
secret variables we simply need to
require that package so i'm going to go
below connect db
and we'll just say require and notice
how we don't have to assign it to any
kind of variable we just go with dot env
and that's the package name and as i
said if you want to install you just go
with npm install and then the package
name
dot env pretty self-explanatory and then
you want to use process dot env and then
whatever is the variable name so let me
save my dot env and then back in the
app.js once we require we just want to
go with dot and config
so essentially we just want to invoke
the config so now if we keep on
scrolling where we have the connect db
we want to go with process dot envy and
remember that was one of those global
variables we go with dot env
and then we go [ __ ] or whatever the
name for your variable is in my case
that is [ __ ] uri and we'll save it and
of course we're back in business because
i have server is listening on port 3000
again very very important
if you want to keep your secret
variables actually secret set up the dot
env
get the package and you'll be able to
access them anywhere in your application
by using
process.env and then whatever e is the
name of the variable beautiful
and once our connection string is a env
variable now let's set up the structure
for our future documents
and assign them to the collection and
we're going to do that using schema and
model from the mongoose
and the way it's going to look like
we're going to go to our starter and
we'll create yet another folder and in
this case we'll call this models and
then inside of the models we'll create a
new file
and we'll call this task.js so i'm going
to go here with task.js and then the
setup is going to be following where
again we import mongoose and we set it
equal to require
and then mongoose of course
and then we're looking for
mongoose.schema so we set up a new
variable and i'll call this task
schema schema and that is equal to new
so we're using the constructor and we go
with new mongoose and schema
and you're probably wondering okay what
on earth is happening
well if you remember
when we were setting up the atlas
manually one of the first things that i
mentioned
is the fact that for our document
there is no set structure
but that's exactly what i want where for
my tasks i only want the name which is
going to be a string and a completed
property which is going to be a boolean
because you would have to agree
that it's not going to make much sense
if somewhere
in my tasks i'll have an array with the
color values correct so therefore we go
here we go with [ __ ] schema and using
schema we'll set up the structure for
all the documents that eventually we'll
have in our collection and the syntax is
following where again we use key value
pairs
and eventually we'll set them equal to
an object and we'll pass in
more options but since i just want to
get something quickly in our database
we'll just start quick and dirty where
essentially i want to come up with a key
in my case again that is going to be
name and completed so those are going to
be the two keys and i'll just set up the
types so that is a bare minimum where
you go with the key name and then the
actual schema type so what type of data
this is going to be and if you're
interested on what options we have just
navigate to mongoose official docs and
then look for schema types keep on
scrolling and then of course you can see
string number and yada yada so i'm going
to navigate back and i'll say name so
that's going to be my first key and i'll
just set it equal to string
then comma and of course i'm looking for
completed
completed that is going to be my second
key and that will be set equal to
boolean again barebones setup will do
more complicated a little bit later and
then once we have the schema so
essentially once we have the structure
for the data
now we want to set up that model and
think of model
as a representation for the collection
so these guys are sticking in the
product so now of course we'll create
tasks collection and then all the tasks
that we're about to
push into our database of course will be
added to that specific collection and
what's even more cool in mongoose a
model is a wrapper for the schema
so if the schema defines the structure
for the document like the type
validations and etc a mongoose model
provides an interface to the database so
using the model will be able to create
update query and delete our documents
with great ease since the api is
extremely extremely straightforward and
you'll see what i mean in the upcoming
videos
and we do that by creating a model and
we right away export so go with module
dot exports and that is equal to mongos
then model
and then model is looking for two things
it is looking for the name
and then we want to pass in the schema
so in here i'm going to go with task and
then comma and of course this is the
schema that i want to pass in so say
here task schema and once we're done
with this the only thing we need to do
is go to our controllers
and start using our model
beautiful
we have set up our first schema as well
as the model
and of course we want to start using it
and yes we will use it in controllers
therefore we'll navigate there and i'm
going to be looking for my model and
i'll assign it to the task variable i'll
say require i'm looking
in the models folder and then more
specifically task and then before we
continue let me just give you a brief
overview of what we're about to do so if
we navigate back to mongoose docs and
more specifically if you're looking for
the models we can find here more info
you can see that models are fancy
constructors compiled from schema
definitions
an instance of a model
is called a document
and then they give you this example
pretty much
everything that we did in last video
apart from the fact that of course they
have different values
and here we have nice explanation that
the first argument is singular name of
the collection your model is for since
mongoose automatically looks for the
plural lowercase version of your model
name
so effectively eventually we'll have the
tasks
then i mentioned one more time that the
instance of the model is called document
and there are few ways how we can create
one we can go this route
or we can use dot create
and here they showcase the callback
function approach but we can also use a
weight
and essentially what create is looking
for well it's looking for the object
with those properties so in our case we
have name
as well as the completed correct and of
course we can pass this manually but
wouldn't it make more sense if we just
go to create task route
and since we know that in there we can
access the task data in the request.body
why don't we just pipe it through and
pass it along to our model create method
and it's going to work something like
this
where i'll grab the body of course it's
going to be coming from my postman here
shake and break and the value will be
true and then instead of sending it back
we'll pass it into task dot create now
since i'm going to be using a weight on
a task dot create of course i want to
refactor this and i'll say that this
function the create task actually is
going to be async so my controller will
be async
and then instead of the function body
i'm going to go with task and i'll set
it equal to a weight like i said i'm not
gonna use the callback function approach
i'll use a weight instead and we'll
await for task
dot create and like i said if you want
you can hard code this here you can say
name and then first
task and of course we can do the same
thing for completed
but i already covered why it's going to
make way more sense if we just take this
rec dot body so whatever we're getting
from the postman and then let's just
pass that object into task.create and
let's see what happens so i'll remove it
here
and i'll just say
rec dot body
over here and as far as the response
well now i'm just waiting for a task so
instead of wrecked that body in response
i'll place my task and i also want to
add the status and if you remember the
correct status was 201 effectively that
is if you have a successful post request
and then instead of json being equal to
rec.body we'll pass in the object and in
here we'll pass in our task and then
once we save again nothing happens
because we haven't triggered the post
request
but
if we go back to the postman and if i
click here send what i should see
is this i should see the task so that's
my object and now check it out we have
this underscore id and what that means
well that means that we created a new
document with the following properties
we have name we have completed we of
course have the id like i just mentioned
and we also have this underscore
underscore v so of course these two are
created by default every time we create
the document and then these ones we
provide
so if you want to keep on testing we're
gonna go with second task
and
we'll set maybe the completed to false
again this is all quick and dirty just
because i want to have some data in my
database there will be still some
modifications to the code
but if we can see the successful
responses
where we have tasks with underscore id
what that also means my friends
is that when we go to our database and
if i refresh
check it out now of course i have the
task manager like i said that's my
database and what do you know
of course i have the tasks collection
now what do i have in task collection i
have documents what documents
shake and bake
and second task and if you have the same
result congrats we're off to the great
start
nice at this point we can successfully
create new tasks
and persist them in our cloud database
so now it's really just about applying
the same concepts to the rest of our
routes but before we set up the rest of
the four controllers in a similar
fashion there are a few important things
that i want to cover first
for starters i just want to showcase
that since we set up our schema
only the properties that we specified in
our schema will be passed on to the
database
and everything else is going to be
ignored
don't believe me let's try it out first
i just want to showcase that in our
schema we specified two properties name
and completed so now if i go back to the
postman
and i'll just set up testing schema
that's going to be my name
testing schema i'll leave completed as
false but if i try to add some
properties
that are not on my schema effectively
they will be just ignored so my guys i'm
just gonna say
random is equal
to random now i do still need to use the
proper jsons index and then i'll just
add the amount and i'll set it equal to
five
now you can add 10 000 properties and
again the result is going to be exactly
the same so i'll just leave these two
and we'll try to send it so here i send
and then check it out
now what i get back is only the name and
only the completed again let me repeat
only the properties that you set in your
schema
will be passed on to the database
everything else will be ignored which of
course is really really cool because
that way we can avoid this mess
where if you remember back in the store
when i was setting up the products one
has name the other one has the colors
because there is no structure for these
documents
when we use schema there is a structure
so whatever we set up in a schema
is going to be passed on to this
database and whatever comes as an extra
is just going to be ignored all right
and once we've got that out of the way
next i want to talk about validation
you see even though we only accept the
properties that are specified in the
schema
our current setup has one big doozy
there is no validation so essentially we
can pass in empty values how is that
gonna look like well again we can go
back to the postman
and in first example i'll just remove
completed
and i'll pass in the name
as an empty string now i do need to fix
this comma here
but you'll see that actually we're
successful
so i can create item this way
and what's even more interesting
is that i can send an empty object and
i'll still be successful
and you have to agree that
actually this is not the best setup
correct so that way we can just set up a
bunch of empty items now what can we do
about it well we can add the validation
to our schema now before we continue
though let me just say that when it
comes to validation since it's a pretty
big topic we'll just be scratching the
surface the plan is to show you more
features as we progress with the
upcoming projects since i have a feeling
that if we'll spend the next hour or two
on just validation
understandably a lot of you will lose
interest and attention don't worry
though the end of the video i will show
you where you can get more info so at
the moment we have a very minimal setup
where we have properties
and we just specify the type
however
we can set up our properties as objects
and then we can also set up built-in
validators how is that going to look
like well
i'll remove the string part from the
name and then i'll set it equal to an
object i'll add a comma of course since
i need to keep the proper syntax and
here the first property we want to set
up is type now it's still going to be a
string but now of course we can add more
validators now what validators can we
use for starters we can go with required
so what this is going to do
is if i pass in the value the object
without my name property then it's going
to spit back big fat error now at the
very basic level you can set up equal to
true or false either it is required or
not but if you want a custom message you
can actually set it equal to an array
where you go with the first value again
true or false
and then you add a comma and then you
pass in that custom message and in my
case i'm going to go with must provide
and name
now what else i can do well i can trim
to imagine the scenario in a postman if
i go here with name
and if i pass in here spaces and then
john effectively with our current setup
that's exactly how we'll save it in our
database
and if i don't want that i can simply go
back where we have the object and then
the property that you're looking for is
trim
and we'll set it equal to true
and what's also really nifty that for
strings we can get min values or max
values and in my case since i don't want
my value to be bigger than 20 characters
for the name one i can go with max
and property that we're looking for is
length make sure that you spelled
correctly this is always a doozy for me
when it comes to length and again we'll
set it equal to an array and i'll say
that the value for my string is going to
be 20 and then in here we'll just go
with name
cannot
be more
than
and of course we'll set it equal to 20
and nine characters and essentially
we're done with basic validators for
name because like i already mentioned i
really just want to scratch the surface
so you get the main idea and then as
we're progressing with the project then
of course we'll implement more features
and i want to do the same thing for
completed where i'm not going to go with
required hopefully this is clear and
you'll see in a second what kind of
error we have if we don't pass the name
but for the completed i just want to
show you that we can also set some
default values and again we want to
remove this boolean and we're going to
go type we'll set it equal to
boolean
and then as far as the default value the
property is simply default and as far as
default in this case
for the task property completed i think
it's going to make most sense
if we'll set it equal to false
again just to showcase how is that going
to look like
in a real project so as i'm adding the
task
new
task
by default it's not going to be
completed and only when we navigate to a
specific task page and i say yep it's
completed now we can add it and then of
course we can navigate back to all the
tasks this was just my setup of course
there's a million different ways how you
can do that but that's why in here
when i'm setting up my validators i set
my completed one to be equal to false so
now of course we can save it
and we can test it out so i'm going to
navigate back to my setup here in a
postman and as you can see completed is
still not required
and that is done on purpose so
essentially i already set this up as
default false so i don't want to set it
up as required therefore we don't need
to pass it here but i just want to see
how it nicely is going to trim
and how we also will get errors
if we don't pass in any values so in
here let me just try with the john and
notice once we send we actually get
trimmed value back and completed is set
to false
right away okay
that's an awesome start but notice what
happens if we send an empty string
so let me remove all the values let me
click on send
and now check it out so we have here
this sending request and the reason why
we're not getting anything back because
we have big fat error in our console we
have validation error and there's few
things that we need to understand about
this error
first it is caused in a task schema
because we finally set up the valve
there and we set it equal to true and of
course we're sending empty string so
that's the same thing as if i were to
send completely empty object over here
so if i cancel it and if i send it again
notice again we're not getting the
response that's point number one number
two
if you take a look at the console you
see that we have this unhandled promise
rejection
and this error is originated blah blah
blah blah and long story short it is
caused in our create task because we
have a weight keyword however we're not
handling this gracefully we don't have
the try catch block where we set up the
await in the try and if there's an error
then of course we do something about it
and since this video is already getting
quite long i'll actually do that in the
next one
so just put this one on ice and then in
next video we'll set up a proper
response and just to recap as far as
basic validation we just need to set our
property equal to an object then we need
to set up still the type and in our case
that was the string and then we can go
with the required
if we want to have a custom message then
we just set it equal to an array
and the first item is going to be the
value whether that's true or false for
required and then the second one will be
the custom message
then for the string we can also use trim
and that's just going to make sure that
we don't have any white space and you
can probably already guess that there's
one for the min length as well
and in a completed one we covered how we
can add a default value as well so for
this one we set it equal to false and if
one of our validations is going to fail
then of course we won't be successful of
adding that item
and like promised if you want to learn
more about validation just head on over
to mongoose docs
so navigate here and then you're looking
for the validation
and as you can see there's quite a bit
of info here so if your idea of good
time is scouring through the docks you
won't be disappointed
not bad not bad i think we have good
general understanding of the basic
validation
in mongoose
so now let's switch gears and talk about
how we can handle it more gracefully
because at the moment well we're just
leaving our user hanging correct
so if the user
sends some kind of request with
incorrect data then of course we have
the error here on the server but as you
can see the user is just hanging and
probably it's not the best approach and
again the whole reason for that is
because we have a synchronous operation
however we're not handling if there is
an error and the fix is following where
we want to go with try catch and then we
want to place our await
in the try block and also right away set
up my response so if we are successful i
still want to send back the response
with our task document the one that
we're getting back
from the model
and then the second thing if there is an
error what do we do well we could also
send back the response and in this case
the status is going to be 500 and
effectively that is just a general
server error and as i said i'm purposely
using just a general server error status
code the 500 one since we'll discuss
errors in greater detail later in the
project
and then we can go with json and i'll
set up the message property and i'll set
it equal to my error so now if we save
and if i go back
and if i send one more time you'll
notice that instead of hanging we
actually get a response and in here i
can see that the status is 500 so it's
definitely our response
and at this point in time you probably
have two questions
first
do we really need to wrap all our logic
in every controller in trying catch
since i can give you a hint that in the
remaining controllers we'll also use the
functions
and we'll stick a weight in front of
them and the short answer is yes
for timing we'll have to do that but
then eventually by the end of the
project i'll show you multiple ways how
we can simplify that
and how we can omit this boilerplate
code for try and catch then your next
question probably is okay
we get the response
but this error
seems a bit lengthy can we make it
shorter and my answer again is yes we
can
and the most basic approach is going to
look something like this
instead of setting message property
equal to another parameter
just simply set it equal to generic
there was another string value as far as
more complex setup i'll discuss it at
the end of the project since i want to
keep moving along with the rest of the
functionality as far as my setup i will
keep sending this giant object since
that way i can show exact error messages
we're getting and as far as our api i
think we're actually in pretty good
shape where we can create a task we do
have some basic validations and if there
is any kind of error well we simply send
back 500 that there is a server error
and we send back error message yes quite
long one but at least it's better than
leaving the user hanging
and if we want to try out the max length
and simply go here with name
and then i'll just add some gibberish
just so it's more than 20 characters so
let me type it out here and then once i
save again we get the error message
where we have name cannot be more than
20 characters
that should do it for this video and now
we're ready to move on to our next topic
and once we're done discussing the
validation
as well as the need for try and catch
since we have a synchronous operation
why don't we continue with our
controllers
and up next i want to work on
get
all tasks
so we know already how we can create a
task we know that we have a model in the
model we pass in the schema and then in
order to get the instance we go with the
name of the model and of course the
method name is dot create now what about
rest of the correct operations and again
we'll use our best helper the mongoose
docs and if we navigate there and then
if we look for queries
then we can have this nice text where it
says mongoose models provide several
static helper functions
four
and this should be already familiar
crud crowd operations and each of these
functions returns a mongoose query
object
now we'll work with query object way
more in the next project but for time
being we just need to understand that
on every model
we have these methods that we can use
starting with delete menu all the way to
update one and the one that we want to
use right now is this one the find one
and i'll just open this up in a separate
tab and then we can see that as far as
the parameter we want to pass in the
filter object now what does that mean
well it means that if i'll leave this
filter object empty this is just going
to get me
all the documents
so in our case this is just going to get
us all the tasks now if we start
supplying the values for example in our
case we could say completed equal to
true of course that is going to get us
what that is going to get us only the
documents that are completed
again the way i've set up the projects
of the next project the second project
is the one where we'll take a deep dive
into the filtering sorting and all that
for time being we just need to
understand that if we want to get all
the documents which is going to be in
our case for the get all tasks
controller we simply need to use find
now it's also really interesting
is the fact that if we go back and if we
keep on scrolling
we can read that a query also has dot
then function
and thus can be used a promise
now there is a caveat where technically
it's not returning a promise that's why
i say here
used as a promise and essentially what
that means for us is that yes we can use
a weight so for simplicity we can stick
a weight in front of it and we'll be in
good shape however if you keep on
scrolling you'll read that queries are
not promises and there are situations
where it's really important but if we
keep on reading here they have that then
function
for async await as a convenience so long
story short similarly to how we created
task with a weight and we set up try and
catch block we'll do it here as well
and the way we'll do that we'll go with
try catch
so in here of course there's going to be
an error but if we're successful then of
course we'll just send back all the
tasks so let's start here with const and
i'll set it equal to the tasks and the
value will be equal to a weight so use a
weight keyword therefore in front of the
function i want to set up my sync and
then i want to go with task so that's
going to be the name of the model and
then the static function name is fine
and since i want to get all the
documents in the task collection
therefore i'll just stick here a empty
object and then as far as the error well
in order to speed this up i'll just copy
the error
from the create task and pass it here as
well and now the only thing is missing
is our response if we're successful what
do we want to do well we want to go with
res dot and then we're looking for the
status in this case the status is going
to be 200
and then json and in here i'll just say
tasks so i'll be sending back the object
and then instead of that object there's
a property by the name of tasks
and as far as the value it's going to be
equal to whatever i'm getting back from
the find and i'm just using the es6
shorthand where if the property name
is exactly the same as the variable for
the value well we can omit the second
part
and effectively it's the same as if i
were to write like this so we have tasks
equal to tasks and then with es6 we can
just shorten this up
and once we save
and if we go back to the postman
and you know let me fix this one
i'll say here properly i'll say testing
testing task
because i want to save that create one
so i'll save it here so it stays as our
request and i'll close it and then if we
go to all the tasks
and we simply hit send
now what we should see
is of course our object and check it out
now we have all the tasks so we have our
array and then inside of that array we
have items of course each item is
represented as an object so successfully
we have set up the second route as well
for all the tasks and here we use the
find static function and we pass in the
empty object which just gets us all the
documents in the collection and in our
case of course those are our tasks and
then if we're successful if there was no
error we just go with res dot status so
we set up the status for response and we
send back a json and i just jam all my
tasks inside of the object and set it
equal to the tasks property awesome and
once we have set up the controllers for
create task and get all tasks
next i want to work on get task
and effectively in our application
that route provides info about specific
tasks
so in here
i can see all the tasks i can create one
of course
but if i want to edit it i'm going to
click on edit button and then notice how
i'm getting the info about this specific
task of course normally you wouldn't
share the id but in this case i just
wanted to provide more info so not just
the name but also an id so that way you
can clearly see that this info is just
about this task and similarly i can go
to the next one and again i'll get the
id i'll get the name and whether it's
completed or not now in this video of
course we won't set up the edit but at
least we'll get that specific info and
general the setup is going to be pretty
similar to the one we have with get all
tasks
however
we'll also have to implement a specific
response
if
the id that we pass in doesn't match any
of the tasks that we currently have
and in order to get up and running we'll
navigate back to the docs to the
mongoose docs and in this case we're
looking for the find one static helper
function just like we used find in this
case we're looking for find one
open up new browser window and then
notice as far as the parameters we go
with conditions so we pass in conditions
object and
they're very helpful here where they say
find one adventure whose country is
croatia otherwise no so essentially we
use a weight just for convenience we
have our model then we have find one and
then we pass in the object
and in that object we set up what well
we set up the condition
and in this case they look for the
country in our case of course
we will look for a task and we'll use
the id
so i'll say
get me the task whose id
is equal to whatever i'm getting from
the params otherwise we'll get back now
so let's now get back i'm looking for
get task and remember in here of course
i'm getting that params id
and before we type anything here in the
controller
i just want to set it correctly my id
because of course
initially well i was just passing here
repeater but of course that's not the
case anymore and since i want to use the
id that i'm getting back from the mongol
i'm gonna go to all the tasks i'll run
it of course i get my list awesome and
then pick any of the tasks doesn't
really matter which one just look for
the id
copy this one and then go back to the
single task and then of course instead
of peter
pass in the eddy and send and if you get
back the id key with this value with
that long string value which is an id
then of course we're in good shape and
i'm doing this just so we don't have the
console log here on the server you can
definitely do so but i just think that
it's more convenient for us to see those
logs here in a postman and then once we
have everything in a place i want to go
with my get task
and here what's the logic well we could
start by setting up i sync of course
because we'll use the await then we'll
go with our try catch block and then
i'll move this sucker up and then first
we just want to get that id out of the
params so of course you can write it the
long way but i always like to do the
structuring first so we'll go here with
const id
and then i always prefer giving it
somewhat useful alias otherwise you just
end up with bunch of ids and then once
in a while it's just confusing which id
is for what so i'll say grab me the id
which is coming from the params but use
the alias of task id from now on and
then i set it equal of course to rec dot
params
so it's the same object that i'm getting
and then of course we want to use that
fine one correct
so we're going to go with const this is
going to be our document that we're
getting back if we're successful
and we'll go with await and then task
and then find
find one and then like i said we pass in
the object and in this case i'm going to
be looking for underscore id
so not the name but underscore id which
matches to that in the params so use
here task
and then id
and if i'm successful beautiful we'll
send back the task
if not then we'll have to send back the
404 response so here we'll go with res
dot and we're looking for status so say
that everything is correct we were
successful and therefore we'll go with
res dot status 200 then dot json and
then i just want to pass in a task i'll
say yep that's the task you're looking
for now there also might be a case where
there's something wrong with an id
where essentially yes we're getting the
value from the params but it doesn't
match any of the tasks and if you
remember documentation
then we get null
so what is the case then well then i
want to check if the task actually is
null and then of course i want to send
back different response now make sure
make sure make sure that you always
always always set up here return
otherwise what's going to happen well
javascript is going to be reading the
code and if you don't have the return
even though there might be no task well
you'll send one response and then you'll
send the next one right after that so
always always make sure that you have
return so that way javascript knows okay
so now i just need to return from the
function and in here we go with
res.status now in this case though of
course task that we're looking for
doesn't exist
and the status code for that is 404
and then again we go with json here and
we'll pass in the message in the object
and the message we'll be following we'll
say no task with id
and then colon and then we'll just look
for task
and then id
and eventually of course we also might
have the error
and i'll talk about these two errors in
the next video because that's going to
be a common theme that will set up for
the upcoming rounds and i kind of want
to give it a separate video
so in here
let's just scroll up
and let's just look for that generic one
the arrest that status 500 and then
we'll just pass in the error
copy this one
and then scroll down
and below where we have the catch of
course pass it in so if i go back right
now to my postman and if i click on send
i should
get shaken big because of course that is
the id now if you don't believe me we
can go back to all the tasks let's keep
on scrolling and then i think i'm going
to be looking for this testing schema
because some of them are actually empty
when we were testing out that's when we
were setting them up so now grab this id
instead
go back to single task
and then copy and paste and of course
now the value is going to be testing
schema and like i mentioned previously
i'll talk about errors why we have two
of them essentially why we have two
responses for the errors in the next
video but that's how we can set up a
route to get a single item
so we go again with try catch we set up
async and then we use the static
function find one and then of course in
this case we're looking for the id
that has the value the same as in our
params if we can find one awesome we
send back that specific task
if not then we send back 404 and then
all the way in a catch block we have our
generic error okay so why do we have
these two responses
where we have four or four
with no task with this id and then we
still have the generic one well it's
simply because we can have two types of
errors
and in order to show you that we just
need to navigate back to the postman and
then notice where we have the params
where i set up this long id why don't we
try changing the last value so instead
of b that i have here i'm gonna go with
zero and once we send well we should get
the message no task with blah blah blah
id why well because of course
in our database we don't have any item
whose id is matching and i can clearly
see the 404 that means that of course
that that is our response but
if we change this around and then
instead of keeping the same amount of
characters we start removing or adding
you'll see this error
and the name of this error is cast error
so effectively what's happening
if we have the correct syntax for the id
but we cannot find the item then of
course we'll have to deal with it
ourselves because essentially there is
no task with this id but if the id
is actually going to have the wrong
syntax meaning it's not going to match
the amount of characters that mongoose
is looking for then of course we'll get
the error from the mongoose and like i
already mentioned this is going to be
somewhat common setup for us for the
upcoming controllers as well because for
both of them for update task as well as
delete task at the end of the day we'll
still have to find that one specific
item
and if we're not successful
then we'll send back the 404 but we'll
always have this generic one as well
just in case the actual syntax for the
id is totally off awesome i think we're
moving in nice space
and up next i'll actually work on the
lead task why well because with update
task
it's a bit more complicated and i kind
of want to leave it as the last one
because i promised you that i'll show
you the differences between put and
patch as well so therefore let's work on
delete now most of the stuff is going to
be exactly the same so once you're
comfortable with delete i think you'll
have no problem setting up update tasks
as well
and just to showcase in our application
if we go back to all the tasks
if you click on removing the task there
we go now of course we just removed the
task
and the setup is going to be very very
similar to getting the task of course
the biggest difference
is going to be the method or the
function that we're going to use and in
this case we're looking for find one and
delete
but everything else pretty much is going
to be the same so if you want you can
just copy and paste and change the
values but in my case
since it's going to be a bit more
productive why don't we type it out
together so i'll go with my sync we go
with try catch block now i have simple
res dot sends so i'll just remove it all
together then we want to look for that
id in the params because again setup
isn't going to be exactly the same
where we pass in the id with our params
and we'll call this task id
and that one is equal to rec dot params
then once we have access to params we
just want to go with const task is equal
to await
again task and then find one
and
remove or i'm sorry delete so find one
and delete and in here we want to pass
in the id again so underscore id and
that one is equal to our task and then
id
and then once we have the setup of
course then we have two options if such
task exists
then we send back r200
if the task doesn't exist so essentially
if this is equal to null then of course
we go with r404 and in this case i will
speed this up a little bit where i'll
grab the if condition
like so
and then as far as the response
initially i'm gonna go with a json
object and i'll set task equal to task
but at the very end of the video i'll
discuss multiple options that we have so
this is the 404 if we're not successful
again if that item doesn't exist with
that particular id if we are successful
we go with res dot
and then status
and we pass in 200
and then we just go with json and then
we pass in the task so essentially that
way in a postman we'll be able to see
which task we removed and then just like
the previous controllers we'll grab our
generic one as well
and set it up in the catch one so if
there is an error there's going to be a
message property with that particular
so we navigate back to the postman
and we're looking for delete task again
we have this dummy value in my case that
is peter but in your case it might be
something else so again we need to go to
get all tasks run it so now of course we
can see all our tasks and then just pick
whichever you want to remove and you
know what in my case i'm going to go for
those empty ones first because i don't
want them in my database anyway so i'll
go over here i'll grab the id and then
i'm looking for delete task copy and
paste and then once i save check it out
now of course i can see that i removed
this task and i'll remove another dummy
one as well so let me run it one more
time now i can clearly see that i have
only one without a name since i removed
the previous one so let me just grab it
over here
and then
back to delete task
copy and paste and then send
and of course i can clearly see that i
removed this one as well and just to
showcase again why we have those two
errors let's go back to all the tasks
let's send and i'll grab the first one
for shake and bake
and what you'll notice
is that if i pass in the id
and if i just change the last value
so i still keep the same structure
then of course we'll get our 404 so no
task with id and of course i have 404
now if i'll start adding or removing the
items
and of course what you'll see
is this error so of course this is
coming from our catch block hopefully
that makes sense and then lastly i just
want to mention that as far as this
response i purposely set it up here as a
task
just so we can see
in the postman because i think it's a
bit useful when we're setting up our
first api
but by any means you're not limited to
sending this type of response why well
because usually when it comes to
deleting a task
you're really not looking for the data
here take a look at our front end it
really doesn't care what task we're
actually removing
because the way the functionality works
is i click on a button
then i'm looking for a response and if
the server sends back this 200 then
right away
on my front end i go like okay awesome i
was successful so let me fetch the
entire list one more time so it's not
like i take that item and then i do
something about it no i just say i want
to remove the item if i'm successful
awesome i'll do one thing if i'm not
successful then of course i want to
display some error message or something
along those lines
therefore
if you go back and if you change this
around to for example and i'll just show
you some common ones that you might see
in the other apis so let me comment this
one out i'll copy and paste
and then as long as you go with 200 you
can simply even go like this you can say
send that's it that's all you have to do
and the functionality will still work or
you might see something like this where
again copy and paste
and then if we go with json
and some people just go with task and
then set it equal to null
and you might add a status property here
with
success
and as you can see sky is the limit i'm
just showing you what type of responses
you might get back because again the
main idea is that if you're successful
if you're getting d200
already on a front end you know what's
happening so most likely you're not
going to be looking for that one
specific item that you're deleting but
again in my case i just set up this task
so we can nicely see in a postman what
we're moving so i'll remove these two
lines of code here
and then i'll just set it back to my
json where i have task is equal to task
and as a quick sign out once we're done
setting up the update task route i'll
spend an entire video on various options
that you have
for your responses
so just put the pin on that and we'll
come back to it a bit later
all right and we have successfully
arrived at our last controller the
update task one and if we are
comfortable with getting the single task
and setting up the delete task we should
be in good shape because yes there's
gonna be a bit more functionality
because in this case not only are we
looking for the id
but we'll also need the body since of
course we'll be updating something
correct and then the second thing we
have to pass in some options since by
default we won't get right away the
validators working and also we won't get
the item that we just updated and don't
worry of course i'll talk about all of
that in detail so for now just to stay
consistent i'll move this sucker down
i'll move it below the delete task
and let's just start simply by accident
both of the things let's get the params
one and then the body one so we just
want to see that we are successful on
acquiring both of those things so i'll
set this up as async
it's just a simple send so i'll just
remove it
and we're going to go with try catch
and for now let's just go with arrest
dot and then status we'll set it equal
to 200 and then the json one and here i
want to grab two things i want to grab
my id
just double check that i'm getting it
properly from the params and also the
body so for now
above the res dot status let's set up
the id one more time we'll say id so
we're destructuring
from the rec dot params
rec dot params and second one is going
to be rec.body
and if you want you can assign it to a
data or whatever but in my case i'm just
going to set up the property here and
set it equal to directly so let's just
say id
is equal to a
task id and then data is going to be
equal to rec.body again why are we going
to be passing data well because if we're
updating something of course you need
that new info correct so if i go back to
my application and if i say that instead
of walking the dog i want to walk the
cat of course i need to supply this name
otherwise it's not going to make any
sense the same goes for completed i need
to pass in that key with the new value
and in this case of course it's going to
be false so once i click edit notice i'm
successful awesome so if i go back to
all the tasks now i have lock the cat
and in order to test this out again we
need to go back to the postman we're
looking for
getting all the tasks since i want those
correct ids
and
you can pick any of them doesn't really
matter i think i like the shake and bake
the most
so take this one
then we need to go to patch the update
task one
copy and paste and then in response we
should see the id correct we're not
gonna see the data since we haven't set
up anything here in our body at least
not right now but we'll do it in a
second but of course now we're just
getting update task
so let's see let me go back here update
task probably i didn't save the file my
apologies let me run one more time
and now i should see the id
that matches of course my shake and bake
but as far as data there's nothing there
why well because i haven't sent anything
from my front end right so now let's go
to the raw and then we'll set it equal
to the json
and then we set up our object and
remember we're looking for the name
and i'll just say testing
edit funk
functionality i guess and then we're
going to be looking for completed and
we'll set it equal to let's just double
check in here it's true so let's go with
false
and let's set it here of course now not
only i'm getting the id just coming from
the params but i also have the data
property and in there of course i can
clearly see those values again the whole
deal why i'm doing this is just so we
don't have to console.log on a server
and once we have all of this in place
now let's roll up our sleeves and
actually set up our functionality so
i'll remove this one we don't care about
this one right now and again we want to
go with the task meaning i'll sign up a
variable with the name of task and i'll
set it equal to await
and of course now we're looking for task
the model name and then find one
and if this one was find one and delete
what do you think is going to be this
one well it is find one and update
and in here we need to pass in a few
things first we need to pass in the
object where again we set up our
condition
so in this case again i'm going to go
with id matches to that one in the
params so underscore id equal to task id
that's step number one
then of course we need to pass in that
new data since we're updating something
correct so let's go here with comma and
that's going to be the second value so
essentially you need to set up the
object and set up which properties
you're updating but remember we're
already getting that as far as wreck
that body so reg.body is right away this
object so i can simply set up my next
parameter like so where i go with
reg.body and then we have options object
but i first want to show you what
happens if we don't use it and then
we'll add both of the values in there as
well so let's start here again by
checking the task because again we might
have a situation where there is no task
with that specific id
and again just speed this up or copy and
paste and then if we are successful then
of course i want to send back the task
i'll say task is equal to task
and don't forget the generic error where
we go to resdot status
and then you already know the rest copy
and paste
and you'll notice something interesting
since we don't have the options you'll
notice the following thing where
i go with testing edit function okay
that's awesome i completed false
but essentially what we're gonna get
back
is the original value so remember the
shaken bag
effectively this is what we'll get back
so once i send notice
yeah i get 200
so i was successful
but notice the value here it's shaking
big and what's more interesting that
once i click on getting all the tasks
it's actually changed
so i was successful so here's the gotcha
the reason why is that happening
is because we're not passing in the
options and as far as the options we
want to do two things we want to get the
new one back because by default we're
getting the old one that's why we were
successful
but in our update response we got the
old value and the second thing what
you'll notice
is the fact that we're not running the
validators so if you remember when we
were setting up the model
one of the things that i set up for the
name was required equal to true
now if i try to update item
with name
equal to an empty string i'm actually
going to be successful now again we're
getting back the old value and in order
to check the new one we just need to run
get all tasks
notice and i promise you i'll say this
for the last time in this video the
reason for that is because we don't have
the options object
and in order to set it up we just need
to go back to all the controllers and
like i said
third parameter is going to be our
options
and then we simply go with new true so
this will always always always return
that new item the one that is already
updated and then the another property we
can run is run validators and we'll set
it equal to true so once we do that of
course we fixed both bugs so if i for
the final time i guess in this video go
back to my post man and in here
i'm gonna go back to shake
and bake and we'll set the value
equal to true
we should see that right away so i can
see shake and bake and if i try to do
that
without passing anything in the name
then of course i'll get my big fat error
because when i was setting up the model
i said that name is actually required
awesome and believe it or not we're
actually done with our basic setup
as far as the api
and in order to showcase that i'll
simply go back to app.js
and then i want to serve my static files
because this is where my app is sitting
and of course since our api is up and
running we can simply set up those
static files the app and the
functionality should work and if you
remember in order to serve static files
we need to use another middleware and
we're going to go with app.use we'll
pass in express
and the name is static and then in here
we just simply need to say where the
static files are located and in our case
of course that is in the public folder
and let me just say that if your code is
exactly like mine
everything is going to work now back in
the app.js i don't think we need that
hello one anymore so let me remove this
one
folder out
i'll just leave the version one and then
tasks and then if i go to localhost 3000
and i removed that hello
i should see my app and i can clearly
see that these are all the tasks that i
currently have and if i want to add new
one i'm just going to say testing app
and once i add of course i have all the
way in the bottom a testing app well
effectively i have two
but we right away can also practice on
deleting so there it is now we can
delete the items
all the way to second task then if i
want to see the single task just click
over here notice now i have the task id
as well as second task and then
eventually if i want to edit well i just
click here on completed
and i'll say third task
third task
and if everything is correct we should
see task edited now i still need to fix
the css but as long as you see the
correct text you should be in good shape
now of course by the time you're
watching this i'll fix this but the idea
is following if i try to edit the item
without providing the name now of course
i'll get error please try again i just
need to fix the css more essentially if
i'm successful i still get this red
color and then once i navigate back now
these are going to be my task
if you're interested in the actual app
just navigate to the public one you'll
see that i used vanilla.js
just so everyone can be on same page
and essentially as far as the logic
you're looking for browser objects and
i'm not going to show you the entire
thing but as far as submitting the new
task i'm just listening for submit event
then i prevent the default i'm looking
for the value in the input
and notice that i'm using the axios
library
and check out the method
what is the method name
that is post why well because that's how
we can pass data onto the server correct
now what is the url
that should be familiar we have api
version one and then of course i'm
looking for the tasks and in here i pass
in the data
so unlike the postman where we were
doing that manually now of course i just
grab the input and i'll pass it in and
if you remember the completed was set
to false right from the get go so i
don't need to worry about that i just
need to pass in the name
and again everything is in try catch
so if i'm successful
then of course what happens well
then i add the correct alerts and all
that and then i just refetch one more
time tasks
now if i'm getting the error then of
course i'll add different alerts and
hopefully you get the gist
and just to lastly showcase the delete
one
if we scroll up a little bit notice the
method here and like i previously
mentioned the only thing i'm looking for
here is the response if everything is
correct if i have 200 awesome
i just refetch all the tasks if not
then there's an error and essentially i
don't remove it from my dom that's why i
said that technically when you're set up
for the delete
in most cases you're not going to have
to send back that item that you're
removing and now it's simply about
making this app better because yes we
have the core functionality in place we
can definitely test it out on the front
end and everything is awesome but
there's some things that we would want
to fix for example i want to remove all
these strike catch blocks i don't want
to repeat myself in such a way i also
want to set up one place where we're
dealing with errors and other
improvements so in the following videos
we'll make our app better so we have the
core functionality in place now we just
want to make it better all right and up
next i want to finally discuss put
method versus patch method
so why in this api in our routes we used
patch
and during tutorial we used put
so here's the deal yes put and patch are
both
are both for updating the resource but
the assumption is that when you use put
you're trying to replace the existing
resource
and patch is for partial update
and since i'm fully aware that this
might sound like mumbo jumbo to you let
me give you an example
so if we go to our postman
and then more specifically update task
if the id is correct
then only the properties that i'll pass
in
will be updated so in this case if i'm
gonna go with
shake
and bake number two
and i'll actually remove completed
only the property that is passed in will
be updated so if i send check it out now
i get the task and i can clearly see
that completed is there even though i
didn't pass it why well because that's
how our functionality is set up in the
controller
so if i'll pass completed and i'll set
it equal to false of course it will be
updated as well so if i go here
completed
and i'll set it to false yes in this
case since i'm passing the property of
course now i'm going to get the new
result
now what is the difference with put well
let me go the long route and actually
set up one more controller but keep in
mind that this is going to be just
temporary controller so if you don't
want you can just sit back and relax and
we'll start in our routes where
essentially i want to go with my route
and in this case i'm still looking for
this forward slash and then colon id
because again
the functionality is going to be almost
the same but i'm looking for a different
method and i'm looking for put and of
course now we just need to create the
controller and in my case eventually
i'll call this update or i'm sorry edit
task just so it's a little bit different
so of course i'm not exporting that yet
but i'll right away set it here in my
structure i'll say edit task and then
back in the controllers
i just want to go below the update task
again this is just going to be temporary
but i'll go with const edit and then
task and that one is going to be equal
to whatever i have over here we simply
need to add
one more option
in the find one and update so let me
select this whole thing just so we don't
have to type it from scratch and all the
way in the bottom
we're going to go with edit task
and like i said it's going to be
temporary so in here i'm not going to
save it with all my routes
but let me just save my current ones
and i'll close all of these windows and
let's set up a new route
so in this case it's going to be a put
route
and remember we have our variable so i'm
looking for url and then i'm looking for
the tasks
and of course i want to grab some kind
of id
so let me get
again all the tasks here
and i'm going to stick with shaken back
because i like that name so much
so let me grab this id here
then back in tasks i will pass it in
and then let's try to recreate the same
functionality that we have for now e in
the patch and essentially
what i really want is just to pass in
some data in my body so i'm gonna go
here with raw
again we're looking for json
and we'll set it up name
equal to john
nothing particularly original and once i
save of course now shaken bake has the
name of john but here comes the biggest
difference between put method that we're
using over here
and the patch method so idea with put is
that if i send only the name
my expectation
is that
all the rest of the properties which of
course in our case is just completed
will be removed from that item so we
will replace that item and how is that
going to look like in our controller
well here everything is going to be
exactly the same
but by default mongoose doesn't do that
so by default mongoose is going to be
like okay so you want to get the item
you want to update it awesome just get
me the properties you want to update and
rest of them will stay the same
and if i actually want to remove those
properties the ones that i'm not passing
in with my request i need to add another
option here and the option name is
overwrite
and we need to set it equal to true so
now you'll notice that back in my
postman
if i send here with name and let's just
keep it interesting and pass in peter
check it out we have name
and the complete is still there now why
it's still there well because in our
model we have default set to false so
there is some default one if i remove it
you'll notice that with output method
the way the controller works right now
if i send it right now then of course
i'll just get the name
so completed is not there anymore so if
i take a look at all the tasks now and
the first one actually completed is
missing so that is going to be the
difference where when we work with put
the expectation
is that we'll replace
the item so we'll just pass in the
properties that we want to set up in
item and then rest of them effectively
will be removed
but when we're working with patch we're
just updating the properties that we're
passing in just remember that in real
life you will see the apis where the put
method is used with the same
functionality as the patch now in our
case for the remainder of the project
we'll use the patch one instead so
therefore i'll remove this edit one
and here as well
and the same i want to do in routes like
i said
this is just for demonstration purposes
so save it here and i also want to
remove this route from my postman just
so it's not in a way so say don't save
and i'm back to my five routes and of
course for the update i'm using the
patch one and before we start
refactoring our code and adding some
extra middleware let's just spend a few
minutes on our responses
and more specifically on the other
options you have when setting them up
and i'll use get all tasks route as my
example just keep in mind that the same
goes for the rest of them
and essentially when i was setting up
the route i said that you have tons of
options here as far as the response so
in my case i'm just setting up course
djson object and then i set the property
tasks equal to tasks but you can also do
something like this where i'll copy and
paste
and i'm going to go with res.status so
this won't change we're just talking
about the object that we're sending back
and instead of simply just sending tasks
you could also add the amount of tasks
and for this property name of course sky
is the limit
whatever you want to come up with in my
case i'm going to go with amount but you
can also call it maybe value maybe the
number of hits or something along those
lines and here you're just looking for
tasks
and of course the length like so
and also what we could do and i'll just
comment these options out just so they
can stay for your reference
and let me copy and paste so i don't
have to type arrest that status also
what we could do well i could set up a
flag here where i say success
is equal to true and then of course we
need to keep in mind if that is the case
then you also need to add something here
where you have the error whether that is
404 error
or it's the general 501 so effectively
here i just add this extra bit of data
where i say yeah the success was true
and then you can even place it in the
data property and then say tasks
is equal to tasks and also maybe add the
amount so that's also something that you
might see around for example the hacker
news api uses the number of hits like so
essentially you just get that value and
again that is going to be equal to the
array that you're getting back equal to
a length and once i said of course my
response is going to look like this now
if you don't like the success one
go maybe with status that's also
something that you might see around
where we set up status is equal to
success
for the successful responses and then
for errors of course we're going to go
with status and then fail or error or
whatever string value you might want to
set up and if you're wondering why am i
showing you this is because i want you
to be aware of your options
so just because i'm setting it this way
where i just pass in the tasks of course
that's not a rule that's pretty much my
preference
and why i don't prefer setting up the
statuses or successes or the data here
that is simply because of the front end
so in my experience when we use frontend
there's two things that are going on
effectively when we have asynchronous
responses we already have try and catch
and because of that i find the status or
success to be a bit redundant because
effectively just like i showed you with
delete
if i'm successful then of course this
code will run regardless and then if
there's some kind of error then of
course i'm gonna have my code e in the
cache block and why i don't like setting
up the data well because on my front end
usually i use axios and if you're
familiar with axios it right away
returns a data property so it right away
has that data object so if you set this
response in such a manner where you have
data returned in the object then on the
front end you'll have
data
and then in that data object you have
another data so essentially on the front
end you need to do something like this
where there is a data object inside of
that data object there's another data
object and then you only get the tasks
which is of course not the end of the
world but in my case again i find it a
bit redundant
and lastly when it comes tutorials and
courses i also enjoy the fact that
there's less typing in the setup where i
just pass in the tasks so be aware of
your options my suggestion is whichever
route you pick just stick throughout the
api
so there's no confusion
don't set up one type of response for
one route and then go totally different
in a different route that's going to be
very confusing to whomever is using your
api and lastly let me just say this yes
you can set up your own api responses
however you like
but if you want our front-end app the
one that's sitting in the public to work
properly
the responses
have to be exactly the same as mine
because that's what the app is expecting
if you'll set it up willy-nilly then you
might get some bugs
not bad not bad once we have discussed
our response options
next i want to work on route not found
so at the moment
life is awesome we have our application
everything works if i go to index.html
of course i can see the application
if i go to api then version one and then
tasks of course i can see all the tasks
what happens if i go with api version
one
and then hollow so i have cannot get api
blah blah blah
and i can clearly see in my browser that
of course we get 404 error but
essentially this is going to be the
default one
and instead i want to set up the custom
one just like they have in algolia one
or again
if you're looking for some kind of
resource
and the server can find the resource and
essentially we still get the 404 but of
course the value here is unknown now it
doesn't really matter what you set up as
far as the value just want to showcase
how we can set up a custom 404 response
and the way we do that we go back to our
application here
and then in the app.js i want to remove
these comments
because i think we're clear on the rest
api
and location here is very important so
we have the middleware for public and
json that still stays the same
then we have all our routes for the
tasks
and then right after that we want to go
with app.use and then we'll pass in our
middleware function the one that will
handle the 404 and send some kind of
custom response now we haven't created
it yet
so let's go back to our starter we'll
create a new folder because there's
going to be a few middlewares that we'll
set up in the upcoming videos so say
middleware
and then inside of the middleware we
want to go with new file and i'll call
this one not surprisingly
not found and a js and as far as the
logic well we'll still have access to
erec and res so we just need to come up
with function name in my case it's going
to be not
found and i'll set it equal to rec and
res
and then as far as the response i'm just
going to go with res dot
then status and of course in this case
it's 404 so the server is letting the
user know that it cannot find the
resource and then as far as the message
i'll just use the simple send and i'll
say route
does not
and exist
so now of course we just need to export
this and we do that with module then
exports of course
and we'll set it equal to our not found
and then back in the app.js
above the app.users we're going to go
with const not found is equal to require
then we're looking of course e in our
middleware so let me say dot middleware
and then more specifically we're looking
in and not found and then in the
app.used we'll just stick not found one
and once we save and in this case i'll
just use the postman just so you can see
that it's gonna work exactly the same
and if we're looking for the url
and then we'll go with hello now of
course we have our custom one we have
route does not exist which is pretty
awesome and just to showcase that it's
going to be the same scenario in the
browser as well notice once we refresh
we have route does not exist so we set
up the middleware folder in there we
have not found.js and then back in the
app.js we import the function we set
some kind of name in my case it's not
found and then all the way in the bottom
we go with app.use and we pass in the
function and in that function we'll have
access to rack and res and in our case
we're just interested in response and
we'll set up a 404 with whatever message
we want to send back
awesome and up next i want to work on
asynchronous wrappers for all our
controllers why
well because we have asynchronous
operations
and yes it's very useful to use these
try catch blocks
but you'll have to agree with me that
it becomes somewhat redundant pretty
much for every controller setting up try
and then catch and as you can see
essentially i'm just copying pasting the
code around so there has to be a better
solution and that better solution is to
create a middleware function
that essentially we'll wrap our
controllers
and in there we'll just set up the
functionality where we don't have to
repeat ourselves and before we continue
let me just say that there are some npm
packages that do that for us
and most likely in the upcoming project
we'll use them instead since that way we
can save some time on the setup but i
think it's very important to have at
least a general idea of what the package
is doing instead of blindly installing
it and therefore in our first project
we'll set up the basic logic ourselves
and we'll start over here with new file
and i'll call this async js and then
inside of it i'm just going to go with
const
async wrapper so i simply create a
function
at the moment nothing is happening here
and then i want to export it so module
exports
and then a sync wrapper
and once we set up the export now of
course i just want to go to my
controllers
and import that middleware so i'm
looking in the middleware and i'm
looking for async so in here let's just
call this a sync
wrapper again and that is equal to
require
then we navigate to our middleware
folder and of course we're looking for
the async
and now what we want to do
is wrap
all of our controllers now i'm not going
to wrap all of them right away i'll just
start with get all tasks just so you
understand how it is going to work so
what we want to do here is just to take
this async wrapper this function
and just wrap our current controller
and essentially it's going to look like
this where we go with a sync wrapper
and we pass in the controller the
current controller
as an argument and since we know that we
can do that in javascript we are in good
shape so we pass it in
and then back in the async
of course i need to set up the parameter
so since i'm passing in already in the
controllers my function my controller as
an argument back in my sync js my
middleware i just need to go with some
kind of parameter now you can call this
callback you can call this function it
doesn't really matter in my case i'm
just going to go with fn
and what am i trying to do here well i'm
trying to avoid this try catch so
essentially i want to have my cake and
eat it too where i can still use this
nice await syntax
but i don't have to set up these try
catch blocks how can we do that well we
set up the try catch blocks inside of
the wrapper
and the first thing that i want to do
from this function
is to return another one so in here i'll
say return async
and then if you remember
in the express by default we right away
got request response as well as the next
so that's what i'm trying to do over
here since i wrapped my controller
in my middleware and if you pay close
attention we're actually invoking the
async wrapper right away now of course i
want to pass in those request
response and next down to my function
down to this controller correct because
now of course i wrap my controller in my
middleware and the way we do that we
return another function since i'll use a
weight inside of the function body
that's why i set it up here as async and
please please please keep something in
mind where these ones the wreck res and
next we'll have access to right away
because at the end of the day we return
another function from async wrapper and
then inside of the function body one of
the things that i want to do is pass
these rec res and next
from express down to this function so
hopefully that is clear again we get
these ones by default the reason why we
have access to them because from our
async wrapper we actually return another
function so that's how we'll have right
away access to them and then in the
function body we'll decide what to do
with our parameter
with our argument which is our current
controller and as far as logic i want to
go with try catch block and then inside
of the try block i'm going to go with a
weight
and function and here we'll pass in rec
res and next
and then once we have passed all of
these things down to our controller of
course now have access to them in here
as well and there also since there might
be a case for an error we'll go with
next and then we'll pass in the error
and if you're wondering what's happening
over here essentially we're passing this
to a next middleware which we haven't
set up yet e in our app.js so that's
what's coming up in the following videos
we'll set up another set of middleware
and in this case we'll deal with errors
so once we save over here we can go back
to the controllers and now i can remove
the try catch block so remove the try
catch block completely and at this point
you should only have these two lines of
code where we're waiting to find all the
tasks and if we're successful we send
back those tasks and as far as the async
wrapper we take our controller
as a argument
and then since we return the function we
have access to rec res and next that are
coming from the express
and we set up the try catch block and in
here we have a weight because our
controller is still async and we know
that by default a sync function will
always always return a promise so in
here i just have a wait and i'm waiting
for that promise to be settled either
resolved or rejected and since my
controller will still need to access
rack res and possibly next since i get
them from express i pass it down to my
controller
and then if there is an error so in here
if we trigger some kind of error whether
in get all tasks or any of the
controllers then of course we'll catch
it over here and we'll pass it to a next
set of middleware which we haven't set
up yet and now of course once we have
everything in place now we just want to
apply these changes to all the routes
now i fully understand that some people
are very negative about refactoring the
code and to some degree i sympathize
with that because i also hold the
opinion where it's not very useful if
we're all the time refactoring the
application
but it was important for me to show you
the long way first because that way you
have a good understanding of how
everything works and now we just set up
the middleware that actually handles
that so let's go back to the controllers
and slowly but surely let's add this a
sync wrapper to all the routes and the
setup is going to be following for all
of them where we start with a sync
wrapper so we set up our two parentheses
here and we need to make sure that
second parenthesis the closing one is
right after the curly brace correct
then we want to remove the try block as
well as the catch block
and again we'll be just left with wait
does that create if we're successful we
send back the task and effectively we
want to do that for all our controllers
so let me go here with a sync wrapper
same deal
wrap this guy here
and then we have try
and we remove the catch but we are
leaving this one
so i will work with this one a little
bit later for time being we'll leave it
as it is with this response and once we
set up our custom error there's going to
be some changes here as well let's keep
on scrolling we're looking for the async
wrapper
and again we want to add the closing one
right after the curly brace we still
pass in the function i'll remove my try
i'll remove my catch here
and we'll save it and the same goes for
updating a task as well so we go here
with async wrapper
and we'll close it
then
we want to remove try
and we want to remove catch
and just to try it out why don't we go
to create task
and then i'm just going to go with
creating task creating
task let's try it out
everything still works i can create my
task but if i'll try to add a task with
an empty string value i should get the
error and i do but of course this is not
the error that we're sending so that's
something that we're going to work on in
the upcoming videos and once we have set
up the async wrapper next i want to work
on catching the errors and we're going
to start our journey actually in the
express documentation so go to
expressjs.com and then in search box
just type error and first let's take a
look at the default one and if you take
a look at the first sentence express
comes with built-in error handler that
takes care of any errors that might be
encountered in the app this default
error handling middleware function is
added at the end of the middleware
function stack
and if we pass in error to the next
and you do not handle it in a customer
handler it will be handled by the
built-in one why am i telling you this
well because that answers this question
where is this response coming from well
that is coming from the default built-in
error handler that's point number one i
want to make otherwise you might be
wondering well where are we getting this
info second next correct that's why in
the async wrapper we set up this next
and error so we passed it to the next
middleware but in our case of course we
haven't set up that handler yet so
therefore it was just eventually passed
down to the built-in one and lastly if
we go back and if we say here error so
i'll search one more time and in this
case we're looking for
writing error handlers so this is what
we're about to do we'll set up another
set of middleware however in this case
the middleware will handle errors
and you can see that if we want to
handle errors we just pass in
four arguments and then the first one
will be that error and then we want to
place that at the very end of our routes
so let's just navigate back and of
course in the example they showcase how
they right away set up the middleware in
the app.js
in our case since we'll have more code
essentially i want to create another
file in the middleware so in here i'm
just looking for new file and i'll call
this error
and then handler and inside of the file
i just need to come up with the function
and i'm going to go the long route where
i'll say error
handler
middleware and that is equal to error
again in this case we need to have four
parameters request response and we also
have next and as far as the logic we'll
add more code once we set up our own
custom error class but for time being we
just want to go with return
and res that status and if you remember
that's exactly what we had previously e
in the try catch block and i'm just
going to go to 500 and we'll say json
error and error is equal to error now if
you want you can cancel log it of course
but the result is going to be exactly
the same where in here we'll have access
to that error the one that is going to
be coming in our case from this async
wrapper and then we just need to decide
what we want to do and i'll just start
by setting error equal to error and
you're not actually
i want to go with message is equal to
error and now we simply want to go back
to app.js
where we have not found let's just copy
and paste and now we just need to come
up with a name and as you know naming is
probably the hardest thing in
programming so in my case i'm just going
to call this error handler and then
middleware and of course that one is
coming
from the file that we just set up the
error handler and then we want to scroll
all the way down and right after not
found we're going to go with app.use and
of course we'll pass in the error
handler middleware and once we save and
we go back to the postman and try to
send the same request
meaning the request with a incomplete
data then we should get a different
response but we don't effectively it
looks like i have a bug so let me check
the error handler and yes of course i
didn't export the function so let me go
with module
exports and that one is equal to a error
handler one and of course if i test it
out right now i should see the custom
response and we can clearly see that
because we have the message now like i
already mentioned previously if you
don't like these big massive error
messages you can simply go back over
here and instead of setting the message
equal to an error you can just hard code
some kind of message so you can go
something along the lines of something
something went
wrong
comma try again
later
this is what we'll see in postman again
we send and now of course our message is
shorter so essentially this is how we
can set up a custom error handler in
express where we add another piece of
middleware and then in there we have
four arguments and the first one is
going to be the error and of course in
our case the way we pass the errors down
to this custom error handler is by using
the hsync wrapper and there we have the
next so as you remember from tutorial
with next we pass it to the next
middleware and previously we used the
built in default one and now of course
we have our own where effectively you
can set up whatever logic you want if
you want to send this as 200
nothing stops you from doing that but of
course a more meaningful response would
be with some kind of error code and with
some kind of meaningful message whether
that is hard-coded string or you can
pass in the entire error object and
right after we set up our custom error
handler let's work on our 404 responses
too
and essentially i want to set up a
custom error class
which extends from the general
javascript error class and that way we
can handle all of our 404 responses in
our newly created error handler as well
and we're going to start by navigating
back to the controllers
and the routes or controllers that i'm
looking for are following i want to work
on update task
here we send the 404 then the same is
for deleting the task
and of course getting the task
and let's just start over here
with getting the task
and simply i want to showcase that we
can create a new error object
if we run the built in javascript error
constructor and we go here with const
and no surprise i'm going to call this
error and that is equal to new and then
we just go with error and here we pass
in the message
so i can say not found
and then next line i'm just going to go
with error so now i'm dealing with the
object that i just created and i'll set
another property on it and i'll say
status so that's the name of the
property and of course the value will be
404 so now
if you want you can console log it here
or what we can simply do
is use next
and pass this guy
down to our custom error handler
remember that's how it works we call
next and then we pass in the error and
of course in this case we are creating
that error ourselves instead of getting
it from the mongoose and the only thing
that's missing right now
is in our controller
because we don't have the next so i want
to go here with next
and then we need to go with return again
i already mentioned why we want to do
that because we don't want
javascript to keep reading the code now
of course we have this one right now but
hopefully you get to just where we need
to go with return and then next and now
of course i want to pass in my newly
created error object
and once i do that
if we go back over here in the error
handler and if we simply cancel log we
should
see our newly created error object so
i'm going to go here with console.log
and i'll look for my error
and now let me go back to the postman
and essentially what i want to do i want
to get all the tasks
and then i'll look for one of the ideas
but again i don't want to get that cast
error so i still want to keep the same
structure i just want to pass in the
wrong value so i'll look for single task
i'll copy
and paste and then instead of three i'm
gonna go with four so once we send of
course we get our custom error message
as vague as it currently is
and then of course in console i can
clearly see that i have
not found so of course that is going to
be my message and i understand that it
might be a bit confusing but effectively
the idea is following where once we
create this new our object that property
is going to be on there so in order to
access the string value we'll have to go
over here and simply go with error and
then that message and as far as the
status well we can clearly see it here
we're going to have 404 so now just for
kicks what we can do
is set up message is equal to error
message like i said
there's the property on that object and
then as far as the status well i can
simply change this one around where
instead of 500 i'll pass in error and
then status and don't worry of course
there's more code coming and once i have
applied these changes of course we can
swing back to our postman and check it
out now of course we have 404
and then the message is not found so
that's pretty cool
now of course we just need to go back to
the tasks
and set it up in such a way where we
don't have to do this all the time
manually and the idea is following where
again we'll create a new class a new
custom error class
and we'll extend it from the javascript
error
and then we'll create a new instance and
yada yada and effectively the way we
want to do that we want to create a new
folder and i'll call this errors
pretty self-explanatory so we're going
to go here with new folders and
we're going to go with errors and inside
of it i'm going to create another new
file and in this case i'm going to call
this custom
and hyphen error and of course i'm going
to add the js extension
and then instead of my custom error now
i want to extend from the error class
now here's the deal in this case i'll
just write out the code and then i'll go
line by line of what's happening because
i think that's going to be a bit more
productive so let's go here with class
and then we just need to come up with a
name in my case
i'm going to go with the long one i'm
going to say custom
api
and then error now we need to use the
extends keyword and since i want to
extend from the error class i'm going to
go here with error and as far as the
functionality we want to go with
constructor and here we'll pass in
message
and status code
and then inside the constructor we want
to call super
then pass in the message and right after
i call super i'm going to go with this
dot status code
and i'll set that one equal to whatever
i'm passing in the constructor so in
here i'll pass e in the status code and
as far as these few lines of code a
constructor method is a special method
we invoke when we create a new instance
of a class
and in our case we'll pass in two
arguments an error message and a status
code then since we're extending
basically we're setting up a child class
we need to call supermethod which in
turn invokes a constructor of a parent
class
and in our case we pass in our message
value
as a result we'll have access to all the
methods and properties of the parent so
in our instance we'll have the message
property and with this dot status code
we create a status code property as well
and that's how we can create our new
custom error class and essentially if
you want to create new instances you can
simply go with custom and then api error
and then pass in those two values the
message and status code but i actually
like to set up a new function that does
that for me
and here i'm going to go with const
create
custom
and error and this function is going to
be looking for two parameters a message
and then a status code
and what i'm going to do is from this
function i'm going to return that new
instance so i'm going to go to return
new and then we're looking for custom
api error and then of course we'll pass
in the message here
as well as the status code now of course
if you want to keep the same parameter
names you can definitely do so but in my
case i'm purposely setting this up so
you can see that this is coming from the
function as far as the message and of
course i pass e into my custom api error
more specifically in the constructor as
a message
and then of course we just need to
export this and we'll have to export
both of them and you'll see in a second
why so we're going to go with module
exports is equal to an object and then
we're looking for create custom error
and then custom api error and once we
have both once we have the class as well
as the function and we're exporting both
now of course we want to go to the tasks
we just need to remember that of course
we're exporting object
so therefore we'll have to provide a
specific name in our case i'm looking
here for the function so i'm going to go
with const i'll set up my curlies and
i'll say create
and then custom
and error so of course that is my
function set it equal to require i do
need to go two levels up
so in here we're looking for the errors
and then more specifically i'm looking
for the custom one
and then i want to replace
all of these three instances and of
course i want to remove this manual code
as well
so start over here
and then i'll keep this one for the
second just because i want to reuse the
same message and the idea is following
where we go with return
then next and then instead of the next
we pass in create custom error
and of course we want to pass in the
message so that's why i'll just copy
this one just because i want to speed
this up
and then the second thing is going to be
my status code which of course is going
to be 404 and now we can remove the
second line
and we just want to copy and paste
so it's the same deal over here
and the same in the update task as well
and once we have all of this in place
now we just want to go to error handler
so our custom error handler and instead
of looking for the function we're
looking for the class because in here
i want to check if the instance is equal
to our customary one then of course i'll
pass in the status code and the error
message however if there is any other
error then of course we'll just go with
res.status 500 and whatever we had
before so let me go at the top and i'm
going to go with const again it is named
import so we're looking for custom
api and then error and that is equal to
require
and same deal we go two levels up we're
looking for errors and more specific
custom error
and let's right away set up the default
one and this one i'll set it back to 500
here and then as far as the json let's
go with the same message i'm just going
to say something
went wrong please try again
and above this return we're going to go
with if
and then we'll check if the error is the
instance of our custom api error
then of course i want to go with return
and i want to pass in the res dot status
and then that will be equal to a error
dot status code because of course that's
where the value is sitting in that
property and then when it comes to the
actual message same deal i'm going to go
with message and this will be equal to
error and then we're looking for the
message property and once we save let's
go and test it out or essentially
if i send it here from the postman of
course i'll have no task with this id
and if i'm going to mess with the syntax
i should get the cast error which of
course i do because i can clearly see
that something went wrong please try
again
lastly let me just repeat one more time
that error handling and validation
is something we're going to return to
later most likely in a separate project
this is just a general setup just to get
you comfortable with overall ideas and
later we'll work on more complex
validation and error handling approach
nice i think we're done with error
handling at least for now
and now let's talk about deployment
and right off the bat i want to say that
we're not going to deploy this project
simply because we have not covered
authentication yet
as well as extra packages for security
and deploying the project where anyone
can tinker with all the data is somewhat
irresponsible
and it actually can lead to a lot of
headaches
but with that said there is something
deployment related i want to cover
and that is our port variable
you see hard-coded value like port 3000
or 6000 or 7000 is decent solution in
our local environment but when it comes
to deployment in many environments the
host so the platform where the project
is hosted on may want to independently
set the port value to whatever makes
sense to the platform because as you can
imagine it needs to handle more than
just one application at the time
and in order to make that possible when
it comes to port value
instead of hard coding to 3000 6000 or
whatever we'll have to use the port
variable that is available in
process.env instead
and setup or operator just in case it's
undefined
and in order to set that up we need to
go to our port variable that's why in
this case we set it up as a variable
and then before d3000 we actually want
to go with process
and then dot env and then we're looking
for the port variable so we go here with
port and then if it is set then of
course we'll use that value if not
then we'll use the or operator and then
of course we're going to go with 3000
now of course in a local environment by
default it's not going to be set so
always go back to the 3000 however once
we deploy it's going to be a different
scenario now if you want to test it out
in local environment you can actually do
so and we do that by stopping the server
and then we want to go with a port
and we set it equal to whatever value
you want now my case i'm going to go
with 5000 because i believe my final one
is using that so i'm going to go with
6000 and then you want to go with node
and then what is the name of the file
you want to run of course it is app.js
and now check it out in a console we
should
see six thousand now of course i still
see three thousand because i didn't save
the file my apologies let me stop the
server
just so you don't think that i'm messing
with you and let me run the command one
more time and now of course in the
console i can see server is listening on
port 6000 and one more time as far as
our logic we just say set port to
whatever is the environment variable by
the name of port
or 3000
if there's nothing there
awesome congrats on completing the
project and i'll see you next one all
right and welcome to our next project
the store api
where we'll learn the advanced filtering
sorting and dynamically populating our
database as well as bunch of other cool
stuff
while i did not create the front end for
this project just because it seemed like
an overkill the idea is following
imagine we're in charge of store api and
we want to provide a bunch of search
options for our users everything
starting with search by name to
filtering based on price amount
since we'll cover all the options in
great detail during the project i won't
do it right now
but i do want to showcase where i got
the idea from and how that would look
like in real life and it's probably not
going to be surprised if i tell you that
i got this idea from the hacker news api
and if you remember they offer quite a
few search options for their user now
we're not going to implement all of them
but we will mimic the major ones and as
far as how it's going to look like in
real life if you took my react course
you probably worked on a store project
and during that project we built the
entire search functionality on a
front-end
now imagine once we're done building our
api the front-end only needs to make
http calls and we send back the data
so the same result user can still search
for products but only this time the
backend does all the heavy lifting and
frontend is only responsible for http
calls so the user can still search for
products whether that's based on name or
category or company and of course you
can read the rest
but the difference is of course that now
the front end only makes the http call
and then the back end does all the heavy
lifting and as far as the project setup
again we've got two folders final one
and starter one and of course the final
one is for your reference and the
starter one is where we'll do all of our
work
and just like in the previous project
when it comes to final in order to run
it you'll need to complete some extra
steps first not just npm install
and of course i'll cover all that during
the project as far as the starter most
of the things should look very familiar
since we covered them in the tutorial as
well as the previous project
and you'll also notice that in order to
save some time on a boilerplate
i already prepared a folder structure
for you
now when it comes to files
most of them are empty since that's
going to be our job during the project
but the folders are already there while
i understand that some people like
creating everything from scratch since
we're going to be building quite a few
projects in my opinion there's very
little benefit to repeat all the steps
every single time
all right and once we're familiar with
the setup now let's kick things into
gear
and of course let's start working on a
project and the first thing we need to
do
is install all dependencies
and we do that by navigating to the
starter so again big picture we're
looking for
fourth project
so zero for store api and then more
specifically the starter
and i think the fastest way is just
typing cd
and then take the folder
drag and drop and of course we're
sitting in the folder
and then we run npm
install
and while the project dependencies are
being installed let me just mention that
in this project we will set up
everything from the scratch just like we
did in the previous project
just so we can keep on practicing on
getting our project off the ground but
starting with the next project
some of the boilerplate code the one
that we'll type in this and few of the
following videos will be already
prepared for you since that way we can
right away cut to the chase
and don't waste our time on stuff we
already covered
and once the dependencies are there then
of course i just need to check the
package.json and i can clearly see that
the command is
npm start and of course we just spin up
the nodemon so we go here with npm start
and we are in good place now of course
let me navigate to the app.js
and here let's start adding the code
and the first thing that i want to do is
get that package in the env so i have
access to environment variables because
of course again we'll connect to our
database and we simply do that by typing
require then we're looking for dot env
that's package name and if you remember
we invoke config now of course we
haven't set up the env yet the file e in
the root of our project but we
definitely need to use the dot env
if we want to access the variables and
of course we'll work on that envy once
we actually start connecting to the
database then i'll add a comment of
async errors
and you'll see why i do that in a few
videos and then of course we want to
spin up the express so we go here with
const and express is equal to express of
course so i go here with require and
then express
and then once i have the package then of
course we want to spin up the app so we
go const app is equal to express and
then of course we invoke it now i'll
start listening for the server a little
later
now i just want to import two middleware
functions that we set up e in the
previous project and those are error
handler so this one over here
more essentially we just catch all the
errors and then we decide what is going
to be our response and then the second
one is not found because this is going
to be the case where i don't want to
repeat the same stuff we already covered
in the previous project
so that's the code that i already
prepared for you and now we simply need
to import both of them and come up with
some meaningful names
in this case i'm going to go with not
found
and then middleware
and that is equal to require and of
course i'm looking in the middle or
folder
and then more specifically we're looking
for that not found one then we'll copy
and paste and then just change the name
where instead of not found we're gonna
go with error and of course the file
that we're looking for is also different
and i called it error handler and once
we have both of these imports in place
now of course we can set up the express
json middleware as well while we're at
it and you know what in here let me just
add middleware comment and then like i
said we're going to go with app.use and
then we'll pass in the express
and we're invoking json then we'll set
up our one lonely route for time being
and essentially this is just for testing
so let me add here routes eventually of
course we'll set up the router and all
that but for time being we're just gonna
go with app.get we're going to be
looking for the home page meaning the
forward slash and then we'll set up rec
and res so of course our callback
function and here let's say rec and res
and as far as the response i'm actually
going to be cheating a little bit where
i'm going to go with res.send
and then since i can pass in some html
i'll say heading 1
and name of the project store api
and of course now i want to close my
heading 1 and then also i want to set up
a link
that will navigate to the products page
the one that we haven't set up yet
and here let's just go with ahref and i
guess more correctly the product route
because technically we'll be sending
json it's not going to be a page and
here we go with forward slash api and
then version one products
and i'm purposely keeping this api in
version one just because we already have
the global variable in a postman and
then as far as the text let me just
close it here and then close the actual
tags
and then we'll say product route so that
way if we ever need to we can just
quickly
navigate from the browser as well so
let's save this one and let's keep it
going and in here i'll add a comment for
product
route that we'll set up in the upcoming
videos and then i want to use both of
these middlewares so we have not found
an error middleware and i simply want to
use app.use but make sure you do that
right after the app.get so we'll say
here app.use and first let's just look
for not found one and then we'll do the
same thing with the other one as well so
pass here error middleware then i want
to set up my start function
but initially i'm not going to use that
connectdb so simply just go with
app.listen but we'll place it in a start
because of course eventually we will
connect to the database so let's just
start over here start
and it's going to be async
and then as far as the function body
let's just go try catch
and then eventually we'll connect to db
connect db but for time being we just
simply want to go with app.listen
and then what is the port well we need
to create that port variable
and if you remember the end of the
previous project effectively we'll set
this up dynamic where we'll go with
const port is equal to
process
dot env online port if it is undefined
then of course we can hard code this
value
and i believe that in my final one i
have 5000 so i'll keep this one as 3
000.
and then we'll pass in that variable
here the port one and then of course
let's set up the console.log just so we
can see that everything works
and here we'll just say server
is listening
to the port and then whatever
is the port variable
so let's say you're here
port
and then i'll add those three dots and
then if there's an error of course we'll
go with console.log and the error and
now finally we can just invoke start
and if you can see in a console
server is listening on port 3000 then of
course we are in good shape and if you
want to test it out in the browser just
navigate there look for localhost 3000
and of course this is what you should
see the hearing one as well as link now
we don't have the route for api version
one product but we can nicely test r404
since we can see the route does not
exist text and if we have all this in
place now of course we can move on to
our next topic and once our basic
express server is up and running next i
want to connect to our database
and if you remember we just need to
navigate to the atlas
and then we're looking for connect
so that is going to give us that
connection string and of course we'll
have to supply here the proper values so
let me just grab this one
then we're going to navigate back to our
project and of course i'll right away
set it up in dot env so in the starter
make sure it's in root we're going to go
with new file and then we go
dot env here and then once we have the
file then of course we want to create a
new variable and since it is a common
practice to call this [ __ ] uri we'll do
the same where we'll say [ __ ]
underscore uri is equal and now of
course we copy and paste
now as far as the database i'm gonna
call my one zero four and then store api
essentially the same as the project name
but sky's the limit you can choose a
different name of course as well and
then as far as the password since i
changed from my silly one two three four
now of course i'll freeze the video so
you don't see what is my real password
and then once you add your own password
then make sure that you save dot env
that's a must then we want to restart
the server so in my case i'll stop the
server with control c and then again we
go with npm start and then once
everything is in place now of course we
just need to go back to
app.js and i just want to showcase that
of course the function is already there
so the only thing you'll need to do
is just to invoke it in appdress of
course you need to require it and then
pass in the connection string with
proper values and since we already
covered all of this setup in the
previous project essentially there's
really nothing new that we can learn
over here i already prepared all the
code so we simply need to grab this
function
and then pass in the correct connection
string so let's go back to app.js and i
guess we'll do that somewhere at top so
right after app and before the
middleware we're just going to go with
const and again i'll name it exactly the
same connect db and that one is equal to
require we're looking in the database
folder and then more specifically we're
looking for connect
now this function of course returns a
promise that's why we set up start with
our sync
and then right above the app.listen i'm
just going to go with await connect db
and then of course i'm looking for my
variable the one that's coming from the
dot env and i simply go here with
process and then dot env and then of
course the variable name was [ __ ]
uri and if you see in a console server
is listening on port 3000 then of course
we are in good shape and we can move on
to our next task and once we have
successfully connected to the database
next i want to set up two routes for the
product
and you'll see why we have two routes
essentially the idea is that one of them
the first one
is just going to be for manual testing
and then since i want to keep on
practicing on setting up the router
we'll do just that and up here i can
notice that i actually have a spelling
bug
or this should be route and then right
after the home route i'll set up my
router and i'll do that using add.use
and then i just need to come up with
that base path or root path for the
router and in my case like i already
mentioned i'm gonna go with api
version one and this is gonna be looking
for the product and like i mentioned
when we're setting up this route i
simply add this api in version one
because that way it's easier in postman
since we already have that global
variable and effectively in here we want
to pass in the router
but in order for the router to work of
course we'll have to set up the
controllers as well therefore we'll
start in the controllers the file is
already created for you and the name is
product
and for time being we'll simply set up
two functions and we'll just send some
dummy data back
and two functions are going to be
following we're going to go with const
get all
products and the first one i'll call
static now this is going to be async
since of course we will use the methods
that we have on the mongos
and here let's look for rec and res of
course and then as far as the function
body for time being simply want to go
with res dot status
and i'll set it equal to 200 and then as
far as the response i'm going to go json
and then instead of the json i'll pass
in the object and in here there's going
to be a message property and then we'll
just write products
testing route now let me copy and paste
this
and then we just want to remove that
static part
and we also want to remove the testing
one so this is going to be actual route
and then of course we can export this so
let's go with module exports and this is
going to be my object and here i simply
want to pass in both functions so get
all products and get all products static
so we set this up then of course we need
to navigate to our routes so in here
this is where we'll set up our router
and then we'll start by getting the
express so const express
is equal to require
and then we want to pass in the express
of course again and then once we have
that let's set up the router and if you
remember the syntax is following where
we go with router and then we go with
express
dot and then with the capital case we go
with the router and then of course we
invoke it
then i want to import both of these
functions from my controllers and i'll
right away use the structuring so go
with const and then the name is get all
product of course and then get all
product and we'll add a static one and
that is equal to require
then we're looking in controllers and
then of course the file we're looking
for is the product
and then if you remember we have
multiple options and in this case i'm
going to go router route and then i'll
go with forward slash so essentially
this is going to be
for that main route here the api version
one and product
and as far as which controller i want to
use i'll use this get all products and
please don't mix them up again the
controller you want to pass in is
get all product
and as far as the static one let's copy
and paste and then we'll just add that
here at the end so this is going to be
our main path or root path and then
we're going to go with forward slash
static and this is where we want to pass
in that get
all product static
and then once we have this setup in
place now of course we just need to
export this so look for module exports
and of course we'll export our router
and once we have set up the routes then
of course let's just finally navigate
back to the app.js of course we do want
to import that
and come up with some kind of name and
in my case i'm going to do that right
after the connectdb and we'll just say
const and i'll name this product
router and that is equal to require and
then i'm looking in the routes folder
and then more specifically you want to
get the product
and then let's keep on scrolling and
where we have app.use
for our middleware now of course we'll
pass in our router so let's just say
here
products and router and once we save
i'll spin up the server one more time
and if you want to test this out let's
just navigate
back to the browser so i think you can
close this one
and then
at the moment it says route does not
exist but once we refresh
check it out of course now we have
message
product route beautiful and then if we
want to test out the static one well we
have product testing route and once we
have all of this in place now of course
we can move on to our next task and
since we have both of our routes in
place i think it's an awesome time to
actually set up a new collection e in a
postman and of course set up those
routes as well so in here i'm just gonna
save pretty much everything from the
previous project
close all the tabs here i'll say yep
save changes and what i'm looking for of
course is the new collection so i'll say
here new collection then i'll right away
rename it
and i guess i went for edit should i
went for rename
and then we're gonna go with or at least
i'm gonna go with zero four and then
store
and then api
and then in here we'll set up two routes
basically one for the product the api
version one and then product and the
second one for the static one so at this
point i think i can close these tabs
here and we're looking for new request
now both of them are gonna be get
requests
so let's go over here url
and then we want to go with double
curlies and then we're looking for the
products
let's send
and check it out of course we have
product route beautiful again save as or
you can simply click on command s
and this is going to be get all
products okay awesome we're looking for
store api let's save it over here and
now let's just add that static one as
well and i'll do that by opening up a
new tab again same thing get route and
then we're looking for the url one
and then once we have the url
uh the products and then of course the
static one as well
so static here let's send because now we
have product testing route and as far as
the name
i'll just call it that i'll say
get all
products
but i'll say testing
and once we have both routes in place
now of course we can move on to our next
topic
and once the postman is ready to go
and before we deep dive
into the mongoose now let me showcase
something in our application
where if you take a look at the
middleware you'll notice that
there is no async wrapper
and if you remember we needed to use
something
either we set up try catch pretty much
in every route correct or of course the
other option was using that async
wrapper
but when we were setting it up i also
mentioned that there are packages that
do that for us and that's why if you
take a look at the package json you'll
notice package the express
async errors and essentially the only
thing we need to do is just go back to
app.js and then where we have a comment
for async errors
just import the package that's it that's
all you have to do so let's go over here
acquire and then of course we're looking
for the package name of express async
errors and just to stay on the safe side
i'll stop the server
and i'll spin it up one more time
and now you'll notice that if i go back
to the product one
and or i'm sorry the products in the
controller i'm actually going to close
the routes i don't think we'll need that
anymore as well as the app.js we're
pretty much
done over here and then if in any of the
controllers you'll go here and throw the
error which you'll notice that will
actually be able to access that error in
our custom error handler and essentially
what that means is that whenever
mongoose
is going to spit back that error unlike
the previous time where initially we set
up trying catch and then we built our
own async wrapper in this case the
package takes care of that so in here
let me just go throw
and i'll call this new error
and i'll say testing package or testing
async errors whatever you want testing
async
errors
and just to showcase that in the error
handler i have the console log for the
error and of course in here i'm sending
back some kind of hard-coded message so
first what i want to do is from the
postman navigate to my static one just
to showcase that of course we are
catching those errors nicely with our
package and then i'll cover the package
in more detail so let me go back to the
postman
unfortunately it's all the way on the
left-hand side so there's a little bit
of jumping here and i'm looking for the
static one i simply wanna invoke the
route and now check it out something
went wrong please try again and if i
navigate back
all the way here in the bottom i should
see error testing async errors and if
you're interested in finding out more
about the package just go to google and
type express async errors and of course
one of the links is going to lead back
to their docs and effectively if you
want to use it in your own project just
go with npm install express async errors
then we keep on scrolling and notice how
the only thing we need to do is to
require it and then we're good to go now
one thing you probably noticed that i
did not use next and essentially the
reason why i didn't do that is because
if you read their docs they say that
instead of using next we simply need to
throw a error and of course since i can
see the error in the console that means
that i am getting that error in my
custom error handler so the
functionality still works so long story
short instead of setting up try catch
instead of setting up our own middleware
we effectively just used a package that
does all the work for us and as a result
we can eat and have our cake too meaning
we get the benefits of just using
asynchronous code and we don't need to
worry about setting up try catches or
our own middleware and the package name
that does that for us is a sync express
errors and we simply need to require it
in the app.js and once we have discussed
async errors
next let's set up the model
and before we go anywhere let me just
mention that i will keep this console
log just because i want to showcase some
stuff here and there but of course
if you don't want it you can just remove
it or you can maybe pass in the error
over here where you have the message
like we did in a previous project that
is totally up to you
now let me just navigate to complete
project and you know what i'll make this
one all the way on the left
and what i want to showcase is that of
course we have the products
and what do the products have well they
have some kind of properties correct now
featured rating created that and of
course you can read the rest
and in order to set it up what are we
going to need we will need a schema
correct and using schema we'll set up a
nice structure for our data and we
already know how to do that
so of course we just need to create a
model and therefore we'll right away
have a
models folder and in there we just have
the empty product js and in here we need
to start by getting the mongoose
and of course i'm looking for my
mongoose package so we go here with the
require
and we're looking for the mongoose then
we want to go with our schema
and i'm going to call this product
schema so that's going to be the
structure for my product and i'll set it
equal to new mongoose
and then of course i'm looking for to
schema
and then in here we want to pass in the
object and this is where we'll set up
the properties so this is going to be a
good refresher on how we can set up the
properties as well as the validations
and the properties i want to set up are
following i want to first go with name
and now we'll have a type
of string
then we want to go with required and
remember we had multiple options and one
of them was setting this up as an array
and the first values of course is going
to be true or false and then the second
one will be that custom error message
and here we go with product name must
must be provided
and then in order to save a little bit
of time i'll just grab this whole thing
copy and paste at least once and then
the second property i want to set up is
the price and of course this will be a
number
so let's go over here
say number and then as far as the error
message let's just say product price
must be provided after that we want to
set up a feature property
and we simply do that by going with
featured that's the name of the property
again we'll set it up as an object and
then type is going to be equal to our
boolean and then by default we'll just
say that all the products are not
featured so that way of course we don't
need to worry about whether the product
is featured not we simply set all of
them as false then we want to go with
rating now of course if you do provide
featured as true then of course it will
be featured but by default all of them
will be false hopefully that is clear
then we want to go with rating and now
we'll be equal to a number so we're
going to go here with type
number and let's just say that as far as
default value it's going to be 4.5 again
if the number is provided of course that
value will be set up as far as the
rating but
if there is no number then there is a
default value
and then we want to go with created at
so essentially this is just going to be
a date when this product was created
and what's really cool that in mongoose
we can use date type and we can actually
set the current time and we do that by
creating the property created at we set
it as an object and then instead of the
object let's go with type and then date
and then if we want to set up the
current time we simply go with default
and then we go with date dot and then we
invoke now so now of course every time
we'll create that new product if we
don't supply the created ad by default
is just going to be a current time and
then we have company and company is a
little bit interesting
where essentially if you take a look of
course we have the name for the company
but when you're adding the products what
we want to do is set up some kind of
guardrails where we can only provide
specific companies
and if you're interested how that would
look like in a real project so imagine
the scenario you have the product and
then as far as the companies these are
your possible values that's it it's not
like i'm just gonna randomly add here
trader joe's or lucky donuts or
something along those lines
and the way we can set that up in
mongoose is following where we need to
go with company here and of course i'll
set it up as an object then as far as
the type yes it's going to be a string
but if i want to limit the possible
options
for this property then we go with enum
property and then in this array we
provide those options and in here of
course you can provide whatever values
you want now i strongly suggest
adding the same values as me because in
the next video we'll dynamically
populate our database and if your values
will differ then of course you might get
the bugs and companies that i chose are
following
so i went with ikea
or in some places in the world they're
also called ikea which is very very
weird and then let me check the other
ones so i have this one then let's keep
scrolling i have this one
and you know what in order to avoid
confusion i'm just gonna avoid actually
pronouncing them
then we have this one
and then let's add a comma again copy
and paste and of course in here i added
those double quotation marks which is
probably not something i want and then i
have the last one let's keep on
scrolling this one over here
so those are the four values that i
chose and again for your own project you
can set it up however you would like but
since we'll be adding those products
dynamically in the next video so we
don't need to add them one by one i
strongly suggest using the same values
now what's also really really cool
is the fact that we can set up a custom
error message
if the value doesn't match any of these
items in the list and the way we do that
is actually following where i'll comment
this out just so it stays for your
reference and we actually set it up as
an object here and then as far as the
possible values we go with values
property and of course we still use the
same values and when it comes to custom
error message we go with message and
then in order to access the value that
the user is providing meaning the one
that is coming in with a request
the syntax is following where we go with
curlies and then value so essentially
that will access whatever the user is
providing and then we want to go with
some kind of message and in my case i'm
just going to say is not
supported and once we save we have our
schema ready to go so now of course we
just want to set up our model so we're
going to go here module export
and we'll set it equal to mongos
model
and then as far as the name i'm going to
go with
product
and then i want to pass in my schema
which of course is the product schema so
product schema over here and once we
save we're ready to move on to our next
task
and once we have our schema and model in
place
before we can start setting up any kind
of functionality of course we need to
have data
otherwise how you're going to set up any
kind of filtering if you have no product
in a database and effectively we have
two choices you either can set up a post
route and then just manually add them
or a better approach is just to automate
this
and essentially just have some kind of
list and pass it on to your database now
lucky for you
if you take a look at our project you'll
notice the product json
and essentially this is just a list of
products just so we can start working on
the filter functionality and the only
thing we need to do is set up populate
js
where we'll dynamically add all of these
values to our database so instead of
going to manual route we're one by one
we add them we'll right away just add
them to our database by actually
invoking the populate.js and the way
it's going to look like we're going to
go over here we'll first grab our dot
env so let's say over here dot env then
we want to go with config
and then what's really interesting that
we need to have another connection so
yes we have one for app.js of course
that still stays the same but since we
want to connect to the database one more
time we'll have to grab that connect
function as well
and here i'm just going to go const
connect
db because that is coming from where
that is coming from our db folder
correct so we go here with db
and then more specifically connect
that's the first thing we want to grab
then we want to grab the model and
you'll see why and we just need to come
up with the name in my case i'm going to
go with product
and then of course we're requiring that
it is coming from the models
and then more specifically product
and then lastly i want those json
products
because that's the data that i'm going
to be passing on to the database so here
we need to come up with the name in this
case i think i'm going to go json
product
and we'll set it equal to require
and where the file is actually sitting
right next to us so just go with forward
slash and then we're looking for product
json and once we have
all of this in place we want to set up
that start function one more time
however in this case of course we're not
going to be setting up app.listen we
simply want to connect to the database
and then use the model to automatically
add those json products the one that we
have in the file to our database and the
way it's going to look like we're going
to go here with const and start
and we'll set it equal to a sync
and in here we'll set up another try
catch like so so let's go try catch and
of course eventually we'll invoke it
here as well
and then i want to go with my await
then we want to pass in the connectdb
and of course inside of the connectdb
we'll pass in the process
dot env and of course our variable so
[ __ ] and then underscore uri
and just because i want to see whether
we're going to get some weird bugs i'm
also going to type in the catch a log
so go over here with log and then we're
going to be looking for the error and
once we have all this in place we can at
least try the connection now there's
still some code that's missing but we'll
get to it in no time so first what i
want to do is stop the server over here
and then we just want to go with the
start invoke it and then in this case
i'm not looking for nodemon i'll simply
go with
node and then of course i'm looking for
the filename so since i'm already in a
starter i just need to write populate
and then once we run it
if our connection again is successful we
shouldn't see any errors in the console
now if you want to help yourself out of
course you can just type here log
and let's just say success or something
along those lines so let's say here
success
and an exclamation point let's save it
one more time again let's stop it and if
you remember from tutorial in order to
go back to the last command we simply
press arrow key up or down in micros i'm
going to press it down and check it out
now of course we have the success so we
successfully connected to the database
now if i want to check out the error
i'll comment out the dot env stop the
server one more time sorry about the
detour but these things are important
and then once we run it of course we're
not successful connecting to the
database because
the uri parameter is not provided
awesome so let me uncomment the env
then clear everything and once we have
successfully connected to our database
there's two things that i want to do
first
i want to remove all the products that
are currently there
and then i want to use the create and
just pass e and the json product so if
you remember in a previous setup and i
think i'm just going to go for final
and let me look for controllers and
tasks notice here this create we passed
here a object correct when we were
creating that task
now what we can also do is pass in the
array so if you take a look at the
product
and i'm sorry not this one products json
you'll notice that this is an array at
the end of the day and then since this
is an array what i can do i can just
pass this in
into the dot create
and then by doing so of course i'll add
all of these products to our database so
let's try it out let me navigate to the
populate one
i have the json product i'm in good
shape so now let me go below the await
but before the success
and in here i want to go with await now
i'm not waiting for the actual response
and i want to go with my model
because model has all those functions
and then we want to go with delete many
so now i just want to remove all the
products that are currently there of
course
in our case there are no products but
i'm just making sure that later if you
want to reuse it then whatever gibberish
you added or whatever data you currently
have you just remove it and then you
start from scratch this is technically
optional if you don't want to do it you
don't have to but in my case i always
like to start with scratch and then we
want to go with a weight
and then product
product and then remember the function
create so now we're just dynamically
creating a bunch of product by passing
in json products that's all we have to
do here we go with json product
and now let's try it one more time and
then of course we'll double check in our
application so in here i'm going to go
back to my console and then i want to go
with node and populate and if i'll see
the success then i know that i'm heading
in the right direction so now let me
just go back to my atlas one let me
refresh
and now where i have my collections i
should have more values
and effectively i have the store api
awesome and in here i have of course all
the products now i'm not sure how many i
set up it really doesn't matter if you
see these products added to your
database now of course we can start
finally setting up our filter
functionality
and while we're still on topic actually
no there is a method by the name of exit
now why that would be useful in our case
because well let's think about it so we
have our popular js
if we're successful
then we might as well just terminate the
whole process
correct i mean we don't need this file
to be running
and if there's an error then again we'll
exit but maybe with a error code
and the way we set up the process.exit
is simply by navigating to the start
here and then probably right after the
success
we'll set up a process again that is
that global variable that we have access
to then we go with exit and that's the
method name and then if we pass in zero
that just means that everything went
well and we're just exiting the process
however if i take the exit method and
pass it in and of course in this case
since i'm running it in the catch i want
to pass in error code i'll pass in one
and then let's do it one more time i'll
clear everything and i'll not test it
out with an error but let's just go here
with node populate and now you'll notice
that once we're successful we actually
exit the process why well because we
have process dot exit and of course the
code in this case that we passed in is
zero and if you want to double check
your data just navigate back to the
atlas and you'll see that all your
product data is still there
and once we have dynamically added
products to our database i think i can
just close the popular js
at least in my case i'm not going to use
it anymore the same goes for product js
and then the rest of the work will
pretty much do over here
in the controllers
and the first thing that i want to
showcase actually this is a refresher
where essentially if we want to search
for a product in a mongoose meaning for
some kind of items in our case of course
that is product well we need to go with
find method correct so let's just go
over here
i'm in the mongoose docs and i'm looking
for the queries
and then we'll keep on scrolling keep on
scrolling in this case they show the
find one example but the idea
effectively is the same that if you go
with find
and of course if you pass in the mp
object
then you'll get all the documents and of
course in the object you can also pass
in some options and if you go with
properties then you just need to provide
what value you are looking for so in our
case if we take a look at our model over
here in the product js well these are
all our properties correct whether
that's name price featured and yada yada
so in here let me start up my server and
then back in product.js i want to get
the model because of course we'll go
over the basics first where i'll start
by just getting the product and that is
equal to require
and i'm looking for my model again
so i'll go two levels up and then i'm
looking for the models
and then the product and then let's
start in the static one so i'll do a
little bit of work here i'll show you
the manual approach and then in get all
products well this is where we'll set up
the real functionality the one that
we'll use in our project and then we
already know the asynchronous so that's
good and now let's just start by saying
const product and simply let's take a
look if we pass in the empty object so
in here let's go with weight and then
product that's the name of the model and
then find and like i said let's just
pass in the empty object and then
instead of the message
i'm just going to go here with product
and then let's test it out in a postman
so i'll go back to my testing one i'll
send it and i should see
my array of products and if that is the
case then of course we're heading in the
right direction now
if i want to be more specific
if i want to say hey
get me
the product where the company is equal
to this one or get me the product where
the name is equal to this one or maybe
get me only the featured one then of
course we simply need to go back here
and where we have the object well i can
say
featured
featured
and then this is going to be equal to
what true or false so let's just pass
intro
and then let's run it one more time and
what you'll notice in your static route
only the products
that are featured are going to be
displayed and you know what i think in
this case it is going to be very helpful
if i'm just going to go with those
number of hits
and i'll set it equal to my array
because that way you can right away see
if you're getting the correct set of
data so let's go over here and in this
case it says something went wrong and of
course because for some reason i decided
to add number of hits in the find and
this is actually something that i'll
cover later why we get those errors and
how to avoid them so let me remove it
this was pretty much an early taste what
kind of errors we're going to have so
let me run it over here where i have the
json response so don't be like me be
better than me and don't pass it into
the find pass it actually where you are
sending the response and let's go back
over here let's send and of course i
have the products and all the way at the
bottom i have number of hits is equal to
seven and if you'll take a look you'll
see that
all the products have featured set true
and you can probably already imagine
that if i'm just going to go here with
name
and of course we can combine them and
again this is something that we'll cover
in more detail in next videos so
therefore i'll remove it and i'll just
start with scratch i'll say name is
equal to whatever i have here my
apologies i copied the wrong thing
if i have multiple
tables and for some reason i just want
to look for this one i can just pass e
in the value where i say yeah get me the
product
but the name property needs to have this
value and now of course once we send i
should get only one
that's the only one that has the
matching name hopefully we're clear on a
basic setup so now of course we can
start implementing the get all products
where the setup is going to be more
complex than just hard coding the name
or any of the other property values all
right i think we're solid on filter
functionality so now let's splice things
up and implement the dynamic approach
since it's highly unlikely that we'll
send our responses
based on hard-coded filter values
and first let's start with our requests
more specifically query params because
that's how we will get our data
and in order to jog your memory on query
string params let's go back to my
favorite api at least for this course
of course the api is hacker news by
algolia api
and once we navigate here
once we start scrolling and everything
and looks like i'll have to refresh you
can see that of course we can get the
items we can provide the route params
that's clear but if we keep on scrolling
notice of course
now we can start searching for some data
and how do they set up the search well
they have the domain
then of course they have some kind of
endpoint that ends with search and then
they have a question mark
and after the question mark we have key
value pairs which essentially are query
string parameters and then of course
based on what you're looking for whether
you intercept the query or you want to
look for different page
then you pass in the value and hopefully
you get the correct result and as far as
our setup we first need to understand
how we can send those query string
parameters from the postman correct so
let me open up the postman and then of
course i'm going to be looking for get
all products
so i'll just leave the testing one as it
is so essentially in there we'll just
hard code all the time
but back in get all products not only
i'm going to be looking for the product
but i can go with question mark and then
of course i can add key value pairs now
we have two options either you can type
it here for example you could say
name is equal to john and notice how
right away they're being added in this
table as well so that's the second
option where if you don't want to do it
in the url
you can just set it up over here and
what's really cool
you can actually check and uncheck them
and what that means is that if i go here
with john and then of course i send
again the name
and if i don't want to send it then i
can just remove it and if i want to take
a look at the featured ones and of
course this is going to be featured
and as far as featured i want to start
with true and then once we send of
course now we just get back the message
but if we take a look at our controller
we should have access to those key value
pairs in rec dot query so let's test it
out i'm going to go with simple
console.log just so we can see that
we're getting data and it is sitting in
rec
and query and let's do it one more time
from the postman so let's send it again
we get back the hard coded result but
take a look at our console of course i
can see that i have the object and then
in there i have key value pairs
with whatever i'm setting up in a
postman and once we have jogged our
memory on query string parameters now we
simply want to go back to the postman
and i'll just use the featured
and i'll show you in a second why i want
to do that and then i'll send it of
course and if i take a look at my app of
course now i only have featured so now
let's set up the logic
where i'll remove the console log
and then we'll still be looking for the
products
and we'll use define of course but in
this case
instead of hard coding
instead of setting up the object and
then passing in whatever key and then
the value of course will pass in
directly direct.query now we will
refactor the code because there are some
gotchas we need to be aware of but with
the most basic setup we'll pass the
query directly into the find
and let's hope that we'll get some
results so let's start the same way
we'll go with const products
and that is equal to await
and then product
then dot find and like i said we'll
directly pass in rec
and query
and of course once i get back the
results i want to also send them and
then in this case i'm going to remove
the message and i'll just say the same
thing where i'll pass in the product
as well as the length of my array so
that way i know how much i'm sending so
let me go back and then one more time
from the postman and again the route is
forward slash product
not the testing one and now i just pass
in featured because that is one of the
keys that i have and as far as the value
i go with true and then once we send
check it out now of course we have the
product
and the amount of items is equal to
seven so if i'll change this to false
now of course i'll get a different set
of values again let's just quickly cover
the logic where we have access to query
string parameters in
reg.query and since we get back the
object we can directly pass it into the
find one and then since in this case i'm
looking for
featured
and i'm setting it equal to true that of
course returns only the products that
are featured and then if we pass into
false then of course we'll get only the
product where featured is set to false
not bad not bad i think our basic setup
works pretty nice or there are some
gotchas we need to be aware of
what do you think is going to happen if
in a query string params we're going to
pass in some kind of value that doesn't
match any of the values that we have
currently in the model so remember when
we're setting up the model we have name
price featured and yadi area but what
happens if
i send with my request a page
which essentially we'll do because
that's one of the functionalities we
want to add and i guess the best way to
showcase that is just by going back to
the postman and here of course i still
have featured set to false now you can
leave it you can remove it that's really
up to you what i want you to do
is go below featured and then just add
another key value pair and then in this
case go for something that is not in our
data so in my case i'm going to go with
page because like i said we use that
later anyway and then you can come up
with whatever value you want and of
course i want to check it here and also
as a side note just notice the syntax so
if you're going to be setting this up
manually in the url just remember that
in between them you need to add this
ampersand of course postman is already
doing that for us but if you're setting
this manually just don't forget so now
once i send
check it out of course i have no values
why well if i navigate back
and take a look at my product what
happens over here well i pass in
rec.query directly correct and without
even cancel logging we already know that
we have a object
with featured set to true or false that
is really irrelevant and then we're
looking for the page with some kind of
value
now mongoose of course is like well
listen i don't have
any product where there is a page
property and that is actually set to 2
1 or whatever so therefore if i go back
and if i do the same thing with the
testing one again i'll have zero values
back
so hopefully that is clear so yes this
probably is going to work with the most
basic setup but then
as your filtering gets more complex
there has to be a better approach and
that better approach is for starters
pulling out only the properties you want
to apply to the find now what do i mean
by that well i'm going to go with const
then i'll destructure from reg.query and
in my case i'm just going to be looking
for a feature of course eventually we'll
add more values but for time being i'm
only looking for featured so i can add
10 000 more items in here in a query it
doesn't matter i'm just going to be
looking for featured and if feature is
set to true
then i'll add it to define and once we
have successfully pulled out the feature
out of the query so now of course we're
only going to be looking for this value
instead of passing this directly into a
find a better approach is actually to
set up a new object so in here i'm going
to go with const and i'll call this
query
object and that is equal to a new object
and now i'll use the if and i'll say if
featured is true
then what i want to do is to set up a
new property
in this query object so in my new object
i want to set up a new property by the
name of featured so let's go over here
let's say query object feature that's
the property name and in here i'm going
to use the turning operator where i'll
say if the featured is set to true then
of course i'll set this property equal
to true now then of course e is going to
be false so let's go with featured and
then we're checking for true so let's
say over here true now of course we use
ternary operator and then if this is
true then we set it equal to true if not
then of course we go with false and once
i have this logic i'll save
and then instead of passing reg.query
what it will do will pass in the query
object and then since i want us to be on
the same page i'm just going to go with
console.log
and you'll notice that
first we only set featured so we're not
going to be setting the page and we'll
only do that
if it is actually passed e into the
query so if it doesn't exist so if the
user doesn't send featured then of
course this logic won't be applied and
of course this is just going to be an
empty object and then we get all the
items so let's test out one more time so
now of course i'm going to go back to
all the products and let's send and now
of course i get back the value of 16
because i'm looking for all the products
that are not featured but notice how the
page is not messing everything up so in
here i can clearly say yep featured is
there the value is equal to false and
this is the object that i'm passing e
into define but if we have a different
request
for example if there is no featured and
the user is only looking for the page of
course we're not handling the page
functionality we'll work on that later
but for time being what happens we get
all the products why well because we
have
empty object so hopefully this makes
sense instead of passing directly
reg.query we set up a new object and
first we just pull out the properties
we're interested so in my case i'm going
to be looking for featured i'm going to
be looking for name later on and
hopefully you get the gist and then
we'll check
if the property is actually coming in
with a request awesome we'll set up a
new property on our query object and
then of course there's also going to be
some kind of functionality in this case
it was just straight up turning operator
and then
instead of passing that property
directly we'll pass in the entire query
object and that way of course we can
avoid that bug that i showed you in the
beginning of the video
wonderful once we have the general
structure in place
so effectively
once we have the empty object and then
we check for the properties that
correspond to whatever we have
in the model now of course we can
continue and add more functionality to
our api correct so we want our user to
search based on name maybe also based on
price
as well as rating and company and all
that now i can tell you right away that
we will purposely work on the number
values so the price and rating and all
that a little later because probably
that's going to be the most complex
logic of this project for now i want to
work on name
and company now company should be
somewhat straightforward where we're
going to check for the company so say
hey
is the company property on myrac.query
and of course then we'll set up the
value in the object
and if of course we can find something
then we're in good shape if not and of
course we return nothing so let's go
back and the first thing that i want to
do is of course pass it from my postman
so in here i'll remove the page
hopefully it is clear what happens with
the properties that are actually
not on our model
and then let's set up a new one and here
i'll say company
company
and as far as the values well let me
check
since it's going to be faster so let's
say i'm going to go with this one copy
and paste and now i'm going to look for
both i'll say hey get me where the
feature is false and company is this one
so let me send it here and now what you
should see
is only the product that matches company
now of course not yet but that is the
eventual goal so let me navigate back
and notice again we only get the
featured why because that's my logic so
let's go back over here and let's say
that we're also going to be looking for
the company again not to be redundant
because this company corresponds to
something we have already in the model
otherwise we'll have that mess where
mongoose is going to be like hey listen
what's happening i cannot find anything
then of course we want to set up the
logic and this is going to be as
straightforward as it gets where
essentially i'm going to say if the
company exists
then of course i just want to set up my
property on a query object and the name
of course will be company and i'll set
it equal to my company the one that i'm
pulling out of here so once i save and
once we try one more time we should get
different amount of values and of course
in this case we get only six so now we
get featured false and company is equal
to ikea
now if i'm going to pass in some kind of
gibberish
i'm going to say that i'm looking for a
company bbb of course i'm gonna get zero
results but that's what we expected
so if we're looking for something that
doesn't make sense just of course the
user is not gonna be successful but if
the user provides correct company value
then of course we send back the list of
products that correspond to that value
and if you're wondering well where the
user
is going to know that info well that's
why we have documentation
so if you go back to this api you can
see how they clearly explain
what are our options and essentially how
we can work with the api so now of
course in our api we handle two things
we handle featured and we also handle
the company
and once we have the first two down i
think we already understand the pattern
so let's try to do the same thing with
the name
and we'll start with the most basic
setup where essentially i'm gonna go
with a name and then whatever value i'm
passing in meaning e in the query and
then eventually we'll come up with more
complex setup where we have the rejects
because at the moment we need to
understand that of course with our most
basic setup we're only going to be
looking for the product whose name
matches exactly now what am i talking
about well let me go back to the static
one
let me send it from here
and i just essentially want to get one
of the names and i'll look for this one
and what you'll notice that with the
most basic set effectively we'll get
only the product whose name matches
exactly so if i go here and if i send of
course now i get only one product but
if i mess it up here meaning if i just
pass in the first value
you'll notice that actually we get
nothing so yes
it's a good starting point
where the value needs to match exactly
but then of course we'll make it more
complex and add rejects to the mix
because that way we'll be able to just
pass in some kind of text values and
we'll get the product where that value
is somewhere in a name
so after my long rambling let me just go
back over here where we have get all
product and what is the property that
we're going to be looking for of course
that is the name and there's also
something that i want to mention where
nothing stops you
from setting up your own api and saying
here that you're going to be looking
for the search for example like they
have in the hacker's news api nothing
stops you it doesn't mean that these
properties need to match exactly now of
course i'm setting up this way because
it's much more easier later when i'm
setting up the object properties so
these ones definitely need to match
whatever we have in a database but as
far as what values we're looking from
the query this is really up to you and
again just to showcase that notice how
they in here use query so we can
definitely set up our own api
with a query or search or whatever the
only reason why i'm using the name
is because it's just going to be easier
when i'm setting up here in the object
hopefully that is clear and then let's
keep scrolling and we'll start like i
said with the most basic setup we'll say
if the name exists
then i want to go with my query object
of course name property and that one
will be equal to the name so let me
swing back to the postman and again now
switch to get all products
and since i'm just gonna get one value
since at the moment my name is gonna
match exactly i'll remove these ones
i'll remove featured and company and you
know what let me go to complete project
and that way i can get the name right
away and once i have the name now of
course i'm going to be looking for the
product
and we want to add a new key
and in here i'll call this a name
and then i'm going to be looking for
this value
and then once i send of course now i'll
get that one product and if we take a
look at our query object of course this
is what we have so we have a name and of
course whatever value i passed in and
since i have one product that matches
that that's exactly what we get but if
you take a look at the mongoose
documentation you'll notice that they
have these query operators now this one
we'll use a little later
when we set up our numeric filters but
with the name i actually want to set it
up as rejects and since mongoose is
sitting on top of mongodb we can get
those query operators from the [ __ ]
documentation so let's search for
mongodb query operators
then let's navigate here and as you can
see we have a long list of the operators
now the one that we're looking for is
this one the rejects one and essentially
the setup is following where we go with
rejects and then we have bunch of
options now the one that we'll use is
just case insensitive and then of course
we just need to pass
in the pattern so let me try it out back
in our application and i think i'm going
to start with the static one
just so i can show you the setup and
then of course we'll set up the more
complex one as well so let me go here
and i'll scroll above where i have the
static product and i'll just set up some
kind of value now since i'm not going to
be passing this with a query just
understand that eventually of course a
value will be coming from the query so
in here i'm just going to say const and
let's call this search and i'll just
type aaa
now where i'm looking for the name
instead of just passing in the value
directly we'll set it equal to an object
and then the setup is following where we
go with dollar sign and then i'm looking
for that reject query operator and then
as far as the value i'll pass in the
search again eventually it's going to be
coming from our query here and then i
also want to set up the options and
therefore i'm going to go with dollar
sign and then i'll pass in the options
and i'll set options equal to i and
you're not instead of 3a's why don't we
go with just one so let's save it over
here again the way it works we're
looking for name property but instead of
looking for
entire name instead we go with rejects
where essentially we're just looking for
the pattern and the way we set up we go
with rejects operator then we pass in
the variable which of course again is
going to be coming from our query and
then we have the options and in this
case i'm passing i which just means for
case insensitive and once we navigate
back to the postman and run it you'll
notice that of course i'll get all the
items where there is at least a a
and then if we're going to go with a b
now of course we're going to be getting
a different value so now of course i
only have 5. now in order to set it up e
and get all product what do we need to
do we need to look for a name we already
doing that and then where we have here
if name exists and then query object
name we simply need to change this
around where again you want to go with
this one instead and in order to speed
this up i'm just going to copy and paste
let's scroll down and let's just say
that if name exists then of course we'll
use the rejects instead now in this case
of course
the search doesn't exist correct so we
need to go with name so if you need to
pause it here and write it from the
scratch please do so because in my case
of course i saved a little bit of time
and just use the one from the static so
once we save again i'm purposely leaving
this one just so you can see what is
coming in and if we hop back to
all the products and of course now i'm
just going to go
with some kind of text value
that is less than the entire name in
this case i'm going to go with e
then i will look for the company
and why don't we keep the same one over
here
and then i'll also look for featured
anvils and notice how slowly but surely
now we can search for more options so in
this case i'm looking for featured set
to false company equal to ikea and then
of course e in the name i'm looking 40.
so i'm looking for the product where e
is in the name and then once i send
check it out now of course i have six of
them and if you'll double check you'll
notice that definitely e is a name the
featured is set to false and of course
company matches to the one that we have
in the query string parameters
beautiful at this point our users have
three options for filtering
featured company and of course the name
eventually we'll set up numeric filters
as well but like i mentioned previously
since it's probably going to be the most
complex thing in this project at least
in my opinion we'll implement that last
for now i want to switch gears and show
you how we can sort our data first in
final project then the general [ __ ]
setup and then of course we'll implement
it in our get products as well
and something to keep in mind sorting
does not affect the amount of items
we're returning
just the order
in which they are displayed
so let me navigate to my final project
and then as far as the sorting notice
right now
i'm just getting them based on a date
when they were created and of course
since we added them dynamically meaning
we pass in the entire batch that's why
of course pretty much
all of them are with the same date but
if i want to sort them based on name
what do i need to do well i need to go
to the url bar because of course i'm not
in the postman and then i go with
question mark and then i just need to
decide which property i want to use
and first i want to go to sort
and then let me zoom out a little bit
and of course we either can go with name
we can go with company we can go with
also price and all that so let's just
start here with the name
and then once i pass it in again i'm
going to get 10 values because i already
have the limit there but you'll notice
that the companies or i'm sorry the
product are going to be in the
alphabetical order so this is going to
be my first one then i have the second
one
and on and on and on now if you want to
sort them the opposite way meaning of
course now we go from a to z but if you
want to sort them z to a
let me zoom in here
and then you just want to pass in the
negative sign here so where you have the
name so that's going to be that
parameter that you're using and then if
you pass in the negative now you'll
notice that the first value is the
wooden table instead hopefully that is
clear now what we can also do
is chain them together so for example
not only i want to look at the name but
i want to also look at the price why
would i want to do that well
if i take a look at these ones where i
have wooden desk notice how the name is
exactly the same
correct
and the only difference between them is
the price so if i add here a comma
and then i say that i'm also going to be
sorting based on a price and since i
don't add the negative
i'm just going to be looking for the
smallest value first notice now i have
the wooden desk with 15 dollars first
and then i have one for 40. and you can
probably already guess i'm sorry for all
this zooming in and zooming out but i
just think that it's important that you
see everything that i type here if we go
with negative then of course what is
going to happen well we'll have one desk
but
the largest value is first now of course
i can just sort based on price then i
just remove the name and then if i go
with price notice again we start with
the smallest value and then you already
know what happens if we pass in the
negative
now as far as the setup
let's just go to the mongoose and i'm
actually here where we have the queries
and i'm looking for
i believe it was over here yeah so
general queries not find or refine by
the or any of these functions just
general queries
keep scrolling keep scrolling keep
scrolling and then in here they'll
showcase two options
that you can use now not for sorting but
in general for filtering we have two
options and we are using this one where
essentially we set up the entire json
but you also have this approach
available as well and this is again just
for your knowledge now what we're
interested is this
notice after defined what do we see over
here we see limit
sort and select and notice how they are
chained after defined
so first we set up our filter object
correct and we passed into define but
when it comes to limit sort and select
we actually need to chain them after
define and this is gonna become really
important a little later on when we work
with get all products so first i just
want to show you the manual approach
where we just go with sort but then when
we set up all the products the fact that
we need to chain them is going to be
very very important so let me navigate
back to our project and let's just start
with the static approach
so remove the search one not going to be
looking for name and in order to make it
interesting essentially i'm just going
to pass in the empty object just so i
can get all the product and then
remember instead of the method i want to
go with string
and i want to pass in the name so i'll
start simply with the name so if we
navigate to the postman again the static
now
and if we send a request notice of
course our response
is going to be in the alphabetical order
meaning we'll start with a
and all the way to w at the very very
end and as you can see i have 23
products now if i'll change this around
and if i'll say negative here
then of course once we send
check it out now of course we start with
the wooden table and same goes if i want
to go with price and syntax is following
where we want to create a space and then
we type in whatever property we're
looking for so in this case again we go
with a name but it's going to be z2a and
then we'll set up the price
of course that is going to be from the
smallest to the biggest value let me go
back to the postman let me send and of
course i start
with a w correct but
my price for the ones that actually
match
is gonna be the smallest one first so
the smallest price first and then the
largest one hopefully that is clear
hopefully we understand how we can set
up a basic sort so now of course we just
need to implement that in get all
products
nice and once we're familiar with
general info now of course let's
implement that in
get all products
and we'll start the same way we'll have
to pull this out out of the query since
i'm interested in that particular
property and of course the property that
i'm going to be looking for
is the sort one so if the sort is in the
query then of course we're good to go
but here comes the biggest gotcha
where if we take a look at our code
right now we are waiting
for this one to complete correct and
essentially when we go with this fine
one we get back a query object but
remember
in order to sort we need to chain this
correct we first go with find and then
if you want to implement sort we need to
chain it right after find now here's the
problem though in my current setup yeah
technically i can go here with sort
but again remember there might be a
scenario where the user is not passing
in the sort
so we want to do that conditionally and
the issue here is following where you
can say all right so i'm just going to
go with let products
and then i'll remove this sort from here
and then i'm just going to go with if
and then sort exist then of course i'll
set products
product equal to product
and then of course sort and then pass in
the value but the problem is following
where since we have this await
actually here in the product we don't
have any more that query object that is
going to be returned from the find one
we actually already get that list of
products so what i'm trying to say
that in order for this functionality to
work where we actually are chaining the
sort if of course it is passed in by the
user we need to remove this await and
the way it's going to look like instead
of setting up the products here we'll go
let result and then of course we'll have
multiple conditions in this case of
course we'll start with sword but then
there's also going to be one for fields
and we'll also set up pagination
hopefully that is clear and only then at
the very end we'll get the product
so we're going to go below the
conditions at the moment we have only
sort but make sure that it is always
sitting at the very very end and of
course in here i'm just gonna go
const product is equal to my result
and of course i wanna wait for it so i'm
gonna say here await
and then i'll remove this one so
hopefully this is clear where instead of
sticking the await over here since we'll
chain the sort and fields and limit and
all that at the very end of the query
object we're getting back
that's why we need to remove this await
because this right away returns those
documents and then set up the await when
we have the complete result and i think
at this point i can comment out the
query object and i think i'll uncomment
once we start working on numeric filters
and now let's just work with the sort
one so for starters let's just see what
we're getting back because that way
we'll have a better understanding of
what kind of functionality we need to
set up so let me just check it here a
sort and then we want to go back to the
postman we're not working in a static
one we want to go to all the products
and again since i want to get more data
i'm just going to remove just keep in
mind that of course
you can still keep them you can still
keep these query params as well because
you will get the correct data i mean we
saw that we're getting six heads but
since i want to have more product i'll
just remove them temporarily and we'll
come up with a new key and in this case
i'll say sort
so let's set it up here sort and then as
far as the values let's just start
simply like we did with name
and once we send let's just go back and
of course now i can see that as far as
my value i have my name
now technically we can right away set up
the sort and effectively we'll change
this to the result
but there's one gadget that we need to
be aware of
if we're sorting based on multiple
parameters then of course the value that
we can see in the console is going to be
different so if i'm going to go here
with comma and then price and you can
keep the minus or you can just set up
the price the result is going to be the
same or essentially now we have two
values meaning we have one long string
but inside of the string of course i
have both i have name and price and the
idea is that maybe the user decides to
chain i don't know three more correct so
how we can split them up so we can get
the correct values because if you'll try
to pass this e into a sort remember the
syntax is following where i want to go
with a space in between them e instead
of the comma so you're not going to be
successful now what can we do well we
can use the good old javascript where
essentially we'll create a variable i'll
call this sort list and that is equal to
sort and i'll split it i'll say that i
want to split it on a comma and then i
want to join it back together so
essentially i split it into an array and
then from the array i join it back
together in this case however just with
empty spaces and now what we want to do
is to go with result remember
that is the query object that we're
getting back from the find and we want
to set it equal to result
and then sort and now we want to pass in
this sort list in there
now what's also really cool is that we
can set up some kind of default one so
let's imagine the scenario where the
user hasn't passed in the sort key but i
actually want to sort it based on the
time when those items were created how
we can do that well we can simply go
with else
else and here we'll go with the result
and that is equal to result of course
again and we go with sort and now i'll
just hard code the value just like we
did over here however which property i'm
looking for well let's take a look at
our model
all the way in the bottom we have what
we have created that again since we
created all of our projects pretty much
at the same time technically you can
argue that in our case it doesn't make
much sense normally of course that's not
going to be the case that's why this is
going to work really nicely where we go
result and then sort and then we pass in
the string and i'm looking for created
add
and then once we save our functionality
should be working so let me try it out
i'm going to go over here i have the
sort one okay awesome and then once we
send of course we start with a products
that start with a
and then of course
as you can see we get the rest all the
way to w but if i'll change this around
and i'll say that i want to go the
opposite direction of course we can send
the request
notice again we have those two
that have the same exact name
but since we go here with this minus
price that's why we start with the
highest value
so effectively we have the descending
order but if we'll change this around of
course we'll have the ascending order
instead so that's how we can add the
sort functionality to our api
and once the sort functionality is in
place next i want to showcase how we can
select certain fields and i think the
easiest way for me to show you that is
going to the final project and then i'm
just going to go with fields so that's
the key please keep in mind that
something that i made up
the actual method name is different it
is select but in the query variables we
set up fields so this is just going to
showcase which fields we want to see and
as far as the values the same as with
sort we simply need to pass here the
properties that are in our schema and in
my case since i want to see
only the name property and only the
price i'll type
name price and hopefully you get the
gist
if you want to see some other properties
just add comma and then the actual
property so let's go over here and now
of course you can see that in my
response i only have the id which is
going to be by default as well as the
name and the price and if we take a look
at the docs we can see that the method
name is select
and again we have these multiple options
where if you want to go with just string
you can simply say select and then pass
e in the properties so let's try it out
in our static one
so let's move up we have the sort i
think i'm going to remove the sort for
now and we'll just say select
and then in here i'll do the same thing
i'll say
name and price
and once we go back to the postman which
is always tough because it's all the way
on the left hand side then i keep
forgetting that
now of course notice our response only
has these two properties it has the two
fields of
name and price and if we want to
implement that in get all products what
do we need to do well first we need to
come up with the name in a query string
again this is what i said before
where when it comes to the query string
you are setting this up because you'll
tell the user in docs hey
if you want to search for certain fields
then you need to add this property in
the query string parameter
if you decide that you'll call this
shake and bake you're in charge you can
definitely do so now in my case i'm not
going to be such a rebel i'm just going
to go with fields
then we're going to keep on scrolling
and right after this sort and you know
at this point i think it's going to be
very useful if i add some comments here
and then right after sort but before the
product would check for the fields again
we'll say if the fields exist
then we'll do the same thing where we
want to split them up
and of course join them back together in
the process we'll remove that comma and
then of course we just need to chain the
select method so in this case in order
to speed this up i'm just going to copy
and paste this is now going to be a sort
list we'll call this fields list
and then instead of sort we're going to
be looking for fields
functionality is going to be exactly the
same we split it up we join it back
together and then as far as the result
of course i don't want to sort it
anymore i want to use select and i want
to pass in the field list like so so go
over here and then let's navigate to the
postman and of course in this case we're
not looking for the static one anymore
we want to go with
all the products here
and then let's just add both of them
together so i have the sword i'll keep
that one and then i'll create a new key
i'll call this fields
fields and then as far as the values
let's just say we're going to be looking
for the company and also i just want to
see the rating over here so let's pass
these two and of course we'll notice
that we only get the rating as well as
the company in our response all right
and once we have covered how we can
select certain fields
next i want to show you how we can skip
and limit
and by using both of those things you
can actually set up a option for the
user to choose a page now how's that
going to look like well in our final
project we can go here with limit and
then just decide how many products you
want to get back and i believe again we
have 23 products so of course if you'll
go with 30 then we'll just get all of
them so just to showcase that notice of
course now we have 23 but if i'm gonna
go less so if i'm going to go with limit
and then for example four then of course
i'll get only four items and if i don't
pass anything in then of course by
default we'll get 10. that's where we
have number of hits and that is equal to
10. so hopefully that is clear and as
far as getting the correct page just
like they have over here where you pass
in the page and that is going to return
that exact page number we have to
combine limit with skip which is another
option we have and before we go any
further let me just showcase how is that
going to look like in our manual setup
so in here i think i'm going to stick
with select i mean
it can stay there it doesn't really
matter and then as far as limit we
simply need to go with a method and
again we chain it and hopefully by now
it's clear that ian get all products
we'll have to do that before we await
for the result and then in here we
simply need to pass in the value so if i
want to limit my response here to 4
then of course i can go back to the
postman now i'm looking for the static
one i send it and of course i'm only
gonna get four of them now if this value
is gonna be bigger than all the items i
have of course i'm just gonna get all
the items that i have in my list and
essentially skip works exactly the same
way but the difference is that it just
skips the first items in response so let
me just limit this by 10
and i'll make sure that we actually sort
a to z so that way of course you can see
exactly what we're getting back so let
me go here and i'll chain
that sort and i'm just going to be
looking for the name and of course now
we have a setup where we're
alphabetically sorting our responses as
well and in order to show you how so it
works first let's take a look at our
basic response so if we go here notice
i'm getting 10 items correct because
that is my limit and then i start with
this item and then i have the next one
next my next one so if i'm gonna go here
with skip
and for starters i'm just gonna say skip
one
notice that of course now we start
with our second item
so the item that was second in a
previous response and if we keep making
skip bigger you can probably already
guess that we're just going to be
skipping the items
in our response so now of course we
right away start with a letter b
and once we understand the manual
approach now of course we'll have to
implement that in get all product and
the goal is to use skip and limit to set
up a pagination functionality
nice and once we have discussed limit
and skip now let's see how we can
implement them to set up the pagination
and in this case i'm not going to be
looking for those values in reg.query
meaning i'm not going to structure them
because we'll set up the variables with
the same name so i think it's just going
to be easier if we'll go with rec query
and then the page as well as the limit
and all that so let's just scroll down
again we're working right now in get all
products i'll make this one smaller
and we keep on scrolling keep on
scrolling and then right after the
fields we want to set up three values we
want to go here with const and page so
this is what the user is going to pass
in
same as they have here
notice we go with page and then we just
set up the page number
now by default i do want to set up where
we get the first page that's why you go
here with page and then remember
whatever is coming from the rec.query
actually is a string and again just save
some time i'm not gonna cancel log
because we did the console.logs before
and notice page is actually two correct
but it is a string of two so of course
before we do anything we need to turn it
into a number so let me scroll back down
and then i'll do the same thing over
here where i scroll to the page and then
we'll start with the number and then
i'll say that i'm going to be looking
for rec query
and then the page now if the user
doesn't pass the value then i'll simply
use the or operator and i'm just going
to say that it is going to be equal to
one
and the same is going to be for the
limit i'll say that yes in the query
there might be a limit since again it's
going to be a number i need to use this
number meaning since i want this to be a
number but
it's going to be a string we need to go
with number and then we pass in rec
query and then limit and if no limit is
passed then we go with 10. that's why in
a complete project you'll see this one
where by default essentially we're just
getting back 10 products
hopefully we are clear on this one
so if the value is passed in awesome
we'll use this value if not then we have
some defaults and now of course we just
want to set up the logic
and the way we set up the logic we go
here with const skip and that is equal
to
page minus one and then we multiply this
by limit and i'll show you with actual
comment example just so we are on the
same page so i'll set up the skip and
now of course i just want to chain the
skip and limit to my result remember
we're still working on the result so
once i have
all of this functionality in place
then we'll simply go with result is
equal to and then we go with a result
and then we change the skip we pass in
the skip variable and then we chain
limit and of course we pass in the limit
variable
now it's going to be kind of hard to see
in our response so let me just set up
some comments just so you understand how
everything works so at the moment we
have 23 products correct so if i decide
to limit my response to only seven items
how many pages i have well we need to
divide 23 by seven
and effectively we'll have four pages so
we'll have seven seven seven so that's
going to be 21 and then the last page
actually is going to have
only two items so we have total four
pages
and the way the logic works
is following where the user will pass in
some kind of value
so maybe for the page is gonna go for 2
because remember by default it's always
going to be 1
and then we multiply this
by the limit that's the key over here so
if we just have a default page we'll
have 1
subtracted by one of course that is
going to be zero and then multiplied by
the limit still gonna be zero so
effectively we'll skip zero items and
then we'll just limit our response to
seven however if the user is going to be
looking for the second page then of
course we'll have 2 minus 1 so have
value of 1 and that is multiplied by the
limit so in this case since i'm looking
for page number two i'll skip seven over
here and then i'll have the limit of
seven so that's how i can see the second
page and in order to showcase that let
me just go to the static one
and i want to get all the items
just so you can see over here
and i think i'll keep this as
name and price like so and i'll sort
this based on name
and then let's do the same thing here so
let me send it this is my entire list
and then if i go to all the products now
let me set it up everything correctly
where i do want to still sort
and i actually want to start i guess
with a name
and then i'm going to remove the price i
don't really care about that i think so
i mean let me just double check so
select yeah so i'm only sorting by the
name
so let's see let's see so we have
products i'm only sorting by the name
and then when it comes to fields i only
want to see
name
and then price
and by default of course we're only
going to get 10 because we already have
that limit of 10. so therefore let me
add here
limit
and i'm just going to go with a limit of
30. of course that is way more than we
have the product so now of course i'll
have all the products if i check it out
here i have 23.
now if i'm gonna be looking for
page number two and i'll set up the
limit where i wanna see only the four
items or three or two or whatever then
of course you'll notice that in here
effectively we'll just skip whatever
items we have in a limit so in this case
if i go with limit off to just to make
it simpler and then if i go for page
number two
so here we'll pass in the value of two
you'll notice how we'll skip the first
two items and we'll right away go
for this one the albany sectional so let
me send it here
and check it out now of course we have
albany sectional and i purposely set
them up both the same just so you can
see how it works so now of course we're
looking at this page and as i'm changing
the limit i'll be changing how many
items i'm getting back and how many
items i'm skipping and then when it
comes to page of course it affects the
amount of items we're skipping as well
because if i go with three then of
course we will skip two times whatever
is the limit and those are the items
we're skipping and of course that is
going to return us that third page all
right we're almost done with the project
functionality the only thing left is to
set up numeric filters or in other words
provide a option for the user to search
based on the number condition for
example get only the product where the
price
is more than 30 or less than 30 and
hopefully you get the gist but since
there's going to be quite a bit of logic
i will split this up in multiple videos
and hopefully that way you won't be
overwhelmed now just to showcase how is
that going to look like i'm going to go
to my final project and in here i want
to go with numeric filters
and of course i'll explain why we have
this type of key
and then we want to go with whatever
property we want but of course it will
make more sense if we're just going to
go with the properties that actually
have numbers as values so in our case of
course we have price and then we'll go
greater than and then of course we'll
pass in the value
so since i'm not using sort it's
probably harder to see
but it's definitely only the product
where the price is more than 30. now
just to showcase that let's go with
ampersand let's add short and let me
zoom in
and then we're looking for the actual
value and of course in here i want to
pass a and d price so say here price and
then let's check it out what we have of
course we have 31 then 39 and on and on
and on so this is how our api is going
to look like
now as far as the mongoose we'll have to
use again
those query operators and in this case
for the greater one we go with dollar
sign and then greater than and the same
goes for less than but of course here we
type lt now i'll show you all the ones
that we're going to use in the next
video now let's just try it out
in our manual setup where we want to
navigate back we're looking for the
product
and at the moment i have fined so let's
go with price
so let's go here with price and we set
it equal to an object
then we're gonna go with the dollar sign
and then we'll pass in sorry not get
gt so that's going to be greater than
and then of course as far as the value
well let's set up the same 30. and once
we save of course and if we go back to
our static one we should i mean we
should let's see so at the moment i find
name price and for some reason
not returning any kind of value
so let me send it one more time there
must have been some kind of bug and now
of course i can see only the items where
the price
is more than 30. and just so we can keep
on practicing
i'm going to go with sort
and place here
price
let's see
so that should be the ascending order
and you can clearly see that we start
with the product where the price is more
than 30.
so that is the manual setup and that's
the general idea
and now of course we can start working
on get all products because in here
we'll have way more logic nice and
before we start typing away in get all
products let me just showcase where i
got the idea from and what are we
actually shooting for and it's not going
to be a surprise where
i'm using again my api and as you can
see here the key
in the query string is numeric filters
that's why we use the same one
and then as far as the options of course
they provide following so these are the
ones where they have numeric values
correct and we'll do the same so
therefore in our case we'll just have
one for the price and one for the rating
and as far as conditions we'll notice
how they use actually more user-friendly
ones correct the ones that we're using
in the final one and if we take a look
at the mongoose one of course they have
this dollar sign greater than and less
than so pretty much that's going to be
the biggest deal converting these
user-friendly ones
that we can simply pass in the url
to the mongoose ones and in order to do
that we'll have to do a little bit of
regular expression magic but don't worry
the code is pretty straightforward and
of course i already got it for you
and first thing we need to decide what
is going to be the name
for the key
in the query string parameter and again
i'll copy my favorite api at least for
this course
and i'll name this numeric filters so
say here that i'm going to be looking
for numeric
and then filters
now once i have access
to the numeric filters i just want to
scroll down
and we'll do the same thing where again
we'll set up a if condition and in this
case i'll uncomment the query object
because there's going to be times where
i do want to showcase what we're getting
back and let's just say with numeric
filters and then as far as what i want
to pass in well first let's go to get
all product and again
just to kind of keep this nice and sweet
i'll remove rest of them and then at the
end if we want we can add all of them
but i'll just remove these ones and then
we want to go with numeric
filters because that's the name that i
came up with meaning that's the one that
you'll showcase in documentation
and then as far as the values
well let's simply go with price is
bigger than i don't know
40 and then comma
and what was the other one i believe
that was rating and then let's set
rating bigger or equals to four
so let's send it to all our products
and of course i didn't save it
very very smart so let me go back over
here i'm going to go with log and
actually i didn't cancel log it either
so let me look for numeric
and we're going to be looking for of
course the filters if they exist we want
to console log them so let's go back
over here and now of course i have empty
query object because i didn't pass
anything in and here i have one string i
have price is bigger than 40 and rating
is bigger or equals to four and the
first thing we want to do is set up the
operator map now what does that mean
you'll see in a second so in here let's
go with const operator
and that map and in here i want to map
the user-friendly ones to the ones that
are understood by the mongoose so i'll
say bigger than
and then as far as the mongoose it
understands the dollar sign and then we
have greater than and once we have the
first one of course we just want to add
the comma and i'll copy and paste this
four times
and as far as the second value i'm going
to go with
greater than or equal and when it comes
to mongos we just need to add this e at
the very end
then as far as the equal well we simply
go with equal sign and then here we say
equals and of course we'll do the same
thing with less than and less than
equals so in here let's go less than
less than equals and as far as the
mongoose values it's lt
and then lte
so once we have the map then this is
where the regular expression magic
happens where first i want to set up the
regular expression and then we want to
run the replace method where we pass in
that regular expression and if it is a
match
then of course we'll change the value
from the user-friendly one that we're
getting in the numeric filters e into
the one that is understood by the
mongoose and when it comes to regular
expression we just go with const and
i'll call this
rejects noun is equal to the regular
expression and this one i got from the
stack overflow so please don't overthink
it you can always find those values you
really don't need to come up with them
yourself
and inside of the regular expression we
just want to go here with b
and then set up the parenthesis and then
you just want to pass in
all of these values separated by the
vertical bars
so in here
we go with less than
then greater than and hopefully you get
the gist and once i have all the values
then we want to add one more b
so let's go over here we add b
and then we're going to go with a g flag
and once i have my regular expression
then i want to go with the replace
method where essentially i call numeric
filters which of course is going to be
my string
and then i'll pass the regular
expression and if there is a match then
of course we'll convert from the
user-friendly one to the one that is
understood by the mongoose so in here
let's call this let filters and that one
is equal to our numeric filters then we
go with replace method and then as far
as the first argument we want to pass in
our rejects and the second one will be
the callback function if there is a
match so what we could do here i can
access the match if there is one and as
far as the functionality well i want to
take this match
and then i want to get the value that
corresponds to something that is
understood by the mongoose so here i'll
return a string and i'll purposely use
the template literal here and i'll
purposely also add these hyphens and
you'll see later why we want to do that
so there's going to be two hyphens one
at the start and then one at the end and
then we want to access the actual value
and now i want to go for my operator map
and then i want to look for the match
and hopefully you understand how this
works so essentially
i have the object
object has the properties correct and
then if there is a match over here then
i just say hey
get me that key
and effectively i will swap the values
and just so you can see how everything
works
instead of numeric filters why don't we
look for the filters over here
and then let's go back to the postman
and send a request one more time and now
of course you'll see the result so
notice
instead of this one where we have price
is bigger than 40 and rating is bigger
or equals to four now of course we have
this we have price and then this is
going to be that amongst value and the
same goes for the rating and since i
don't want to overwhelm you we'll stop
over here and we'll continue with the
logic in next video we have successfully
converted our values to the ones that
are understood by the mongoose but we're
not done because of course i cannot pass
this one into my query object we need to
do a bit more data massaging
and the way it's going to look first i
want to come up with options because if
you take a look at their api
like i mentioned previously you can only
do that on
certain
properties because these properties of
course have number values and
essentially we want to do the same where
i'm going to go with options and that's
just going to be an array and here i'll
pass into string values i'll say price
and rating because of course those are
the two properties that use the number
value
and then we want to go with filters and
set it equal to the filters and first
again we'll use the split method
remember that's the method that's
splitting string into an array and i'll
say that i want to split it where's the
comma so of course now i'll have two
items in my array i'll have this one
and i'll have this one
hopefully that is clear and then after
that we want to go with four each so now
iterate over that array and then in the
callback function i'll have access to
that item again it's going to be a
string of price and yada yada and the
same goes for the rating
and then we want to do more splitting
over there
and effectively i'm going to split it
into array and then remember we also
have array destructuring where i can
pull out the values
and i'm just going to set it equal to
item split and remember that when we
were setting up our regular expression i
purposely added here these hyphens so
now each item so price and the rating i
actually want to split it on that hyphen
so say here split it on hyphen and the
way the array destructuring works
instead of object where we say a
specific property whatever i'm going to
type here first
is going to match this price because of
course we're splitting on hyphen the
second one is going to be of course my
operator and the third one is going to
be the value so in here i can just go
with field
and then operator and as i said not if
you need to catch up on the array of
structuring i have that video in my
javascript nugget series so let's go
over here with the value so this is
going to be the actual value and then
only if the field so only if the price
and rating is actually in my options
only then
i want to add a new property on that
query object so in here right after that
i'm going to go with if and then the
name is options and we can use this
includes method
and if it includes the actual field then
inside of the block i want to go with
query object and then i want to set up
the field so now again i'm dynamically
setting up the property
on my query object and since we're
cancel logging of course you'll be able
to see that and then as far as the value
well again we need to go with object of
course so let's set it here equal to an
object and then we go with operator
again this is dynamic of course because
this operator will change in one case we
have greater than in other case we have
greater or equals so therefore again we
go with operator that is coming from
here
and then as far as the value well we're
still getting this as a string correct
so we need to go again with number and
then pass in the value so now of course
once i save
since we're constant logging you'll be
able to see actually what we have in a
query object so let me go back let me
send it one more time and what you'll
notice
is this query object we have price and
of course we have greater than and as
far as the rating we have greater than
or equals so what's really cool of
course now we get the correct values
where we only get the ones that have the
price bigger than 40 and rating is
bigger or equals to four so if i'll
change this around and if i'll just say
that i'm looking for a rating that is
bigger or equals to 4.5 and then maybe
the price
is going to be
bigger than 90 then of course once we
save check it out we have
only
how many seven products correct so
that's how we can set up these numeric
filters in our api and once we have the
numeric filters in place we're pretty
much done with the project hopefully
everyone enjoyed it and i'll see you in
the next one all right and welcome to
our next adventure
the json web token basics project so far
in our projects all the routes were
public
meaning
anyone can access them and use them
however they please
but of course that's not how we want to
set up apps in real world
i don't want random people to access my
data
and i bet you probably feel exactly the
same way
so how we can restrict the access well
i'm glad you asked a very popular method
is using jwt or json web tokens
and for the sake of simplicity just
think of them as long strings now of
course they're way more complex than
that but let's just not worry about that
right now
and the idea is following imagine we
have two routes
a dashboard and a login or register
route
now dashboard is protected so i can
click all day long on get data
but i'll have no access to the info
and only if i log in
i get the token and only once i have the
token i can access the secret info which
in this case is just going to be a
random number so let's try it out i have
the dashboard clearly says here no token
present and check it out not authorized
to access this route and again i can
click all day long and i can showcase
that
in the console where notice we're
getting these
401 errors but i'll have no access to
the data now in order to access the data
of course i need to log in and of course
this is just going to be a simple
version where i just need to provide
some kind of values if i won't provide
the values then i'll get the 400 one so
this is going to be a bad request and i
still don't get the token so let's go up
i'll say user name and i'm just going to
go with my john and again you just need
to provide some kind of values it
doesn't really matter in a later project
of course it will matter what we provide
there but in this case we just need to
provide something and only if i do that
then
i send it here notice user created so
now of course i have no errors and also
in the local storage i'm going to get
the token now don't worry about the
front end local storage and all that
i'll talk about it in more detail later
just think that you're getting the token
and once the token is present and of
course we can clearly see that here with
the text of token present then
we can make as many requests as we want
in order to get our data again as long
as the token is valid we are good to go
now if again i'll try to submit and then
i'll remove the token then again we're
back to the not authorized this route
now the reason why i made this project
so simple and straightforward is because
it's crucial that you grasp the main
concept
if you do i guarantee you you'll breeze
through the upcoming projects
even though they will be way more
complex than this
just always remember
if a valid token is present in the
request the user can access specific
info
now not all of the info of course you
can only access the info that belongs to
you so you cannot just randomly come
here and get my data but still if the
token is present you can get that
specific data but
if we have a restricted route so keep in
mind that login is not restricted anyone
can try to log in but if we do have the
restricted route like we have with
dashboard
if the token is not present or it's not
valid then the server in this case
that's of course us
will kick back the error response and
that's how essentially
we restrict access to certain routes
aka certain resources
and as far as the setup again we've got
the folders final where you'll find the
complete code
and a starter where we'll do all of our
work
and when it comes to final you'll be
able to spin it up once we cover
gwt or json web token basics since
you'll need to set up a variable in.env
and when it comes to starter all of it
should look very familiar and like i
promised in a previous video
in order to save some time on a
boilerplate i already set up a basic
express server for you
so let me install dependencies
and then i'll show you our app.js
so let me zoom out
i'll open up my terminal i'll clear
everything and then of course first i
want to navigate to the star one
so grab it over here and then we're
gonna go with npm
install
and then of course you will also spin up
and pm start
now when it comes to package json of
course there are few other packages as
well
and i'll talk about them once we get
there
and when it comes to app.js essentially
first i require dot env and of course
that is in order to access the env
variables then we have express async
errors and if you remember we use that
package just so we don't have to set up
our own async middleware
then we grab the express from express
and we invoke it and we set it equal to
app
then we're looking for two middlewares
not found one an error handler one and
if you take a look at the folder the
middleware one of course you'll see the
error handler
this is the one that we used all the way
in the project number three this is
essentially what we set up where we have
the custom api error
and of course we're looking for that
instance and then if that is the case
then this is the response if not then we
just send back the 500 one the generic
one
and of course since we're using
our own error class of course we also
have it in the errors so if you take a
look at the custom error one of course
you can see that we have the class that
is extending from the error and we'll do
that because of course there's going to
be some instances where we'll implement
our own class instead
and of course i'm importing both of them
from the middleware like i said
and then you can find the other one the
not found here as well and then we'll
also work on the authentication
middleware that's what we'll find here
the empty file
then we keep on moving and we can see
that we have app.years so we implement
the middleware and in this case i'm
looking for a static one so essentially
we're serving static files
because this is where our front-end app
lives notice over here again we have
index.html style css as well as the
browser app.js and then of course we
have express json and that is simply
because one of the routes is going to be
a post route and i want to access
request.body
so i want to get that data that's going
to be coming in and then of course we
implement both middlewares the not found
one as well as error handler one and
then we have the port variable we set it
equal to process.env port or 3000 and of
course in the final one it's a little
bit different i believe it's 5 000 just
so we don't have the port issues meaning
just so we don't have two apps trying to
access the same port and then of course
i have a start one however you'll notice
that in this case we're not connecting
to the database so i simply wanted to
showcase how everything is going to work
without database
and of course the next project will
implement the database because of course
that will add an extra layer of
complexity and of course in here i just
call app.listen set up the port i set up
the console.log and if there is an error
i log one now if you're wondering why i
kept this db folder with connect1
just so you don't forget the setup again
in the next project of course
a major part of the application is going
to be setting up everything once the
database in this case i just wanted to
showcase how everything is going to work
in isolation and if you can see server
is listening on port 3000
you can bravely navigate to your browser
and we're looking for localhost 3000 and
of course you'll see the app now nothing
is going to work i can guarantee you
that because of course we have no routes
but you should see the ui so you should
see the form as well as this g brush
here in the bottom and if you do
then of course we're in good shape and
now we can start working on the project
beautiful and once we're done with the
setup
next i want to set up our two lonely
routes so we'll have one fake one for
the login register and sign up and
please understand that of course in the
following projects there's going to be a
huge distinction
whether we're registering or we're
actually just logging in but in this
case we'll jam both of them together
because our main concern
is going to be that
jwt or json web token and as a quick
side note in the following videos when i
use term jwt of course i'm talking about
the json web token and then basically
what we want is to set up those two
routes and we already know how to do
that so of course we have the routes
folder in there eventually we'll have
the router
and then we'll also have the controllers
so in this case let's just start with
controllers so i'm going to go here with
const and effectively i'll set up both
of these functions
and i'll go with this sync because
remember we have the package that
handles that the express async error so
we don't have to set up the try catchers
or our own middleware and we can simply
go with rec and res
and as far as the response we'll just go
with the res dot and then send
and here i'm just going to say fake
login
register
and then of course d sign up and like i
said normally of course there's going to
be a difference whether we're logging in
or we're registering however in this
case we'll just mush all of them
together
and then we'll say we're out here
that's for the login and when it comes
to dashboard this is where we want to
share that secret or authorized data so
let's just say here dashboard
and that will be equal against your sync
rook and res
and here let's do it a little bit more
interesting where i just want to set up
some random number and i'll call this a
lucky
number and of course that will be equal
to math
random which is coming from the
javascript we'll multiply this by i
don't know maybe 100
and then let's wrap everything
in the math floor
and essentially we should get the random
numbers between
0 and 100
and then once we set up the lucky number
let's just go with the res dot status
and of course eventually this route will
be protected but of course for time
being we'll just go with res dot status
200
and then i'll say json and we'll be
sending back the object i'll say message
here
and eventually it's going to be the name
of the user
and therefore i'll place everything
right away in template string but for
now
since we don't have the user i'm just
going to say john doe
and then the other property on the
object is going to be a secret
so let's say here comma secret
and again we'll use the template string
and we'll say here is your authorized
data your lucky number and then of
course we'll access the variable and
once we have all of this in place once
we have the first string as well as the
second one with lucky number now of
course we just want to export them and i
think for now i can just close the
console as well as the sidebar and we'll
just go with module
exports and of course we're exporting
the object and we're looking for two
functions login
and dashboard and it looks like i made a
big old doozy where essentially i set up
my code
in the router instead of the controllers
my apology so take all of this code
cut it out from the routes
and you're actually looking for the
controllers we copy and paste and then
back in or out of course this is where
we want to set up the router so in here
we're looking for express just like we
did before we go with require we're
looking for the express package of
course
then we want to set up the router so
const
router is equal to express.router
router we invoke it
and then we're looking for both of the
controller functions
and those are login and dashboard and
both of them are coming from the
controllers
so hopefully you're able to fix my bugs
and essentially we want to go two levels
up
and then we're looking for the main
and then once we have all of this in
place eventually there's going to be a
middleware for authentication as well
but for time being we'll just go with a
router and then in here let's go with
dashboard first so dashboard
and this is going to be a get route
and we'll simply pass in the dashboard
controller
now the login one is going to be a post
one because of course we want to get
those user credentials the username as
well as the password so we go here with
router
then route
then forward slash login
and of course in this case we go with
post method and then we'll pass in login
and then last thing we want to do is of
course export this so module
exports and we set it equal to the
router
and then once we have all of this in
place we go back to the app.js we're
looking for the main router
so i'm going to go above both the
middlewares
and i'll say here main
router now that is coming from my route
so require
and it's in the same folder essentially
it's in the root so we simply go with
forward slash we're looking for the
routes
and more specifically main
and then where we have the middleware
for not found one and all that above it
we'll just go with app.use
and again what is going to be that root
endpoint well in my case again i'm going
to go with api and then version one
because that's the setup that i have of
course e in the postman and then of
course we'll just set up that every time
we get a request
on this root endpoint we'll just go with
main router so we go with main router
and of course in the main router we have
the dashboard so that one will be api
version one forward slash dashboard and
then for the login you already can
imagine that it's going to be api
version one and login and once the basic
controllers as well as the routes are in
place now of course we can move on to
our next task
nice and once we have our basic
controller setup in place
now let's also test it out e in the
postman so in here we want to go with
another collection
and of course
i'll give it another name
and i'm going to go with 0 5
and pretty much the same as the app name
so say here jwt basics and then in here
we'll have two routes
one
like you just saw is going to be to get
one and we're just going to be looking
for the url
then we'll go with forward slash and
then we're looking for the dashboard of
course
so that's going to be our get route once
we send the force we should see hello
john doe yadda yadda the lucky number is
90 and notice how every time we send of
course we'll get a different value and
this is done on purpose just so you can
see that we are getting a new request
out and then of course i just want to
save it
so let's say over here and of course i
want to save it here
in my latest collection
and then i want to do the same thing
with my other route with log in one but
of course that one is the post one
correct so let me close this one and
we'll just start with post
then we're looking for the url
and of course the route is logging here
and just to jog your memory when it
comes to the post route of course we
want to send some kind of data to the
server because effectively
we want to create a resource on a server
so therefore we go with body we'll go
with raw and we'll set it equal to json
and in here let's just go with username
because this is what we'll be sending
from our front-end application
as well as the password and of course
since we're just testing everything out
we can go with whatever values you want
and as a side note
in general we'll only check if the
values are provided
now in the following project of course
this is where the things are going to
get way more interesting than that but
for now you just want to send username
and then comma and of course the
password
and as far as the password i think
throughout this project i'm just gonna
stick with secret and then once we send
of course we have fake login blah blah
blah which means that everything is
correct and once we have tested both the
routes and once we have properly saved
them in our collection so here let's
just call this login
register and of course we can start
focusing on the real logic therefore in
here i'm just going to save it and we
can start working on our next task and
before we continue let me just give you
a big picture
of what we're about to do so first we
know that we have a post route the login
one
and essentially
since we want to log in or register user
in this case we're going to be looking
for two things we're going to be looking
for username as well as the password and
we already know that it's going to be
available in reg dot body
now if both of them exist we want to
create a new
jwt
if not then we want to send back the
error response then we want to say hey
listen please provide email and password
now
if we're good
if we create a new json web token then
of course we want to send it back to the
front end
since frontend needs to access it in
order to send another request in order
to send the get request where
essentially we display this secret
information
and on our end we want to set up the
authentication
so only the request
with jwt can access the dashboard
otherwise if you go currently to our
front end notice and click here and i
can actually access the data but that's
not what we want what we want on the
front end here or from the postman
doesn't really matter but of course with
front end it's just easier to see we
want to provide username and password
and only if both values are provided
then we get back the token and only with
our token we can make a successful get
request
and eventually display our secret data
on a front end otherwise we get an error
since the dashboard route is restricted
and only accessible by authenticated
users or in other words only by the
requests where json web token is present
and if we take a look at the comments
the first thing we want to do is check
for username and password and since it's
a post route we already know that data
is going to be indirect.body so here we
go with const and then looking for both
things username
password and this is going to be the
case where i will log them out so i'll
set up here log
and i'm going to be looking for both
user name
and password this is the case where you
can send those requests from the front
end
but i highly encourage you to do that
from the postman first and only do that
later once our jwt functionality is in
place
so my case i'm going to navigate to my
postman i'm looking for the login one i
have the body yeah that's awesome and
then i'll send it and back in my
application
if i take a look at the console of
course i have
john and secret there also could be a
case
where the user is trying to
log in with just empty values correct
so
he or she can send this type of request
and now on the console i can see that i
have nothing and before we issue the
token
which eventually will allow
the front end to access the route i want
to check
whether the username and the password
have been provided
now eventually once we work with
database effectively we have three
options first option remember when we
use mongo's required validation
it checks that for us
if the value is not present it simply
spits back the error so that's
definitely one route that we can take
once we introduce a database but in this
case remember we're not connecting to
the database another option we have is
to set up the entire additional layer of
validation which is going to be sitting
in front of all of our requests
and in order to accomplish that task
we'll utilize another package by the
name of joy
but i only want to do that in a later
project once we have a solid
understanding of the json web tokens now
the third option
is actually checking for both of these
values over here
where i can say hey
if the username or the password
have not been provided
then i'll send you back a a response now
in our case what's really cool we have
that package that wraps all of our
routes and we simply want to throw a
error what error
well our custom one where we say hey
listen you did not provide both values
so therefore we'll send back a 400
response which essentially is a bad
request so let's try it out
i'm going to go back to my controllers
and here i'll say if
and then if there's no username
username and the setup let me move these
ones up
and i'll add that comment check
in the controller
in the controller and once we're done
i'll actually show you how we could have
used that in task manager as well so
let's go down and then we have username
if it doesn't exist or
if the password doesn't exist so
essentially if one or both are missing
then we want to throw that error why
well because that's what we can do since
we have that express async errors now
what error are we looking for of course
that is our own one
so in the controllers what we want to do
is import our custom error so let's go
here with const custom
api error now that is equal to require
we're looking in the errors in this case
and more specifically we're looking in
the custom one
and if
the user hasn't provided the values of
username and password then of course we
can simply throw a new error and
remember this is going to be handled in
our own error handler middleware correct
the middleware that we set up it's going
to check for our own
api error and if that is the case then
we'll send back the status with the
status code as well as the error message
so now we simply want to throw new
custom api error my apologies i started
typing error actually we need to go with
custom api error and here we'll say
please provide email and password and as
far as the error code it's going to be
400. so 400 stands for bad request and
once we have the code to throw the error
now i can remove this cancel log
and let's just go back to the postman
and test it out
so if i haven't provided anything i
should have please provide email and a
password and status code should be 400.
again
if you already forgot how the custom api
error works and all that please go back
to the previous project
i believe we set it up in task manager
where i covered all of this e in great
detail so essentially if these two
values are not provided we have three
options we can either use [ __ ] and you
know just so it's less confusing i'll
write here mongoose validations or we
can set up another validation layer with
the help of package by the name of joy
which we'll do later or we can simply
check in the controller
and just to showcase
if you take a look at the task manager
so remember that was our third project
where we essentially just started
working with database more specifically
if we're looking in the controllers
and then create task remember we handle
this with the help of mongoose correct
because if you take a look at the models
you'll see the name and this one is set
to required now the same way we could
have just checked e in the controller we
could have just said okay
check if the task exists
if it doesn't exist we throw the error
in this case it was a little bit
different we used next since we used our
own async wrapper the general idea
doesn't change we're still throwing the
error and if everything is great then
we're creating a task and the only
reason why i'm telling you all of this
is just so i understand that you have
multiple options you're not limited to
just setting up the validations in the
mongoose yes you should do it it doesn't
mean that you should skip that part just
be aware that there's extra layers of
validation that we can add and in our
case we simply set them up right in the
controller so if the username or a
password is not provided just throw the
error which gets handled in our own
middleware in the error handler one and
here we just check for the custom api
and then we send back the response and
of course if that is the case we don't
send back this string we send back the
error
all right we check for empty values now
what well now we need to create a json
web token and send it back but before we
do that let's back up a little bit and
take a look at the big picture one more
time so far we have been setting up all
our routes in the following fashion as
long as the endpoint exists user just
needs to make a request and our server
will send a response but that's about to
change from now on we'll have two types
of routes
the public ones accessible by anyone and
restricted ones accessible only with
correct signed jwt or json web token so
back to our app
if the user provides correct credentials
meaning in our case of course those are
just some values in the username and
password we send back the signed json
web token and in order to access
dashboard wrote he or she basically a
frontend needs to provide the same token
otherwise we'll kick it back with an
error response and before we analyze the
structure of the json web token let's
talk about some big picture things first
and let's start with general concept
json web token is just a way to exchange
data between two parties and probably
the most common example for such parties
is a front-end app and our api
now why using jwet
is far better
than just some random string
simply because jwt has a security
feature
where we can be sure about the integrity
of our data if the token passes the
validation it means
it's the same token we sent to the
client
and the data wasn't tampered with second
for now don't worry how and where the
front end will store the token i'll
discuss it in more detail in a few
videos and third please keep in mind
that one of the features of http
is that it is stateless and that simply
means that server does not know or you
can think does not remember any previous
requests
sent by the same client
and as a result yes
even after the first second or even the
200 successful dashboard request
frontend
will still need to provide the valid
token otherwise the axis will be denied
remember how i suggested to think of
jwts as long strings well of course it's
way more complex than that so now let's
spend few minutes on the jwt structure
and then of course we'll dive back into
the code
and a very good resource is cite by the
name of
jwtio
again the url is jwt io and more
specifically we're interested in two
pages the introduction one and the
debugger and i'll start with
introduction and i'm not going to read
the entire thing line by line that just
seems a big waste of your time but i do
want to point out some things here and
there as always if you are interested in
learning more you know already where to
find it
and the first thing that i want to point
out is this sentence where it says this
information can be verified and trusted
because it is digitally signed so this
is what i was saying in a previous video
essentially we do that using the secret
and the algorithm and we'll learn more
about them in a few seconds so let's
just keep on scrolling they say when you
should use tokens okay
and this is going to be the structure
for the web token and like i said the
result is going to look like a large
string but of course it's way more
complex than that and essentially in the
json web token we have the header
payload as well as the signature
and when it comes to header consists of
two parts and one is going to be the
type of token and of course we're going
to go with jwt and the second one is
going to be the algorithm that is used
of course to create that signature then
this one gets encoded with base64 url so
we'll code this one
and then we have the payload in the
payload this is where we'll place the
information
and as an example we can place here the
id of the user that just signed on or
logged in or registered or whatever
then we send back the token the entire
token with that payload back to the
front end
then the front end sends it back to us
and then when we decode we get that id
and essentially what that means
is that if the user has some kind of
resource we access right away resources
that belong to only that user so
essentially if you create some kind of
resource
only you can access it
or modify modified or whatever then we
keep on scrolling keep on scrolling and
i'll talk about the payload of course
when we actually create our own token
this is just an example of what we can
send back again this also gets encoded
with base64 url and then lastly we have
the signature
and as far as the signature this is
where the algorithm is used the one that
is specified in the header and then we
add here the secret to sign our token
and as far as the secret this is
something that we'll have to keep on the
server
and again i'll talk about when we
actually create our own signature so
once we set up our first token then i'll
talk about it how and where we should
store the secret value and the idea is
we have the algorithm we have the
encoded header as well as the payload
then we take the secret string value
that is always going to be only on the
server
and then we sign this one and then once
we sign this is going to be a result so
essentially this is what we're sending
back to the front end and after that we
have a bunch of useful information of
how we can send back the token
from the front end and this is something
again we'll cover a little bit later
once we already create our token so
we'll swing back and i'll discuss what
is the better and all this cool stuff
and as far as the structure i think
we're pretty much done i just want to
showcase in debugger that of course we
have the token like i said this is the
signed token the encoded one and this is
what we're sending back to the front end
so this is what the front end will
receive
now once we decode there you go you'll
have information about that user so
you'll have some kind of id maybe a name
and when it was issued and of course
later we'll do something with that data
so this is that id that we're looking
for the user id and then we can use this
id to access the database resources and
all that cool stuff hopefully we're
clear on the structure
so now we can take a look at the package
we'll use to sign and decode our tokens
when it comes to signing and decoding
our tokens there are quite a few
packages out there so you definitely
have plenty of options but for my
projects i usually use package by the
name of json web token of course if
you're using starter i already installed
it for you but if you ever want to use
it in your own project just run this
command and as far as the docs since
we'll use only two methods i'm pretty
sure i won't return here but of course
if you ever need more info just utilize
the search engine nice and once we have
discussed the general principles of jwt
now let's try to issue one
in the project
and first what we want to do
is import the package and again the
package we're looking for is this one
the
json web token and of course we want to
assign it to some kind of variable so
i'm going to go with jwt is equal to
require and of course we're looking for
the package and once we have the package
after the if assuming
that both of the values are provided we
want to create a new token
and we do that in following way so we
come up with some kind of variable in
this case again it's going to be a token
pretty straightforward and then we go
with jwt so the package name and then
we're looking for the sign method
and then in the sign method
we want to provide three values we want
to provide a payload
a jwt secret
essentially is just a secret string
and then the options
now when it comes to payload you go with
object and pretty much in here you can
pass whatever you want sky's the limit
now please remember one thing you don't
want to send back some kind of
confidential information so don't stick
a password over here that is a very very
very bad practice now what normally gets
sent back well if we're creating a user
a id is very helpful because then later
on when we're authenticating the request
we can check for the user if i'm
creating a user and that user is i don't
know checking for some kind of resources
we only provide resources
that belong to the user
so in our task manager application
we only provide tasks that belong to the
user and as a result only the user
who created task for example can view it
or it and hopefully you get the gist
so in here i'm just gonna go with
username that was already provided over
here so that's what i'm sending back and
like i said normally send back the id
but since we don't have the connection
to the database
i'll create a dummy one from scratch
i'll simply go with id
and then i'll go with new date and i'll
say get time and let me just add a
comment just so it's clear that this is
only for demo and once i have both of
the comments first i'll add the id
and then i just want to mention here
that when it comes to payloads it's a
good idea to keep them small because the
bigger the payload the more data you're
sending over the wire and of course as a
result for someone with bad internet
connection the user experience might not
be the best one so that's about it for
the payload and then we want to provide
that jwt secret so we go here with a
comma
and we right away want to set it up in
our dot envy so of course we need to
create one from the scratch and in the
star we're going to go with new file dot
env and then we need to come up with a
variable name and in my case i'm going
to go with jwt underscore
secret and when it comes to value
in this application i'm just going to go
with something really simple as jw
secret
but let me grab the comment that i left
here
just for a demo
in production use long complex and
unguessable string value and when it
comes to more complex projects i'll show
you how we can create one so let me just
take this one out
and then i think i'll just leave that in
the controller there
right below the payload small comment
where again you always always when it
comes to production you want to have
them long complex and unguessable in
this case we're just cheating because i
don't want to bother with that so we go
with variable and then some kind of
value and now of course we just need to
go back to the controller here
and then remember we can access it with
process dot env and then more
specifically
we're looking for jwt
and then underscore secret and if you're
confused or just wondering why we're so
fussy about this jwt secret string if
you recall the json web token structure
video
this is the secret that is used to sign
r tokens and therefore it's a good
practice to only keep it on the server
and make it more complex than our
current jwt secret
just keep in mind that if someone gets a
hold of your key
they can start signing tokens on your
behalf and that's definitely not the
spot you want to be in as you can see
even in the docs they suggest your 256
bit secret and like i already mentioned
in the following project i'll show you
where and how
we can set up a proper secret value in
no time and then the last thing we want
to provide
is options and we're going to go with
expires in option
and i'll set it equal to 30 days
and i'll come back and talk about the
expirations and all that a little bit
later so once we have the token now of
course we want to change our response
where instead of the string
we're going to go with actual status so
set it up over here 200
then that
and of course we're going to be looking
for the json here
and then let's just add here a message
and we'll say user created
user created and this is the case where
the front end is using that message
so i strongly suggest keeping it the
same way and then we'll go with token so
effectively we have our token and now we
just want to send back to the user so
once we save we're going to go back to
the login one and in this case i'll try
one more time providing empty values and
of course in that case i get back my
error one but if i go here and if i say
john
and secret i should
get back my json web token and of course
i do and what's really cool
if you take this value
and just head back to the website
and just copy and paste what do you know
of course now i have username some kind
of fake id and this is going to be the
expiration so as you can see
this is the payload
that we're sending
not bad not bad we signed a token
sent it back to the front end now
well first we need to understand how the
request with the token already present
is going to look like
but before we continue let me just
emphasize something
since it's a backend course we're not
going to dwell too much
on do's and don'ts on the proper
jwt storage on a front end yes of course
there are best practices and don't get
me wrong they are important but our
current goal is to secure resource
access on the server
and therefore we're only really
interested in how the request is going
to look like so we can implement the
correct functionality on our end and if
you keep reading the introduction you'll
see that a common approach on a
front-end is to set up the authorization
header
in your request so of course in our case
that is going to be a get request
and then add the bearer schema
essentially what that means is that we
have the header by the name of
authorization
then we go with bearer and then space
and then the token and in this video
i'll show you how it looks like on the
front end as well as the front end code
and then in the next video we'll do it
together in a postman
and basically the idea is following
where i have the username password and
all that and i just go here with peter
and then i pass in my secret
and what i want you to see
is the local storage because of course
at the moment we have nothing in there
and the idea is following where i will
get back to token because of course i'm
providing some kind of values in the
username as well as the password and now
check it out here i have token so now of
course
when i'm making that next request so if
i go here with get data of course in my
code i just grab the token from the
local storage and of course i'm
successful and if we take a look at the
network requests so again this is going
to be for the login this is to get the
token and then of course as far as the
dashboard just open it over here and
notice the headers so we keep on
scrolling the request headers blah blah
blah and what we're looking for of
course is this authorization one so
that's the one that we want we have
authorization then we have the bear and
then of course we have the token
and if you're interested in a code just
navigate to browser app.js
and first what you want to do is to look
for the form event listener we're
listening for the submit event and then
in here i have try and catch and in the
try and catch i'm using axiorys library
with a post request and surprise
surprise i'm sending this post request
where to a login one and what am i
passing in passing in username and
password and what happens if i'm
successful notice this line of code we
go with local storage set item token and
then whatever i got back from the server
so i right away save this token in the
local storage now there's also a catch
and in this instance i just removed the
token now again this is just my
preference just so i can demonstrate
things but hopefully you get the overall
idea that of course on the front end
you'll store this token somewhere
and then of course when it comes to
actual request
i have the button i have the event
listener the click event listener and
then i'm issuing a get request
of course where is it going it's going
to the dashboard and the way we add the
headers again this is just for axiorys
library but the idea is going to be
exactly the same for fetch or any other
ajax library where you'll go with
headers and then of course the name is
authorization and then like i said we go
with bearer schema and then we add the
space and then we pass in a token and as
you can see i'm getting this token
from the local storage and of course
let's take a look how we can send the
same request
with a postman and once we have
discussed in theory how we can send back
the token let's try doing that in the
postman so in a login every time i send
a successful request meaning where the
username and password
are valid values instead of empty
strings then of course we're getting
back the token
and of course all this time i'm creating
with john but just understand that every
time we're getting that unique token
and what we want to do
take this token so copy this one and of
course don't worry later we'll set it up
with different usernames at the moment
there's really no need for that and then
back in the dashboard so in our get
request we're not looking for the body
we're looking for the headers and in the
following project i'll show you how i
can do that dynamically in postman
because of course when it comes to
bigger project is going to get annoying
really fast if you have to all the time
copy and paste those tokens just to test
something out but in this project yes
we'll do this manually so again we are
in the dashboard that's the route of
course it is get and all that and then
we're looking for the headers and header
name is going to be the authorization
one
then we want to set it equal to bearer
that's the name and you have to follow
this to the t
so bearer and then copy and paste the
token so now of course
if we send
yeah we get the value blah blah blah we
have the number but what's more
interesting if we go back to the
dashboard and if you log request headers
you'll see something really cool where
if i go with request and like i said
headers now let me send one more time
again the token is still valid we have
30 days so everything is going to work
if i scroll up check it out we have
authorization header and then of course
i have the bearer and then this is the
value
and this is what we'll do in the
following videos
we'll extract this
and actually validate it and if it is
valid only then we'll send back the data
with the actual username the moment of
course we just have john doe but
eventually we'll set up where whatever
username gets sent back to the front-end
well that one will send back here
because that way we'll showcase that we
only access
the specific resources that the user has
not just some random ones
beautiful
and in order to get to this value we'll
just have to do a little bit of
javascript magic
and we'll also have to throw a few of
the errors if the values are not
provided
so in dashboard first i want to assign
that authorization header to some kind
of variable and in my case i'm going to
go with auth header and then i'm looking
for a request
and then of course headers like i said
and then we're looking for the
authorization one so once i have access
to the header then i want to check
whether it actually exists because maybe
user is sending a request without the
header altogether and if it exists
whether it starts with a better and then
the space again this is very very
important that the syntax is exact
because if it's not going to be exact
then of course all of this loses the
meaning so let's say here if
and then off header so if it doesn't
exist or
the auth header
and then starts with that's the method
that we can use on javascript strings
and in here i just want to say if it
doesn't start with the bearer then of
course we'll throw the error so if there
is no authorization header
or it doesn't start with bearer then of
course we'll throw our custom error
so i'll just add here bear
and then the space now if that is the
case what we can do
well we can throw our own custom error
and in order to speed this up i'm just
going to copy and paste we're throwing
the error and normally you're going to
be way more awake than this but in this
case since we're of course just testing
the jwts i'll say here no token provided
in that case if you hit some kind of
roadblock at least you know where the
error is coming from and when it comes
to text normally it's going to be along
the lines of invalid credentials to
access this route and as far as the
status code instead of 400 it's going to
be a 401 so that is not a bad request
that is actually the authentication
error but again in this case just to
make it easier if you need to debug i'm
gonna go with no token provided
and then as far as the error we're gonna
go with
401 and of course in order to test it
out why don't we go back
and then i'm just gonna uncheck the
authorization just so we can actually
see what we get back and once we click
check it out now we have message no
token provided and what is the error of
course error is 401
now if i go back to the authorization
header and if i send now i can see
something went wrong
try again later
that's interesting so let me double
check my code and yes of course it
starts with not start with so let me try
one more time
let's send and there you go now of
course we have hello john though and of
course the secret as well and once we
have passed the first stage now i just
want to get that token and we can access
it in a following way where i'm going to
go with cons token is equal to auth
header and then we want to split it
again this is a string so we split it on
a space and we're looking for the second
value
and if you want to double check let's go
with token and let's cancel log it just
so we are on the same page so let's send
one more time and as i know there's a
tiny bug there as well
and you should see
in the console
a token
and i'm also going to fix it over here
what i'm going to say your lucky number
and once we have all of this in place
now of course we just need to set up the
verification where yes we got back the
token from the front end however now we
want to verify
whether the token is actually valid and
as far as verification goes something
like this
where if you take a look at the docs of
the package
the json web token one you'll see that
one of the options we have is using
try catch and then we just need to come
up with some kind of variable name in my
case i'm going to go with decoded and
that is equal to the package so jwt
now the method name is verify and here
we need to pass into values we need to
pass in the token
and then the second value
is that secret string so again we go
with our process
dot env and then the jwt and if there's
some kind of error for example
the token might be expired we'll handle
that in the catch block and what do we
want to do well we want to throw another
custom error and this is going to be the
case where i'll show you that vague
response where again we'll throw custom
error if we're not able to verify the
token and as far as the response will
say not authorized to access this route
hopefully this is clear so we try to
verify
if there's any kind of issue we throw
another custom error and in this case we
go with not authorized to access this
route and again the code is still 401
because that is authentication error and
then of course if we're successful then
we just keep on typing because all the
data is going to be in this decoded now
what data you might ask well let's go to
console.log and let's check it out
together so let's cancel log one more
time
let's send it here
and now of course you can see that i get
back my id username as well as other two
properties issued at
and expiration and of course
all of this is coming from our payload
the one that we passed over here
when we signed the token so of course
you can already imagine that if the name
is going to be different for the user
name of course this value will also
change and by accessing that value now
of course we can set up a dynamic
response so what do we do over here
we just say okay we have access to the
decoded one so let's take our code and
just move it up place it in the try
block
and then instead of just console logging
i'll keep the random one and all that
don't worry there's gonna be a little
bit different setup in a second anyway
but instead of john doe we'll go over
here with decoded and what is the
property that i'm looking for on the
object of course that is the username so
we just go back over here to the
username and if i navigate back to the
postman now of course once i send i'll
get back to john so let's go over the
steps in the postman first and then
we'll try it out in the front end in our
application so first let's go with login
again i'll try to log in without
providing the username for example i'll
send it over here now of course i have
please provide email and password so
that was that first check so if we are
successful here if i provide peter
then of course i'll get back my token
awesome and i can see that the user has
been created
then we want to go to the dashboard and
where we have authorization header now i
want to change this around where instead
of this value again just make sure
there's that space that's a big deal
here we'll provide this value instead
and now of course i have hello peter and
then again some random lucky number
and if everything works in a postman it
should also work on the front end so
let's try it out over here let's refresh
of course we can see no token present
and here i'll just try to get the token
without providing the values and of
course not successful
so i get back the error and therefore
i'm going to go with anna and then again
some kind of dummy password we send it
now we're successful
user has been created of course i can
see that token is present oftentimes the
token is going to be in local storage
and of course it is so now of course
when we're making those following
requests
now the token is present so we're
successful now we can clearly see our
username and then we're getting those
random values so all the following
requests are going to be successful as
long as we provide a token and since
token is in the local storage of course
we can always access it when we make it
and then we're good to go now if we
remove it and in this case i just set up
the functionality that if the user tries
to
get the token without providing the
values then i just wipe out the token
in the local storage so if we go back
notice it's actually empty now i'm not
saying that that's always going to be
set up on the front end it's just
something that i used in this case so
now if we go back again we don't have
the token so we get this not authorized
to access this route nice work we're
actually done with the main
functionality but just like in a
previous project once everything is in
place let's also work on some
improvements which we'll use heavily in
the following projects and first i want
to set up the authentication middleware
and essentially the idea is following
where yes at the moment we have the
dashboard route and in there we're
successfully checking whether the json
web token has been provided and of
course if it's there then we send back
the lucky number if not then we throw
the error but we need to understand that
in a more realistic application of
course there's going to be multiple
routes that use this functionality and
what are we going to do are we really
going to copy and paste for every route
that needs it or
it just makes more sense to take all
this code stick it in the middleware and
then just choose which routes need to be
authenticated and of course the answer
is setting up our own middleware so
first let's go to the middleware
directory in there you'll find
auth.js and we'll just start very simply
by creating a function that function of
course is going to be a sync and we'll
be looking for rec res and next and next
is very very important because otherwise
our whole cycle is going to break and
then of course we just want to cancel
log so in the beginning we'll just
cancel log and then we'll set up the
functionality let's go over here as
always naming is really up to you i'm
gonna go with authentication and then
middleware and that is equal to like i
said async
then we go with request and response and
then next because remember in order to
move on to the next middleware which of
course in our case is going to be a
dashboard route we'll have to call next
and i'm going to go with console.log
then i'm looking for rec
headers and then more specifically i'm
looking for the authorization one i just
want to check whether it exists
and then i want to go next like i said
and then of course we invoke it now we
just need to export this so we're going
to go here module
and export
and that will be equal to my
authentication middleware function
and now another million dollar question
so where are we going to use this
middleware now in a later project
we'll actually use it on multiple routes
but in this case we only have dashboard
that needs it correct so as far as the
login this is going to be for public
access
but when it comes to dashboard this is
going to be protected by that
authentication middleware so therefore
in the router in the managers we're
going to go here const and then of
course i'm looking for my function and
in this case i'm just going to call this
auth
middleware and that is equal to require
of course
then we had the middleware folder and
the auth file and the syntax is
following where where we have this get
method
before the dashboard i actually want to
stick my middleware so i'm going to say
auth
and then middleware and i'll add comma
so now of course every time
someone's going to be hitting this route
first they'll go through the middleware
and of course in the middleware since i
have next then i'll pass to the
dashboard
and in order to test it out i'm just
going to navigate to the browser so this
is where i have the working application
and it doesn't really matter whether
you're logged in or not just go here to
get data
and of course in my case i haven't
logged in i have no token so therefore
i'm getting back this not authorized
access this route but what i'm more
interested
is back in my application in the console
i can see bearer and that is set to null
so now i know that
all the requests that are going to the
dashboard are actually hitting this off
middleware first so now of course we
just need to add the functionality and
we'll be in good shape beautiful
and once our bare bones setup is in
place
now we simply want to go back to the
controller the main one and we'll need
to copy and paste two things and again
i'm just doing this just so we can get
to the functionality and you're looking
for jwt because of course we'll
implement that functionality as well as
the custom api error and as i said not
in the following videos we'll work on
more errors so essentially we'll create
here more error classes so i'll have to
do some refactoring as well but for time
being we'll just grab these two lines of
code we want to go back to the auth we
want to make sure that the paths are
correct so as far as json web token of
course it doesn't really matter i mean
that's the package we installed we just
want to make sure that this path is
correct
and it looks about right so now of
course let's go back to the controllers
let's keep scrolling keep scrolling
so of course that was the previous route
the login one and as far as the
dashboard we simply want to take this
logic where we're looking for the header
and if there's some kind of issue of
course we just throw the custom api
error
then we get the header and if everything
is great
if we can verify the token then instead
of setting up right away response in our
middleware we're actually going to set
up a property on a request object and
the property is going to be user and
then we'll pass it to the next
middleware which of course
is going to be this dashboard route so
let's go step by step let me take these
i mean what is it five lines of code
take it out so everything up to try and
catch you want to go back to the auth js
now you want to remove the console log
and just keep the next because that is
very very important
then back in the controller you also
want to take the try block but we'll
have to do a little bit of acrobatics
here because i'll actually need these
lines of code so let's go back over here
take the try catch as well step by step
and then copy and paste and here the
logic is following where you want to
remove this response with lucky number
so these things go you want to cut it
out and go back to your controller and
set it up in the dashboard so this logic
stays of course the same where we have
lucky number we generate that and of
course we only send that response if
we're successful now back in the author
js like i said we're still checking for
the header we're checking whether it
starts with bear if not we throw the
custom api error that's why we import it
over here
then we keep on scrolling we get to the
split we get the token and now of course
we have try and catch where we are
invoking the verify method we pass in
the token that we're getting back as
well as the secret one and then if we're
successful
then instead of sending a response since
we're working in the middleware the
logic is going to be following where i'm
going to go with const and then i'm
looking for two things i'm looking for
id
and the username here and that one will
be equal to decoded so of course
if i'm successful this is going to have
some kind of value if not we'll throw
the error and then if that is the case i
want to go with
and i'll just set it up to the object
where i'll have id
and username and of course once i have
set up the user property
with this object value now of course i
want to call next so
we'll move this next up over here and
what happens in the controller in the
request we'll have that user property
and now instead of looking for decoded
of course we'll look for the user
now in order to make it a bit more
explicit i'll actually cancel log it
just so you can see where it's coming
from so i'm going to go here with rec
and user so you can clearly see that
we're getting that
from our middleware of course and then
instead of looking for decoded we're
going to go here for user and username
now in this case i also need to add
direct since of course i didn't
destructure it so on the request object
and i have the user property and in
there i'll have the username as well as
id and let's just test it out one more
time to functionality so again i'm gonna
be on localhost 3000 i don't have the
token so now of course i shouldn't see
anything in the console and i don't
because remember we only get to the
dashboard if we're authenticated so
let's try it out here where i'll say
peter and then again my secret password
i'll submit
okay i created a user token as present
and then once i click on getting the
data now of course i have hello peter
and i'm getting the lucky number and now
if i take a look at the console check it
out now of course on the request object
once we get to the dashboard we actually
have the user with id and username peter
and of course this is coming from our
middleware where essentially again we
check for the authorization header then
we check for the bearer we split it up
we get the token then we use try and
catch because we want to run the
verify method and then we pass in a
token we pass in the secret and then
from the decoded we get the id and
username and since we want to pass it to
the next middleware
essentially we create a new object we
say user object on the request and then
pass it on to the next middleware and of
course if we're not able to verify the
token
then we send back our custom api
response and again the end result is
following where you can set up whatever
amount of route you want
and in front of all of them you can just
stick off middleware and then you don't
have to repeat this code the code is
sitting in one place and check for token
if the token is not present then you
just send back the error response
and once we have the middleware in place
now i want to switch gears and talk
about the errors
and if we take a look at our application
at the moment we have two types of
custom errors we have one for
400 that's going to be the bad request
and then we have another one for
authentication where of course we have
401
and technically we have been doing fine
with just this one custom error but
there's actually a better approach
where yes we have custom api error
that extends from the error so this
logic stays the same
but instead of just using this one class
will actually extend from this custom
api error and then for every type of
error we have which again in our case r2
we have one for battlequest and the
second one for authentication we set up
two more classes and then in those
classes we right away hard code the
status code and i fully understand that
this might sound confusing so let's just
start working on it and in the process
you'll see what i mean so first what you
want to do
in the custom api error just remove the
status code we'll set them up in
separate classes and then we want to
create three more files and we're going
to start with index.js and you'll see at
the very end of the video why we want to
use that
then we want to set up two more
and we're looking for bad request
and we'll go with js and then i'll set
up another file by the name of on
authenticated
and then of course it is js
and then in the bad request what we want
to do
is pretty much take the code that we
have in the custom error one pretty much
just copy and paste because we'll just
change some things around so copy and
paste over here
and then i want to close this one
so i'll say close saved
and then instead of the custom api error
we're going to go with bad request
that request
and of course this is going to be
extending not from the error actually
it's going to be extending from our
custom api error so let's go here with
const and we're looking for custom
api error now this is in the same folder
correct so we just go here with the
require
and then we pass in the path
so the path of course is custom api
error and instead of like i said
extending from the error we're standing
from custom api error and then we still
have the constructor we don't want to
use the status code over here and as i
said not you know what
in customer i also want to remove it
so we just have the constructor and
super here as far as the message and
then in the bad request
this is where not only we have super
method with a message but it will also
go with this dot status code
status code and we'll set it equal to
some kind of hard-coded value now for
the battlequest what value we're going
to use well we're going to go with 400
and then of course instead of exporting
custom api error we're going to go with
bad request and now we simply want to
take all of this code copy again just so
we can save a little bit of time
and paste in the
authenticated one and then of course
again i'll have to change some values
around
where this is going to be the
unauthenticated error so let's go over
here on
authenticated
and we'll call this error of course
we're still looking for the custom one
so we're still extending from this one
now the status code is going to be 401
and here we'll also say that we're
exporting on authenticated error and
then we want to go to index.js
and here we'll import all three of them
the custom error the bad request as well
as the unauthenticated
and then we'll export them as one big
object and you'll see once we start
factoring the application why it's more
useful so essentially if you want you
can technically leave it the way it is
just remember that
every time you'll need to use
one of these you'll essentially need to
look for that specific file
if we set up this index.js first of all
you'll be able to look just in the
errors because by default the index.js
will be served and in there we'll have
all of the errors so let's start here
with const and then custom api error and
of course i'm looking for the file by
the name of custom api error then we
copy and paste and we just want to
change these values around so of course
this will be the bad request one and
then last one will be that
authentication one and of course we just
want to change these files around
so this will be the bad request one
and then the last one will be equal to
our authentication one and then we want
to set up the object we'll say module
exports and that is equal to our custom
api error and then the battery quest one
as well as the authentication one now of
course at the moment our imports are a
little bit different but before we do
that i also want to talk about the
status codes so let's just fix the
status codes first and then we'll do
both things we'll import the proper
error classes in our application and
also right away set up the status codes
using the external library all right so
far in our application every time we
need a status code we just type the
number value which is kind of okay but
there's actually a better approach and
that better approach is using the
library by the name of http status codes
and of course we need to install the
library so this is the code if you need
it for your own project in my case of
course i already installed in the stars
so that's why it's available and then we
simply want to get the status codes from
the library
and then this is an object and then as
far as the properties we just need to
look for the text values for example for
200 we're going to go with ok
now if you want to take a look at the
codes of course just keep on scrolling
and you'll notice that if we want to go
with 200 response of course then we just
type okay
if we want to go with battlequest then
we just type it and this is going to be
400 and hopefully you get the gist and
as a result
we'll accomplish two things
it's going to be easier to understand
what is happening as far as our
responses
instead of juggling the 400s and 401s
and all that in your head and the second
thing of course we'll have more
consistency so let's try it out and in
this video i'll just try it out here in
the error classes and then of course in
next video when we'll be refactoring our
code since of course we have different
setup for the errors then we'll also
implement those status codes there as
well
and what we want to do is go to the bad
request and then below or above the
custom api error again this part doesn't
really matter we're just going to go
with const and then we're looking for
status codes now this is a named import
so make sure that the name is exactly
the same
status codes and then that one is coming
from our library http status codes and
then instead of this 400 we're going to
go with status codes and then we're just
going to be looking for bad requests
notice how they right away give you all
of these suggestions again it's easier
to read it's easier to understand what
is happening and second we'll have the
consistency and we want to do the same
thing in on authenticated as well so
let's navigate to this file again we'll
copy and paste just so we can speed this
up so copy and paste we get the status
codes and in this case of course we're
not looking for the bad request which
one we're looking for
unauthorized so let's go over here let's
say status codes dot
and then we're looking for the
unauthorized one and once we have fixed
the error classes using the status codes
now of course we just need to hop back
to our application and refactor it since
of course our error handling has changed
as well awesome and as far as the
refactoring we actually need to work in
three files
we want to look for our middleware so of
course that is going to be the other one
so let me just close all of them for now
and then let's start from the scratch so
like i said we're going to be looking
for the auth middleware that's the first
one
then we also want to work in the main.js
we'll have to
change the code here as well and then
lastly of course it's also going to
happen
in the error handler so where we have
middleware for her handler we'll have to
change some things around here as well
so first let's start in the auth chairs
now what error are we throwing over here
well at the moment it is custom api
error
but actually what error is it well of
course it is the authentication error
correct and we already have the class
for that which has the unauthorized
status code so what we simply want to do
is look for index.js so of course this
is going to be the errors folder and
then more specifically we want to look
for this error i'm just going to copy
this value and then back in the auth now
of course we're exporting as named
exports so we need to change this around
where i'll say okay i'm expecting here
the object and this is not going to be
coming from the custom error it's
actually going to be coming from the
errors copy and paste and now of course
i just get the
unauthenticated error and then instead
of the custom api error we're going to
go here and we'll say on authenticated
error and now of course we don't need to
pass in that status code correct we just
need to provide the message so let's
remove it over here
and then we want to do the same e in the
catch correct so the functionality is
going to be exactly the same and just so
we can speed this up
maybe let me grab the first part over
here
and copy and paste and then again we
don't need the status code we just
remove it and we'll be in good shape so
that's the first file we want to fix
then we want to go to the main.js e in
the controller and pretty much it's the
same thing
where at the moment i have custom api
error
but effectively what error i want to
throw here well i want to throw the
battery quest one correct
pretty much everything after that is
just for successful responses
and i think i'm going to remove the
console log since we already covered
that and then let's scroll up again we
want to change what we're actually
requesting so in this case i'm looking
for this
bad request error so let's go back to
the main.js and we'll set it up as an
object over here and then again we're
not looking in the custom error we're
looking in the errors and keep in mind
that since we're exporting as object if
you have multiple errors we simply want
to add comma and then just get them so
now we're looking for bad request error
and instead of custom api error we'll
exchange it for
bad request error we already have the
status code so we can remove that and
then finally let's go to the error
handler one and in here of course i'm
still looking for the custom api error
so as far as the instance this doesn't
change because both of them the bad
request
as well as the unauthenticated
extend from our custom api so this will
be still true the difference of course
is that we're looking for the object in
this case and we're looking in the
errors that's number one and the second
thing we want to do is get those status
codes and that is coming from the http
package so let's say here http status
codes and in the if block everything is
going to stay exactly the same because
of course we're getting the status code
from the object correct and then as far
as the message it's also there but when
it comes to this 500 you can change this
around and say that we'll be looking in
the status codes and this is going to be
equal to the internal server error and
when it comes to message i guess it can
stay the same and with all of this in
place let's just navigate to the browser
and then let's test it out let me
refresh
let me remove that token
so we're not cheating here so let me
remove it from the local storage and
let's try it out and let me refresh one
more time we have no token okay that's
awesome i can see not authorized to
access this route so i can clearly see
that my functionality works at least for
now and then of course if i wanna see
something i'm gonna go with anna and
then i say secret and then we submit and
user is created token is present so now
of course let's get data and of course
the user is still the same and
everything is correct and if you want to
try out setting up the user
without any kind of values let's try it
out we have please provide email and
password and if we inspect
we should see in the console
bunch of errors meaning we have one for
401 and then we have one for
bad request and again not to be
redundant but all of this code
refactoring and then introducing new
packages
as well as setting up more error classes
is going to make way more sense
as we progress to more complex projects
my idea is following where i want to
show you the simple setup first
and then show you these changes on a
small project because that way i believe
that it's going to be easier for you to
follow along because now we have only
what six seven files something like that
correct but as our projects grow
we'll still rely on these topics we'll
still rely on multiple error classes
we'll rely on status codes
as well as setting up the middleware but
of course then it's going to make way
more sense because we'll have
way more routes and way more
functionality and with all of this in
place we're done with the project
hopefully everyone enjoyed it and i hope
to see you next one all right and
welcome to our next project the jobs api
where we'll finally combine our auth
knowledge with crud functionality and as
a result we'll have an api where users
can log in and manage their job search
during the project we'll also learn how
to deploy our app to heroku so host our
apps on the cloud and set up nice
documentation with swagger ui for this
project i still managed to build a
matching front-end app but moving
forward so in our future apps i'll
exclusively use documentation to
showcase the end result since building a
front-end project for every api is just
too time-consuming
and before we take a look at the
features let me stress one more time
our job will be setting up the api so
the back end the front end is there just
to give you a better overall perspective
on how the api is going to be consumed
in real life and basically the idea is
filing where we have some kind of
front-end application
and we can log in or register so of
course if i haven't created my account
then first i would need to register so i
go over here and then i'll type some
kind of gibberish i'll say that i'm
peter the email will be peter
gmail.com and then we go with secret now
regardless
whether you're logging in or registering
will be sending the token the json web
token and then on the front end will
right away be able to
showcase the user account so if i go
here and if i say that i want to
register
and if i submit if i provide the correct
values now i can see my dashboard since
i just created my account i have no jobs
so of course in here i just need to
provide the values i'm going to go with
apple again and i'm going to be looking
for
front and position
i submit now i have my job i can delete
the job
i can edit the job and i can also take a
look at the single job
so in this page
i'm actually fetching data about that
one single job and i have functionality
to edit once i change some values
now when i'm sending this http request
this is going to be a patch request so
here i edit and if i provided the
correct values then i successfully
modified the job
so now i can go back to the dashboard
and i see that i have my job but in this
case instead of pending which is going
to be the default case we have the
interview and if i'm no longer
interested or maybe they sent me a
rejection i can also remove the job and
once i do that i have no jobs to display
and as a quick side note if you're just
interested in the front-end project just
navigate to johnsmilk.com
and at this point it is still on home
page but if you don't see it there it's
always going to be available in the
projects page and you can quickly find
it if you look for youtube now youtube
doesn't mean that the project is going
to be on youtube
i'm just grouping my projects that way
and then in here you can take a look at
the application if you click on this
massive master button
and if you want to take a look at the
source code just look for star files or
complete both of them
actually go to the same repo
and then in the source you'll be able to
find everything and a few things to know
about the project when it comes to the
url of course i'm using my api so if you
want to clone the project
and test it out on your backend you just
need to change the url and that is in
the ax usgs so in the source i have
axios.js
and as you can see the url is pointing
to
my backend but if you want to test it
out on yours you just need to change the
url and lastly keep in mind that i
recorded this in july of 2021 so
eventually once the react 18 is stable
i might refactor the code to take
advantage of the new features all right
and as always we'll start with the setup
and essentially we're looking for the
folder number six of the jobs api and
then more specifically we have two more
directories we have the final one as
well as the third and of course we'll do
all of our work in star
and then final is for your reference so
this is the complete project
now at this point you should be able to
already spin up the final project if you
want to just look for readme and then
here you'll find the info where we do
need to create a dot env file in a root
and then set up two variables the [ __ ]
uri as well as jwt secret one and of
course this is gonna be the connection
string the [ __ ] uri which you're
getting from mongodb you just need to
set up the proper password as well as
database you want to use and as far as
the jwt secret one for time being you
can set up some kind of silly value like
we did in a previous project because in
the jobs one i'll show you where to get
a proper jwt secret value and after that
just run npm install and npm start and
the final project should be good to go
now as far as the starter we'll just
navigate here to the folder
and first thing that i want to do is go
with cd
and then drag and drop the star and
before we do anything let's just go with
npm install and npm start so that should
install the dependencies and spin up the
dev server and as far as the setup in
this case we're going to have two
controllers one for authentication and
the second one for the jobs again we
have db1 where we're connecting to the
database that should be already familiar
then we have errors folder with all our
classes so we start with our custom api
one and then we have one for bad request
we have one for not found on
authenticated as well as index.js where
we essentially pull in all the classes
and then we can start using them around
the project since we have index.js
we simply need to reference the errors
folder and that will be the default
export and then we have middleware one
where we've got a authentication one so
essentially this is going to be exactly
the same like we did in the previous
project however this one i want to
retype from the scratch because we only
did it once and then probably in the
upcoming project we will reuse this one
as well and then of course we have error
handler one
so this is where i got the custom api
one and then i'm just checking if that
is the case if that's our custom api we
send the response with the status code
as well as the error message and i'm
using the status codes library and i
prefer using this package because in my
opinion it adds a bit more consistency
to our application
as well as it's easier to understand
what's happening with a status code in
this case we have internal server error
and also during this project we'll do
more work here in the error handler one
because i want to show you how we can
check for
multiple mongoose errors instead of
sending back always this 500 one with
the long error message then we have not
found so if the user is looking for the
route that doesn't exist we send back
404 and then route does not exist after
that we have two models so we'll have
job and user and also the same goes for
routes we'll have the auth as well as
the jobs and then eventually we come to
app.js where again we have two packages
that we have used quite extensively dot
env as well as the express async errors
i don't think i need to repeat what
they're doing then we're looking for
express we invoke it and we set it equal
to the app we have two middlewares we
have not found one as well as the error
handler one that we invoke dot json
because there's going to be some post
routes and we want to access data in
reg.body there's a simple route app.get
just a forward slash so this of course
is going to be to our homepage just so
we can test it out whether that's the
postman or the browser and i pass in the
not found one as well as the error
handler one in app.use and i set up the
port in this case i'm going to go with
3000 i believe the final one is 5000 and
then we have a start function
where we just invoke
app.listen and eventually we'll add here
more code if you can see clearly in
console server is listening on port 3000
and if you navigate to the browser and
go for localhost 3000 you can see the
jobs api we are in good shape and we can
start setting up our application
all right and once our basic app is up
and running let's start setting up the
structure
and we'll start with our controllers so
essentially in here we want to set up
the functions that eventually will be
controllers for our routes
and i want to start with auth and again
this is just going to be a structure so
we'll just add some dummy code like
registered user or login user and that
sort of stuff so let's go here with
const register so this is going to be
our first function and again it's going
to be async rec and res and in the body
like i said i'm just going to go to
rest.send and we'll go the register user
register user and then as far as the
author out the second one will be a
login one so let's just copy and paste
and i simply want to change here the
name for the function
as well as the string so let's go with
register login or i'm sorry
we're going to go with
login user my bad so login
and let's go with user since i have the
controller i also want to export it so
we're going to go with module
then export
and i'll set it up as an object and
we'll go to register
and log in and essentially in order to
speed it up i just want to take this
whole thing
copy and then back in the jobs we're
gonna go with get all jobs
get job create job
update job and delete job essentially we
have a crud functionality so i can just
remove the second function as well as
the login one we will rename them and
let's just start with get
all jobs so this is going to be a get
route that gets me on the jobs
so i'll say the same thing in string so
get all jobs let's just change what
function we're exporting and now we want
to copy and paste this four times i
believe one two three
and four so we'll go here with
get job this is going to be a route to
get a single job
then we have one for creating a job so
create and job as far as the string
we'll go with create job
then we have one for updating the job
update job
and let's do it over here as well
update job and lastly we have one for
deleting job so let's say delete and job
the same goes for the string so delete
job and now i just want to add the rest
of the functions
in my
object the one that i'm exporting so go
with get job then we're looking for
create job
the update job so comma update job and
delete job and once we have the basic
controller structure in place
now of course we can do the same thing
with our routes and as far as our routes
let's start with auth js and of course
we need to set up the router so let's go
with const express easy equal to
acquire
acquire and of course i'm looking for
express
remember we need to go with some kind of
variable and micros router and we'll set
it equal to your express dot and router
we invoke it and then we'll import both
of the functions from auth controller
and remember the names were register and
login so let's go over here
login
and register and both of these things
are coming from our controller the auth
one so let's navigate over there we have
controllers and of course the auth one
and once i have my imports in place now
of course we just need to set up the
routes and if you remember we also had
an option of router and then that and
then whatever is the method and both of
these are going to be the post routes so
i'll simply go with router that post and
then we go with forward slash register
and then of course we'll pass in our
controller after that we'll copy and
paste again router.post in this case
we're looking for the login one
and of course the controller will invoke
he is also going to be a login one and
then at the very very end we'll just go
with module
exports and that is equal to the router
so that should do it for
auth.js and before we navigate to app.js
and import it and set it up let's also
do the same thing with the jobs router
because essentially the idea is exactly
the same where i want to go to jobs and
again in order to speed it up
let's just take
these two lines of code
and i'm sorry i navigated to the wrong
file so here in the jobs i set up the
router yep that stays the same and now
we just want to go
with const and we want import we want to
import get all jobs get job
also i'm going to be looking for create
job
create job then we want to update the
job
and lastly we want to get a job or i'm
sorry not get job delete job
delete
and job and all of that is coming again
from the controllers correct so go with
require and we'll set it equal to the
controllers folder and of course we're
looking for the jobs and once we have
these imports in place now of course
we'll do the other way where we go with
router dot route and then we'll have
post and get on a forward slash and then
we'll have the get delete and patch on
forward slash and then the route param
so let's go with router
dot route and this is going to be the
forward slash of course and therefore
we'll go with post so this is going to
be to add the job and get all the jobs
remember that was the structure for rest
api and we're looking for the controller
of create job of course let's go with
dot and then get and this is going to
get me all the jobs then we'll copy and
paste
and i'll add here the id remember the
route params
and in this case we're not going to have
post
so i can remove this one and we'll start
with get now this is going to get me the
single job here
then we're gonna have one for delete of
course the controller is delete job and
then lastly we have one for patch and
here we'll pass in update job and then
at the very very end of course i want to
go with module
dot exports
and the router now of course if you
prefer this index you can also use it
here in auth js i just thought that this
is a nice refresher where of course we
can set up our routes
this way as well
and once we have both of the route files
in place now of course we just need to
go to app.js we need to import both of
them
and again as always this is really up to
you
but i'm gonna do that above the error
handlers because there's also going to
be a connectdb here so connect db is
still coming up let's just go with
routers
and here let's say const auth router and
that of course is equal to require
and we're looking in the routes
and then more specifically of course i
want to access the auth one copy and
paste and this is going to be a jobs
router of course this is coming from
routes and forward slash and jobs
and then i don't think we need a dummy
one anymore i think we are pretty clear
on what's happening so now of course
let's remove it let's say app.use and as
far as the path i'm going to go with api
version 1 again that's my setup in
postmatch so we might as well continue
using that one and as far as the auth
i'm going to go with
forward slash auth and of course what
that means in here we have the full path
of api version one auth and then
register
and the same goes for the login and as
far as the jobs will do exactly the same
we'll go with api version
jobs and then the forward slash is just
going to have the create one and get all
of them and then the route params will
have the rest of the three hopefully
that is clear because again we pretty
much keep repeating the same thing so
let's go with api version one and then
auth and then let's just pass in the
auth router so now of course we just
need to copy and paste and let's go with
jobs1
and of course now we want to implement
the jobs router so i'll say over here
and i don't think i'm going to do any
kind of testing since it doesn't make
sense at the moment i'm just going to
check my error so it says over here
router.post requires a callback function
but it's not given so let's see let's
see let's see
maybe i didn't export something
so let's go to jobs
that's the router
and of course i'm looking here for the
auth one for some reason
so let's remove this one
and then as far as create job
looks like i didn't export it or
something along those lines so let me
take a look at the jobs
of course
there's a naming issue it's a create job
so create job and of course i need to do
it over here as well so once i fix this
tiny bug
now we should be heading in the right
direction where we have the routes we
have the controllers so now of course we
just need to start adding the logic
and the reason why i'm not testing
anything right now because of course
we'll work in each of the controllers
quite extensively and before we do
anything of course we'll just check
whether we're getting this silly string
response and if we do then of course
we'll work on our logic
all right and before we can start
registering our users
the last thing that we need to do as far
as the general setup is to set up
connection to the database and of course
we have the function we already have
connect js we have the functionality
where of course we use the mongoose we
set up to connect we pass e in the url
and of course these are going to be our
options to remove those depreciation
warnings and the only thing we need to
do is set up in a star
dot env
and here let's go with [ __ ] underscore
uri
and of course you want to pass in your
connection string so let's go to connect
we're looking for connect your
application
i'll take this one over here
and copy and paste and as far as
database i mean it's not going to be a
surprise if i go over here with
0 6
and i'll call this
jobs
api
and then of course i just need to
provide my password and once you do that
just navigate to app.js
so let me close everything just so it's
not so busy
and i guess in the app js i'm going to
go above the routers i'll say const
connect
and then db
and that will be equal to require of
course
and we're looking for our function
and that is located in the db folder
not the error sorry the db one and now
we're looking for connect and then we'll
just scroll down where we have the start
and we'll go with await
and we'll invoke the connectdb and now
of course we want to go process dot env
and then the [ __ ]
[ __ ] underscore
and uri so underscore and uri and once i
save and if i can still see servers
listening on port 3000 that means that
our connection is ready to go and now
can finally start setting up our
authentication all right and once the
database connection is in place the
first thing we want to do is to create a
user model
and in a process we'll learn a few more
built in mongoose validators
and as xenon if you need to reference
the steps we're about to take
just navigate to the readme in the root
so in the star route look for readme and
here you'll find all the steps and since
i want to show you more validators let
me open up the mongoose docs so in here
we're looking for a validation
and then more specifically just look for
the string one because in the user
pretty much all of them are going to be
strings so
just click on any of these ones
and here and there i'll just use this as
a reference just to showcase what's
happening and essentially we want to
navigate of course to the user model so
the file is over here and remember we're
looking for the [ __ ] is of course so
const
mongos is equal to require and of course
i'm looking for the mongoose and after
that we will add two more packages the
jwt one the json web token one as well
as bcrib js but of course that is still
coming up and i want to start by
creating a schema so let's go here let's
call this
user
schema not as equal to new mongoose
and of course we're looking for the
schema here in this case
and i want to go with parentheses
pass in the object and as far as the
properties will have three we'll have
name
email as well as the password so let's
go over here with the name that's going
to be the first one i think i can close
the sidebar just so i have a little bit
more real estate and we'll start with
type type will be equal to string then
we'll right away set it equal to
required
and then we'll set it equal to array
remember the first value is whether it
is true or false of course in my case
i'm going with true and then we'll say
please
provide a name so of course that is our
required validator and after that i just
want to showcase that in the mongoose
docs we can see that we have min length
and max length
now of course as far as the values
that's really up to you
my case i'm going to go with min length
and i'll set it equal to 3
and of course i'm going to also set up a
max length and i'm just going to say 50.
then i want to go with email
and in order to speed this up we will
copy and paste and of course i'll change
the name here this is going to be an
email
then i'll still set it as required so
that's going to stay the same let's set
it over here and then we also have a
match one which pretty much creates a
validator that checks if the value
matches the given regular expression now
why we want to use that because i want
to use the regular expression to check
for the valid email there's plenty of
suggestions out there most likely the
first answers that are going to pop up
are going to be from stack overflow just
pick the one that makes the most sense
to you and you'll be good to go now as
far as this project you have two options
you can either get the code in the
readme or just look in the final one so
in the final of course i have the models
and all that and then just look for the
user one and you can take the entire
property that's really up to you so in
my case i'm just gonna navigate to the
readme i'll take here this code and then
i want to go back to the user
and more specifically the email i want
to remove both of these the min length
and max length and then we want to go
with match
and we pass in the array so essentially
that's the syntax and then we want to
pass in the regular expression then
comma and then whatever error message we
want to provide and in this case it's
pretty much going to be the same
i'm just going to say please provide
valid email
and once i have the match in place the
last thing i want to set up for the
email
is unique
and true
and essentially what unique does it
creates a
unique index and this is something you
need to be aware of where technically
it's not a validator and that becomes
important when we run validate method
manually which we haven't done so don't
lose your sleep over that and when
you're writing automated tests and of
course you can read more about it in the
docs but the way it works it just
creates that unique index so if i'm
trying to save a user
but there is already a email news
then i'll get the duplicate error
message and lastly i want to go with
password and here
i think i'm going to take the name
because pretty much is going to be
exactly the same where i'm going to go
with password
password and then required will be true
now of course the error message is going
to be a little bit different
say here password and then as far as the
middle length and max length i think i'm
going to go with 6
and no longer than 12.
so let's set it up this way we have the
user in place
the only thing left to do is of course
export it so let's go with module
and export
and i'll set it equal to our mongoose
model
and of course we want to pass in
our name and my case i'm going to go
with user as well as the user schema so
user and schema and once we save now of
course we can start setting up our
register controller
beautiful our user model is in place so
now of course let's set up the first
route and steps are going to be
following where first we want to
validate a name email and password
whether of course the user has provided
the correct values and in this case i'll
purposely go with mongo's option just
because i want to show you how we can
send back nice error responses instead
of those big objects then we want to
hash the password and don't worry if
this looks like gibberish to you right
now of course i'll cover it extensively
a little bit later
after that if we're successful
if we can hash the password if the
values have been provided then of course
we create the user and once we have the
user we want to create that token that's
going to be associated with that user
and with that token the user can start
creating resources which of course in
our case is going to be jobs and in
order to get that token to the user of
course we will include it in our
response
so let's get cracking
and of course we're looking for the
controllers in this case and of course i
have the final open so i'm actually in a
wrong folder so let me look for
controllers we're looking for the auth
and of course more specifically the
register one we can start by importing
the model
so in here i'm going to set up a user
and that is going to be equal to require
then we're looking two levels up
and of course i'm looking for the models
and then more specifically a user model
and once i have the model before we do
anything here let's just check in the
postman
whether we're getting this silly string
because if we don't then of course we do
need to troubleshoot so let me navigate
back of course here i have all my
workspaces and i'll create a new one
that's not a surprise
i will rename it and i'll say
0 6
and let's call this jobs api
now the url of course is going to stay
the same remember that global variable
so
that saves us a little bit of time and i
want to go with new request this is
going to be a post request
and here i'm going to be looking for my
url of course so url and then remember
we're looking for auth
and register hopefully that is correct
let me just double check
so in the
here i have api version one so that
should be still in my global variable in
the postman and then more specifically
auth
and then if we take a look at the routes
in here in the auth of course i have the
register and like i said both of them
are going to be post routes so why don't
we start by selecting a body then we're
going for raw we want to go with json
and then let's just set up the name
and it's not going to be surprised if
i'm going to go with john
then as far as the email let's just go
with the dummy one so i'm going to say
john
gmail.com
and then lastly we want to go with
password and i'm just going to stick
with secret because that's the most
simplest one in my opinion so i have
name
email
as well as the password
and of course once i send i should get
register user if you don't then again
please troubleshoot because otherwise
anything we're about to do it's not
going to make sense and before we move
along let me just save this one
and i'm going to look for my jobs and
let's just call this register
and user so let's save it over here and
let's right away test whether we're
getting back the correct values meaning
whether i can access them in a reg dot
body so change this one around where
we'll say res.json and i'm just going to
pass in reg.body again in this case i'm
just checking
whether my middleware is correct and if
i can see all the three values that i'm
sending from my postman then of course
we are in good shape
now i also want to get these status
codes remember that was the library that
we used before so let's go over here
let's say const and we're looking for
status codes
and that is coming from our library the
http status code so require
require
and we're looking for the http status
codes and then in here i want to set up
the status
status
and of course dot json after that and
let's just go with status codes
and then we'll set it up as created
because remember we are creating a
resource so this will send back the 201
and once we have all of this in place
now of course we can create that new
user correct so let's go here let's say
const user and we'll go with a weight
because of course this is asynchronous
then the model name user and we'll go
with create method and in the create
method since i want mangoes to do all
the validation i'll simply pass in
rec.body just like we're doing over here
so now of course i can remove it from my
json and for them being i'll just send
back the user our current code actually
is a big big mesh because we're saving
the passwords as they come in as strings
and that's a very very bad practice and
don't worry we will fix that a little
bit later for now i just want to see
whether everything works and once we hop
back to the postman
we should be able to send a request and
in my response i can see that i created
a new resource
in a [ __ ] database since i have that
underscore id and then the rest of the
properties that i provided in my request
and with this in place now of course we
can move on to our next step
beautiful we can save our user
and before we cover why it's such a bad
practice to save our password as a
string
now let me remind you about the error
checking
and more specifically let me just jog
your memory on the fact that we can
check for the empty values right in the
controller because keep in mind that at
the moment we are doing that using the
mongoose so first let me show you how we
can do that in the controller and then
i'll talk about it while we're checking
in the mongoose essentially what i'm
trying to accomplish
and if you remember we simply check it
in the following way where we go with
name email and password now all of that
is coming from rec that body of course
and then we want to go with if and if
one of the values is missing then we'll
throw our own custom error more
specifically the bad request one so
let's say over here email
and then we'll do the same thing for the
password so if one of them is missing
then of course we'll throw the error and
of course we need to import that so say
here const and we're looking for bad
request
quest
and error so that's the one we're
looking for now if you don't want to
make the typo then of course just
navigate to the errors folder more
specifically index.js and then just grab
this value
so that way you'll avoid some
unnecessary typos so let me just make
sure that the name is correct looks
about right and then we want to go with
require of course we're going two levels
up and we're looking for the errors and
since we have index js over there of
course we don't need to be more specific
by default we'll get back the index.js
and once i have the import in place now
of course we just want to throw the
error in the if block where it'll say
throw new
and of course i'm looking for bad
request one
and then we just need to pass in the
message because remember the status quo
is already there and let's just say
please
please provide
name
email
and password
and password and once i save and once we
navigate back to the postman if i'll
remove the password completely
and if i'll just send notice now of
course i will get the message now our
functionality will still work because of
course we're using the mangos validators
even if i remove this code so if i
comment this one out and if we go back
and if we send without a password or
without any of these two values as well
of course we'll get back there now the
reason why i'm using the mongoose
validator because during this project i
also want to show you
how we can send back more meaningful
response because at the moment of course
i'm sending 500 which technically isn't
the case because of course now we have a
bad request instead of internal server
error and also notice these massive
objects probably would be better
if we would send just please provide the
password or the email or the name and
therefore in this project we will use
mongoose validators quite a bit
just because of course i want to show
you how we can send back more meaningful
messages but that doesn't mean that
we're not going to check in the
controller so of course this one is
optional
but there's going to be some cases where
yes we will have to set up that check
directly in the controller so this one
i'll remove because this pretty much is
a repetition here but when it comes to
different routes yes there might be some
cases where we check directly in the
controller hopefully that is clear so
now we can start tackling the password
issue
not bad not bad if we take a look at our
database we should see user's collection
and overall life is great
if only not for one big doozy
notice how we store password as string
so now if someone breaks into my
database he or she can easily ruin the
life for all my users
since in most cases people use the same
password for everything
so if there's one thing i want you to
take away from this course please
never ever store user passwords as
strings trust me they will thank you for
that later
okay well what's the solution
well we want to hash them instead which
in simple terms means generating random
bytes
and combining it with the password
before we pipe it through the hash
function a mathematical algorithm that
maps data of any size to a bit string of
fixed size
something to remember hashing is a
one-way street meaning it cannot be
reversed
also if the input changes even tiny bit
the resulting hash will be completely
different which is really really good
for storing passwords since we can
accomplish two things at once store
passwords in a form that protects them
even if the password itself is
compromised and at the same time being
able to verify the correct user password
both of which will cover extensively in
the upcoming lessons when it comes to
password hashing
for this and following projects we'll
use a library by the name of bcrypt.js
again the library is called bcrypt.js
and if you're using a star i already
installed it for you so we can start
using it right away
and as far as the syntax for hashing the
password it goes something like this
where first we want to import the
library of course and we're looking for
the bcrib js again please keep in mind
that the library name is bcrypt.js
don't install the beaker one and then
wonder why you have bugs so again the
name of the library is be crypt.js and
the only reason why i'm telling you that
because i fully understand that it's
very easy to mix them up
and once we have access to the library
instead of dumping the entire body with
our name email and password we want to
create a new temporary user object and
in here i'll just pull out the values
from direct that body so my apologies we
already had this code but i removed it
with a bad request
so now i'll have to retype it one more
time so we'll look for name email and
password and all of that is coming from
rec.body and then i want to set up the
temp user object and of course keep in
mind that in the temp user
all three properties need to be there
otherwise we'll get back the error so of
course in here i'm passing reg.body now
i want to set up a new object and you'll
see
why i'm telling you that in a second and
effectively i first want to set up the
hashed password and then i'll go over
line by line and explain what's
happening so let's start over here with
const temp user
and we'll use the es6 thing
where i'll go with name is equal to name
and emails equal to email and what i
want to do here is set up also a
password but password will be equal to a
hash password which of course at the
moment we don't have
and in order to set up the hashed
password we need to run two methods we
need to run gensalt
and then the actual hash method and
first i want to create a variable and
i'll say salt and we have an option of
running them asynchronously so just go
with a weight then i'm looking for
bcrypt and like i said the method name
is
jen salt and then we want to pass e in
the number value
again i'll explain all of this in great
detail in a second and then once we have
the salt then we want to create that
hashed password so let's say over here
hashed and password and we'll go with
await then bcrypt again decrypt and the
method name in this case is hash
and we need to pass in two things we
want to pass in the password we want to
hash
as well as the random bytes which
essentially is that sold so let's start
over here with password then comma then
we pass in the salt and now where we
have the password in the temp user
instead of directly using the password
we'll go with hash password and now of
course instead of dumping the entire
body we'll go with dot dot again we want
to spread them out and then we'll go
with temp user and once we save all of
this now let's hop over to the postman
and let's try to send the request
so in here we need to keep in mind two
things first
the fact that we have set up four unique
emails so if we'll try to send
the same email we'll get the a response
that's number one number two remember
when we're setting up the password the
basic password we also add the max
length since i wanted to showcase that
we have that valve there now in this
case of course we will get an error
because the hashed value is going to be
way longer than 12. so let's try it out
let's send
and like i said we will get an error
where the max length is 12 and of course
this is the hashed password value and in
order to fix that of course we just need
to go to our user model and then remove
the max length like i said
i added this just so you can see that we
have this option but of course in our
case we are not going to use it and then
once i fix that then the another bug is
going to be that we have a unique email
so if i send with john gmail.com of
course i'm going to get an error which
pretty much tells me that i have [ __ ]
error
and more specifically there's an issue
with an email and this is the case where
again we'll work on these custom error
messages in a second now we simply want
to change the john to john 1 at
gmail.com and once i send check it out
now of course i'm getting back the user
now it's still not a good idea to send
back the password so that's also
something that i will work on a little
bit later now the good news is that if
we navigate right now to our mongodb
and if we take a look we'll see our
second user
with a email of john 1 and of course now
the password is hashed
and what that means is that even if
someone breaks into our database and
steals all the data instead of actual
password values they'll get the hashed
ones which prevents them from easily
reusing them later
now that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
protect your database of course not
that's not what i'm saying just make
sure that you always always hash your
passwords and never ever ever
store them as strings and as far as the
code if we take a look at auth.js
in line 9 we generate salt
which essentially just means random
bytes and we do that by running the
method
gen salt and in there we provide a
number of rounds so how many
random bytes we'll get and of course the
bigger the number the more random bytes
we'll get and of course that also means
that the more secure our password is
going to be but we also need to keep in
mind the more rounds you have
the more processing power is going to
require and therefore i just went with
10 which i believe is a default one and
trust me that is already a very very
secure password and then of course we
take that salt so there's random bytes
and we pass in the hash method and hash
method is simply looking for the
password so the password we want to hash
as well as the result and once we
provide both those values as a result we
get back that hashed password and of
course that one we can safely store in
our database so we just add it to our
user and we're good to go beautiful we
now know how to hash user passwords
and if we take a look at our register
user steps essentially we just need to
generate a token which should sound
already familiar since we spent the
entire project on that
and we'll be good to go right well yes
and no
that's true we don't have much left
but if we take a look at our controller
it's getting somewhat busy so if we'll
keep on adding more functionality
and just keep jamming the code in the
controller eventually it's going to get
bloated and way harder to manage
now what's the solution you might ask
well
another set of middleware only in this
case we're talking about the mongoose
middleware but just keep one thing in
mind the end result is going to be
exactly the same
will still hash users passwords
it's just the logic will be stored
nicely in a separate place
and since i want to show you the entire
documentation i'm going to navigate back
we're looking for the middleware and of
course you can read yada yada yada we
have pre and post so before and after
hooks and essentially we're looking for
pre
and more specifically pre save and the
way we set it up
we have the schema so in our case of
course that is going to be our user
schema then we go with pre so that's the
syntax and we're looking for save
so before we save the document and then
in the callback function
this is where we can access the
properties in a document and do some
exciting stuff and of course since this
is a middleware then we just go with
next and once we're done we pass it on
to the next middleware now i'll also
show you with async weight so this is
coming up first let's just focus on this
next one over here and essentially what
we want to do
is take the bcrypt we'll just save a
little bit of time
and we will go to our models we're
looking for user one of course
and then here let's copy and paste we
have the bcrypt let's keep on scrolling
okay that's our setup and here this is
where we want to go with our schema so
before we set up the model we'll go with
user schema that's the name of course
then we're looking for pre and then save
so pre-save and since we'll use a weight
we'll right away set it up as a sync
and then let's go with function and i
highly highly highly suggest using the
good old function keyword value because
that way this will be scoped to our
document so if you'll go with arrow
functions if you're familiar with them
you know that
as far as scoping this there's different
set of rules in this case if we use the
good old function that's why you'll see
that in the docs as well
this will always point to our document
so in here let's go with our function
and it is a sync nice then let's pass in
the next of course
and then remember the functionality what
are we looking for over here well i want
to generate the salt correct and of
course i want to get the password and
just so we get comfortable let's write
it from the scratch so let's go to the
user one
and essentially i want to go with const
salt so now we're generating those
random bytes so let's just go over here
with a weight and then be crypt and of
course the function name was gen salt
and i'm not going to go 20 rounds i'm
going to go with 10 here
and then as far as the password well
this is where the callback function
comes into play where in this function
this will point to the document so when
we type this over here basically what
we're talking about is our document
before i want to save the document what
do we want to accomplish
well we want to hash the password
correct
so what we can do we can go with this
dot and we're looking for password so of
course this is over here and we simply
want to go with await and we want to
hash it we want to go with await then
bcrypt and then of course the method
name is hash
and then we're looking for this.password
so our current password for saving
and then we pass in salt and that's it
that's all we have to do and once we're
done with the functionality what's left
well we want to pass it on to the next
middleware so we just go with next and
we invoke it and now check it out
if we take a look at our controller
since we're not sending the bad request
here anyway i don't really need all
these lines of code that's it i simply
want to take my body just like we had
before with dot dot erect.body and
everything else is taken care of over
here and you have to agree that this is
much cleaner and nicer to work with so
let's go back
and then like i said i'm not interested
in any of these things over here
and we'll simply go with dot dot correct
that body i'm still sending the user
just because i want to showcase that
will be hashing the password but don't
worry that's also not a good practice to
send back the password so we won't do
that in a few seconds so let's go back
to our postman
we want to send it
and check it out we have john with john
blah blah blah and of course we have our
hashed value so our functionality still
works and the last thing that i want to
cover in this video notice the docs in
mongoose 5.0 blah blah blah next we can
go with async await well that simply
means that back in our user one
can just remove it and
what they're telling us in the docs that
it's still going to work so let's test
it out in this case i'm going to go with
john 2 since remember we have those
unique emails let's send it and we still
get the response so we know that that
works and if i go to my database now of
course i should
have quite a few users already there
with hash passwords apart from the first
one of course that is where the secret
is and now i can remove it
and we are good to go now we can hash
the password but we're doing that using
the mongoose middleware nice we're a
little bit familiar with mongoose
middleware so now let's continue with
our steps we're saving the user so we're
good on that and now of course we just
want to generate the token and send back
the response
and we'll first set up functionality
again in the controller so we're clear
on what's happening and next video i'll
show you another nifty setup that we can
use with mongoose and like i already
previously mentioned this should feel
familiar because we spent the entire
project on that the jwt basics so if we
go back to the controllers in the fifth
project meaning the folder name is five
of course this is not the fifth project
and if we take a look at the main
check it out we go with jwt sign correct
and of course that is coming from our
library the json web token one then we
pass in whatever we want to pass it on
to the front end and of course later
we'll use the id to access the resources
that are associated with that user
then we pass in the jw secret one and in
this project i'll show you where we can
get a proper value and eventually we
pass in the options and we just say in
how long it expires so let's try to
recreate that back in the auth.js and
what are we looking for here we're
looking for the library of course now i
can remove the bcrypt because everything
is already set up in model so let's go
over here with jwt
we will set it equal to require of
course
and then we're looking for the package
the json web token one and then once we
create the user this is the case where
we want to create that token correct so
let's go over here with const and then
we'll go with token and for time being
i'll just pass in some random string and
then we'll set up properly everything
after that so let's go here with jwt
then we go with sine of course
and we want to pass in the data we want
to send back
and in my case again we'll go with id
and name so let's start with user id
that's just how i decided to call my
property here so user id is equal to
user so that's the user that i'm getting
back over here and remember on that
object we have id property correct and
if you want to double check it's right
over here this is what we're currently
sending back
and we go with underscore of course
and then we'll go with id
and again that's just my preference to
kind of separate the two otherwise you
have job id you have user id and many
more ids and then if you just keep using
this underscore in my opinion is just
harder to manage everything so that's
why i always go with user id job id or
whatever so that's the first thing that
i'm sending and next i want to send the
name
so i go with name and then again user
that's my object and the name and like i
said i'm just going to pass in some jwt
secret right away so i'm just going to
be cheating a little bit over here
and then we'll add a comma and then
let's go again with expression remember
this one was expires in 30 days so use
the same value and of course a little
bit later i'll talk about other options
as well so let's go here let's say
expires and in
and i'll set it equal to
30 days
then we save and of course instead of
sending back the user i want to send
back the token
and this is the case where as always
there's multiple setups that you can
have
you can send back maybe only the token
or you can be like hey
maybe my front end needs the name
directly now what am i talking about if
i go back to the application
that i built for this project
if i go to login
and of course more specifically i'm
going to be looking for register and
then i'll try to use
some kind of values here
that are not already a database so i'm
going to go with anna
and maybe let's add a tube because then
for sure everything is going to work
once i submit
not only i'm going to get back token i'm
going to say here never i'll also get
back the name but again this really
depends on the setup that you have on a
front end you can send back only the
token and actually there are setups
where the front end
decodes the token instead instead of me
sending here a name and set it equal to
username front end decodes the token now
it's not going to be our case but just
keep in mind that's why you don't ever
want to store anything here as far as
the secrets because as far as the coding
you can actually do that now of course
when it comes to verifying
that's where you need that jwt secret
but as far as decoding yes there are
some setups where front-end just decodes
and gets whatever property it needs so
in my case the jobs app i'm also looking
for the user and more specifically the
name property but hopefully it is clear
that in this case it's just my
preference when i was building the
front-end app
when it comes to response what you
definitely want to send back is the
token because that of course will allow
that user to access resources on the
server later on so my guess i'm going to
go with user so that's going to be
another property i'm sending and in this
case of course i'll access my user
object and i'm just going to be looking
for a name so i'll have another property
there by the name of name and then i'll
set it equal to user and then name and
of course now i just need to add a comma
and we're successfully sending the token
and again let's test it out in a postman
first
so i'm gonna go here with john3
at gmail.com we send it back now notice
we're not sending back the password
anymore and of course i'm getting the
user as well as the token and just to
reiterate on the front end of course i'm
using the ana over here so in react i
set the state and i set up the state
value just to showcase that notice over
here i have my reducer blah blah blah i
have user and notice the name of course
that is anna and i'm accessing that
right from the response
and then when it comes to the token
you'll have multiple options and one of
them is going to be storing it in a
local storage so now of course in the
local storage not only i have the name
so that way when i refresh of course i
can still showcase data but i also get
the token so when i'll be making future
requests on behalf of anna of course
i'll have the token hopefully it is
clear and now of course we can take a
look at another solution that mongoose
provides to make our code cleaner
awesome and to complete our register
functionality
let's learn about schema instance
methods
in mongos so i'm going to navigate to
the docs in this case we're looking for
schemas
and if we take a look at the list
we see this instance method
and essentially what happens
every document we create we can have
functions on them so these are going to
be instances of course of our schema
correct and the way we set up those
functions we go with
the schema name then methods and then
whatever function you want so
essentially once i create that user over
here in the register
that user will have a function and you
can probably already guess that we'll
create a function
that just generates that token and of
course in that function we'll pretty
much have the same code and therefore we
won't have to bother with that in the
actual controller in the register
controller and let's start somewhat
silly where i want to go back to my
model the user one and let's just go
with user schema
so of course that is the name that stays
the same then we go with methods and
then let's just say
get name
so let's imagine that we're just lazy
getting the username and we have
multiple options we can set it up as
async
or we can just set it up as a regular
function so in this case we'll just go
with a regular function so no async
keyword but again we do want to use this
function keyword not a our function
because that way this will always point
to our document
and with get name simply what do i want
to do i want to return
this dot and name and now of course we
just want to go back to auth.js
and where we have user.name let's just
invoke let's say user
and we're going to be looking for get
name so invoke this one and now let's go
to the postman and let's try to send it
so i'll navigate back i'll send it and
because i wasn't careful of course i
didn't pay attention to my email so of
course i need to change it to
john4gmail.com
and i can clearly see that i still have
the name so if i'll change this one
around then if i'll say anna
and maybe i'll go with
anna gmail.com
then i'll still be able to access the
name and what that means is that we can
generate the token using the instance
method instead so again we're trying to
keep all our logic in one place where we
have the user schema instead of
scattered around
our controllers and let's just fix
everything back we'll say username
we'll stay with that for time being of
course we can cut it out and i think
we'll retype one more time from scratch
just so we can get comfortable with jwt
now i'm not gonna need the import here
for the token anymore so i can
definitely cut it out i have my user
awesome and eventually i'll invoke a
method that will get me that token so
now let me save auth.js
back in the user of course the name is
not going to be get name
and you know what i'll just set up
everything from scratch i'll say user
schema
then again the syntax is methods and
then we're looking for the function name
and in this case i'll call this create
jwt and again it's going to be a simple
function here and as far as the logic
we'll just return right away jwt sign
and of course in here i need to get the
library so let's go with jwt at the top
and then
jwtc sign and again remember in the
function we can access the document how
well by using this correct and as far as
the payload again i'm going to go with
user id then i'll set it equal to this
and underscore id so this points to the
document and then we're going to go with
comma
name and then we'll just go with this
dot name and again we'll just cheat a
little bit where i'll say
jwt secret and then as far as the
expression again we'll keep it at 30
days so expires
and we'll set it equal to 30 days so now
if i go back to auth.js i simply want to
call create
jwt that's it that's all we have to do
so once we create the user of course we
have that instance method and here i can
just say token
and i'm going to go user and of course
the name of the method is create
and jwt we invoke it and now of course
we can go back to our postman now we
already have one anna
and let's just change the name just so
we can see that it works we'll go maybe
with peter
and i'll set it here as peter as well
and then once we send of course
now i have the peter as well as the
token and of course that means that
everything works and successfully we're
done with our register controller and in
the process we learned about hashing the
passwords setting up the mongoose
middleware as well as the instance
methods on a schema all right and once
we're good with register route like
promised let's swing back to the json
web tokens and the first thing i want to
talk about is the expression so remember
in options we go with expires in and as
far as default setup so if we just
provide a number this is going to be in
seconds
now if we provide a string
then we need to make sure that we add
time units whether that's days hours and
all that
otherwise it's going to be interpreted
as milliseconds so if you go something
like this
string of 120 it's going to be equal to
120 milliseconds and of course we'll
return to this one once we start
refreshing the tokens and all that cool
stuff for now just be aware that by
default it's going to be seconds unless
you provide a string with a time unit
that should do it for expires in and as
far as that secret string
yeah you can get away with jw secret but
of course a more proper setup is
generating some kind of more secure key
and i prefer using all keys generator
dot com again this is a free one of
course if you want you can donate and
all that but you can use it for free
you're looking for encryption key and
then more specifically you're looking
for 256 bit one and then of course you
can get the value and just take that
value and stick it in the dot env file
and as a side note we can also set the
expires in ind ind.env as well and
actually this is exactly what we'll do
right now so let's navigate back to our
project i'm looking for dot envy and
then i want to set up two values i want
to go with jwt underscore
secret and that is going to be of course
equal to my encrypted one and then the
second thing that i want is that
expiration and as far as the name i
think i'm going to go with jwt
jwt underscore
and lifetime
and now of course once i have both of
these things and as i know of course i
need to set it to some kind of value so
in my case i'm going to go back to my 30
days and once i save both of them
now of course i just need to spin up the
server
and i'll be able to access that in my
user model and once my server is up and
running i can just go back over here
and instead of hard coding
simply go with process
dot env and in this case of course i'm
looking for jwt underscore secret and
then as far as expires in i'm gonna go
with my value and again we're looking
for process dot env and we're looking
for jwt
and lifetime or however you called your
variable
and once we have both of these in place
now of course let's test it out just to
make sure that we don't have any silly
bugs
and let's go with peter
and we'll set it up as 23. i send and
everything is correct so once i have all
of this in place now of course we can
switch gears and set up the login
functionality beautiful once we can
successfully register the user
now of course let's worry about the
login functionality
and
honestly
we have covered pretty much all of the
things apart from checking the password
so of course since we're using a library
to hash the password of course we want
to compare it as well
now since that involves creating another
instance method we'll actually do that
in next video in this video simply want
to check whether we're getting the email
and the password with some kind of
values because that's the whole setup
for the logging in in this case they
don't need to provide name they just
need to provide email and a password if
they don't we send back the bad request
one
after that we'll check for the user in
our database so basically we'll go with
our user and find one and we'll pass in
the email
and if we can find one
then of course we'll send back the user
and if not then of course we'll send
back another error and let's start here
by removing that not send i'll close the
sidebar here and let's start by const
email and password and this is the case
where i'll do the checking the initial
checking right in the controller and
i'll actually cover
why that's my preference in this case
once we're done setting up compare
passwords functionality so first in the
request i'm looking for email and
password and right out of the gate i'll
say if no email
or if no password
then of course we'll go with our bad
request and of course we'll do that in
if block and we'll say throw
new and we already have the import for
battlequest so we just go with bad
request error and we just need to
provide a message please
provide
email
and password
and once i have this one in place then
of course we want to check for the user
correct how do we check for user well we
have the model we have the user model
and on it we have a method by the name
of find one so let's come up with some
kind of variable name and microsoft's
going to be user and we'll go with await
of course it is asynchronous then we go
with user dot and find one
and then instead of passing in the id
and all that we'll pass in the email so
whatever we're getting from the user
we'll just pass it in here and
effectively at this point we have two
options
if the user exists
awesome then of course we can send back
the response with the username as well
as we can create token of course
now if the user doesn't exist then of
course we want to throw another error
now in this case though we're not going
to be throwing bad request error in this
case if there is no user then of course
we'll send back the unauthenticated
error because in this case the user is
not providing valid credentials and
that's a big difference so let's go back
to auth.js of course we want to import
that so in here let's go with on
authenticated error
that's the class we're looking for and
in here let's check and eventually
there's also going to be code for
comparing
the password
but like i said we'll do that in next
video so that is still coming up for now
we'll just say
if there is no user then please throw
that error
throw new and again we're looking for
our auth error and we'll simply say
invalid credentials credentials and once
we have taken care of this now of course
we want to create the token because if
we go past this error that means that
user is there user exists and remember
the instance method we created in the
previous videos the create token one or
create jwt don't remember i believe it
was create jwt of course we want to
invoke it and essentially we want to
send back the same response so the same
response as we sent when we registered
the user so if user exists let's create
that token and of course we'll go with
user
create
jwt we invoke it we get back to token
and now it's the same deal we go with
status now in this case we want to go
with status codes and it's not going to
be 201 it's going to be 200 and of
course that one is the okay one and then
as far as the json same deal also in my
setup on my front end i'm looking for
the name property so not to be redundant
but you always want to send back the
token but optionally you want to include
some more things as well and in my case
those more things is just a username so
go with user
for name of course the property and then
username and then comma
and of course in here we're looking for
a token
so right after the name we'll go token
and of course that is equal to the token
that we're getting back from create
token and now of course we can go and
check it out in the postman
so let's go back over here i believe we
just created peter 23
so now let's just test it out i'll
create a new route
so let's say here new route it's still
going to be a post route of course
and as far as the url again we're
looking for our global variable
forward slash and it's going to be auth
and of course in this case it's a login
one and then let's just grab these
values over here
let's say that we'll take the name email
as well as the password and of course we
won't use the name
but we can nicely copy and paste just to
save a little bit of time copy and paste
and of course
forgot about my curlies so let's place
it here properly everything
and this is turning out to be a mess
okay
i set up everything correctly over here
and i don't need the name
and i'm just going to be sending the
peter 23 with a secret again for time
being we're really just checking whether
that secret is there i'll save it and
i'll say in the jobs one
and we'll say login user
and then let's test it out
cursor here still have the body yes
everything is correct and of course i'm
getting back to peter
now if i'll do some mistakes
if for example i'll remove the password
we should get the 400 one and that's the
please provide email and password okay
that's good let me add the password and
now let's mess up the email instead of
23 i'll go to and now of course i have
invalid credentials and of course the
error in this case is 401 so our base
functionality works really great the
only thing that's left to do in here is
just to compare the password using our
library and if you remember the library
name was bcrypt js not bad not bad we
can register user we can almost log in
and the reason why i say almost because
of course the moment as long as there's
some kind of value for the password
we're actually sending back the token so
now let's fix that let's actually
compare the password and this is that
interesting thing where you might be
like okay but wait a minute
back when we were registering of course
we were hashing this password correct we
went with gensalt and then hash and the
deal is following where essentially we
have our library we have the package
dbcrypt1 and in the beaker package of
course there is a function by the name
of compare
and it compares
the hashed passwords so again it's a
one-way street once we hash the password
that's it
but with compare method we compare those
hash passwords and of course if they
match awesome we send back the token and
user has successfully logged in and of
course keep in mind that we can set up
this functionality right over here but
why we would want to do that if we
already know how to set up the instance
methods so instead of jamming more code
in the login controller we'll simply go
over here and i'll say user schema
and of course we need to go with methods
and then as far as the name i'm going to
go with check password or compare
password again naming is really up to
you
in my case i'm gonna go maybe with
compare password sounds a little bit
more sophisticated and this is going to
be a sync function
and then this function is going to be
looking for one argument and that of
course is going to be the password
that's coming with a request
and i'm just going to name this one
candidate password
and password
and then as far as the function body i
want to come up with some kind of
variable and in my case i will call this
is match and we'll set it equal to a
weight because we can run the compare
method asynchronously and we'll say
await again the package name is bcrypt
of course and then the method name
is compare and then in the compare we'll
pass in two things
we'll pass in the password so the
candidate password essentially the
password that is coming in with a
request and after the comma of course
we'll get the password from the document
of course the one that is already saved
in a database so let's go back to the
compare and we'll just go with candidate
password so again the one that's coming
in with the request and of course in
order to access the document password we
simply go to this dot and we provide the
password and then what we want to return
from the function is the match so let's
say here returned and is match and once
we have the function in place
now we simply want to go back to
auth.js and if we can see that we have
the user we also want to set up one more
if statement where we'll check the
password so now of course i can move
this comment down and i can say if there
is a user i also want to check whether
the password matches and we can do that
by going with const and then come up
with some kind of variable is password
correct and of course we need to go with
a weight because our function is
asynchronous then we're looking for the
user so of course this only happens if
we have a user if we don't have the user
then we right away send back invalid
credentials and here we'll go with check
or i'm sorry compare password of course
i went with sophisticated name then we
pass in the password that we're getting
from the user and now of course we want
to do the same thing where we want to
check
if the password is correct
then of course we just return a token
and all that if not then we'll throw the
error
and i'll just speed this up and we'll
copy and paste and we'll do the same
thing
if the password is false meaning
if we get back is match as false then of
course we'll just throw this error and
now let's go and test it out in the
postman so at this point i have email as
well as the password and they should be
correct so let's send it here and of
course i get back the response but
if i start messing with the values for
example if i go
with a wrong email now of course i'll
get invalid credentials so let's set it
back to 23 and then if we do the same
thing with the password we'll also get
back the same message so notice here we
have this invalid credentials now if i
provide the correct values the correct
email as well as the password then of
course everything is great and we get
back the token now lastly you're
probably wondering okay but why did you
check over here right in the controller
because technically we need to
understand that yes if there is no email
of course we'll get that mongo's error
correct well let me showcase something
so i'll comment this one out so
basically now we're not checking for
empty values
and let me provide the correct one let
me say that yeah the correct email is
going to be peter 23 yay area but i'll
remove the password
and essentially once i send i get back
this error response but it is empty so
let's go over the
reasons why is that happening well if we
take a look at the user of course we
have the compare one and this one will
throw an error it will throw an error
because of course we're passing in the
empty value correct back in auth.js
we're getting back the password but
password is just empty string
and we are getting the error and we are
actually handling that error
in our error middleware so let's go back
over here the error handler we are
handling it over here and i can actually
showcase that can go with log
and we can cancel log the error and
again let me send one more time and in
the console you'll see the error and
again it is thrown
by our library notice here legal
arguments undefined and i just find it
easier to check it right over here or
something we'll learn later to set up a
validation layer and again that is all
coming up for time being i just find it
easier to check for that error right
here for those empty values and then
just send back the response instead of
chasing it in error handler can that
just my preference of course if you
don't like this setup you don't have to
use it but that's my explanation for
using this bad request over here
hopefully everything is clear as far as
the register and login and now of course
we can move on to our next step all
right and once the login register are in
place as far as auth the last thing we
need is auth middleware where we can
verify the token and if everything is
correct and get the user id and pass it
along to the job routes now the
functionality is going to be exactly the
same like in the previous project i
might just use different variable names
here and there and to answer your
question yes
i'll purposely retype everything from
scratch
just because i find repetition to be
very important aspect of learning now if
you don't agree with my opinion
essentially you have two options you can
just copy and paste the code from the
previous project and i'll show you of
course where you can get it in a second
or make this a challenge and try to
recreate everything from scratch
yourself and of course if you get stuck
utilize the previous project code or
this video lecture and of course the
code that i'm talking about is this one
if you navigate to folder number five
the jwt basics one and then more
specifically if you look in the
middleware of course you'll find the
middleware that we are about to set up
and now of course i'll close everything
and i'll start from scratch so i'm
looking in the star looking for the
middleware and i'm going to go for my
authentication one
and first let's start with imports and
essentially we're looking for the user
first so that's going to be our model so
let's go with require
and i believe this was two levels up so
let me look in my models
and of course user okay that's good then
i want to go with my jwt because of
course we want to verify the token so
let's go over here with require and the
package name is jsonwebtoken and the
last thing that i want is the
unauthenticated error which of course is
coming from my errors and this is the
case probably
where it's going to be faster if i just
copy and paste so let me take a look at
index.js
and of course
the name is right here
so let me import this from my errors and
again i think i'll have to go two levels
up so let me take a look at
require and we're looking at the errors
folder and since we have index.js you
already know that we don't need to
specify the path we just simply say
errors
and with all of this in place now of
course what we want to do is go with
const auth so that's going to be our
middleware and of course it's going to
be a function
and it's going to be looking for three
things the iraq res and next and then as
far as the function body remember the
first thing we want to do is check for
the header so let's add here the comment
and we're looking for a header first for
the authorization one and then we want
to check whether it starts with bearer
so first i'm going to set up the
variable and i'll say auth
header and that is equal to require
errors
and the authorization one of course and
then after that i'm looking for if
statement and in here i want to check
if it doesn't exist if there is no
header then of course we'll throw the
error or
if it doesn't start with better so let's
go over here with mouth header and we'll
go with starts with so of course that's
the javascript method that we can use on
a string and then we go with better and
in some setups you'll see this space
added as well but
honestly it doesn't really matter
because remember
once we are done with if statement we're
still getting the token and if there's
going to be no space then of course the
token won't make sense we won't be able
to verify the token we're splitting the
token anyway
and let's go over here with throw new
and of course we're looking for on
authenticated error and as far as the
text let's go with authentication
and invalid
and you know we'll also need to add here
async so let's add over here async now
we're checking for the header as well as
the bearer and if one of them is false
then of course we throw the error and
once we're done with that let's go with
our token so let's say kant's token is
equal to auth error and then remember
we're splitting it
and we're splitting it on the empty
space and then we're looking for the
second value that's why we go with one
so we turn this into array and then
we're looking for the second item in
array and this is what i'm saying so
even if you omit this and if you just
check for the better if the user has
sent bearer and then right away token
well
this one won't make sense because
basically this will be undefined
we won't be able to split the string and
of course if that's the case we won't be
able to verify hopefully that is clear
so let's go over here with try catch and
then as far as the try block we'll try
to get the payload so let's say over
here payload and remember the method
name is jwt and verify and here we want
to pass in two things we want to pass in
the token comma and then of course we're
looking for process dot env
and then jwt underscore secret
and now of course once i have the
payload i just want to pass it along to
the job routes and in order to do that
we'll first add a comment attach
the user to the job route and then as
far as the logic we can simply set up a
reg.user so i'm right away setting up
the property on a request object
and as far as the value is in there i'm
going to go with user id again that's
just my preference and then i'll go with
payload so this is what i'm getting back
from the verify and of course in there
i'll have the user id as well and
technically we won't use the name
but just for testing i'll pass in the
name as well so let's say here name and
again we're looking for payload and then
that name and again if you're a little
bit confused essentially in here we're
just getting the payload that we're
setting up in the route so if we take a
look at our index routes i'm sorry not
the index roads if we're looking at the
author outs
and notice here when we're creating the
json web token right now of course the
functionality the actual functionality
is in the model so let me go over there
in the user essentially this is what
we're passing in we're passing in the
user id as well as the name so
in the authentication middleware of
course this is what we're getting back
and again this is just for testing
essentially in our controllers in the
job controllers of course we'll just use
the us id but since i want to showcase
that this is actually the same user also
pass in the name here as well and then
as far as the catch well we have the
error and we can just throw it we can
just say over here throw new and we'll
go with our error and essentially the
text is going to be exactly the same so
i'll just take it from here and copy and
paste and before i let you go of course
remember that we need to do two things
we need to export the auth as well as we
need to invoke the next because
otherwise we won't get to the job routes
anyway so let's go over here with next
first so now of course we pass along the
user to the job routes and we need to go
with module
exports
and then we're looking for auth
and i'll set up the actual middleware as
well as test it out in next video all
right and once the auth middleware is in
place now of course we just need to
decide
where we're going to place it because if
you remember the previous project we
only had one
authenticated route and of course we
just used the router for that
and technically we can do the same thing
over here in jobs but we just need to
understand that of course in this case
we want to authenticate
all the routes so basically we want to
protect all of them because if i create
a job
i only want to look at my jobs and i
don't want you to modify my jobs or
you probably don't want me to modify
yours so essentially what i'm saying we
want to add that protected route
for all of them so we want to protect
all of our routes as far as the jobs not
just one of them so technically you can
say yeah well okay we can import and
then we can just add them one by one and
technically it is an option but there's
actually a better one
if we go to app.js take a look we have
app.use and then of course we have
all the job routes and in this scenario
what we can do we can just get the
middleware and then stick it in front of
the jobs router and with that in place
all of our jobs routes will be protected
so instead of going one by one
we just do that in app.js and as a
result we'll protect
all the job routes so let's do it we're
going to go where we have the connect
and above or below doesn't really matter
i'll say authenticate
user
and we'll go with require and of course
i'm looking for my middleware
and in there i'm looking for
authentication one and then we scroll
down
we go with authenticate user pass the
comma and we're good to go
and in order to test it we'll go to the
controllers over here and since we'll
start working in create job anyway i'll
look for
create job and we'll just test it out
and we'll test it out in the following
way where i'll go with res.json
and let's just pass here rec dot user
so i'm getting that user from my auth
one if everything is correct and of
course i should be able to see the user
as well as the id so let me save it over
here and as a side note i actually
removed all my current users e in the
database just so we can start nicely
from scratch because as we were setting
them up we used the dummy string and
then we set up the proper one just so we
don't get any dumb bugs i also suggest
to do the same work remove all the users
and we'll start everything from the
scratch so now of course i want to go to
the postman i already have the register
route correct so let's just get the
token first so of course i go with name
email and password i get the token
awesome
that's what i wanted and now of course
we want to set up a new route now again
this is going to be a post route to
create a job so let's go over here let's
say new route we're looking for the post
method
and we use the same url of course and
then if you remember
the difference was that for jazz we just
go with forward slash and jobs and if
you want to double check just go to
app.js first notice that's the path
again this is already part of our
variable the url one then we have the
jobs and then of course in the routes as
far as the post well that's going to be
a route anyway so that's going to be the
forward slash now for getting the single
job deleting and all that then of course
we'll pass in the route parameters as
well but for the post it's simply
forward slash which just means that we
go with url and then the jobs now we're
really not concerned with the body
because we're just testing whether our
authentication works but what we do need
to get is authorization over here and my
apologies i'm actually looking for the
headers and the reason why i'm showing
you the authorization because
at the end of this project or maybe in
few videos i'll show you how we can set
this up dynamically so you don't have to
every time just copy and paste the user
token because we need to understand that
of course we can use
multiple users correct and you don't
want to copy and paste
every time that token so i'll show you a
dynamic way how we can set that up but
not yet so let's go here where we have
the headers again we're looking for the
authorization one
and then we want to go with bearer and
we want to pass in the token and once i
send if everything is correct
check it out i have the user id which
should match to whatever id i have in
the database and of course i'm not going
to check value by value but hopefully
you understand the idea where these ones
should match this one and the one that i
have over there on the postman and i can
clearly see the name so what happens if
i go with different user
if i register this user instead
and let's go with anna here again the
same secret we get different token
and now of course we should get
different name correct so in the jobs
i'll remove the john token
and i'll paste the ana one once i send
of course now i get back the ana so what
that means in any of the job routes i'll
have anna's id or john's id or whichever
token i'm getting and when it comes to
any of these functionalities
will only deal with the resources
that are associated with a user
hopefully we're on the same page and now
of course we can start setting up the
functionality
and once we're done setting up our auth
middleware i also want to mention
something where as you're looking at
someone else's code you might come
across this syntax
where instead of creating a object
like we are doing in line 20
what they do is they look for the user
in the database so they take the model
the user model and then either find by
id
or find one that also works and then of
course they just pass in the id that is
coming from the token
and in most cases they will use the
select to remove the password there's
really no point to pass this password to
the upcoming middleware meaning our
request
and therefore they just use the select
and remove it and then when it comes to
reg.user well i just set it equal to
this variable and it's definitely an
option but the reason why i'm not doing
that in this project is simply because
if we just think about it we really have
no functionality to remove that user
anyway so if i'm getting my id
from the token i'm pretty sure
that there is a user on the other side
again you might see this code and yes we
might implement ourselves in a future
project but not in this case i really
didn't see the point of looking for the
user since we have no functionality to
remove it in the first place now if you
do decide to go with this logic then of
course just make sure that you remove
line 20 because otherwise you're
overriding with our current setup anyway
awesome and once our auth is working now
essentially we want to set up a model
for the job
and of course work on rest of the routes
now before we set up the model though
let me also quickly save it
so this is going to be create job
so let's set up the name create
job and of course i'll set it in the
jobs one and i also want to test it out
really quickly
where if in headers i make that mistake
and i don't add the space what response
i get of course i have
authentication error so again this just
proves the point that i was making
before where essentially even if we omit
the space over here we still check the
token
and of course in that case we're not
able to split it meaning we are
splitting it but we're just getting
undefined and as a result our token is
undefined as well so hopefully that is
clear so now let me just navigate to the
models and i want to create
a job model and the first thing that i
want to do is set up the mongoose
and of course that is equal to require
and we're looking for a package the
mongoose one and after that let's just
set up our schema so let me close the
sidebar just so we have a little bit
more real estate so job schema
and that is equal to new mongoose
and schema
schema and here let's pass in the object
and as far as the properties i'm going
to have the company
and that will be equal to an object of
course type will be
set to string
then required will be true
and essentially we'll set it up as an
array of course and let's just say true
and as far as the message we'll go with
please
provide
company
and name and last thing that i want to
set up for the company's max length that
we can use
on strings
and in here
we'll set it up as 50. of course if you
want to go a different value be my guest
so let me take the company and we'll
copy and paste this one
one time and the second property we want
to set up is the position
it's going to be a string again
it will be required and in this case of
course we'll say position please provide
position as far as the max length in
this case let's maybe increase it in my
case i'm going to go 200
and then as far as the job interview
well there's always this status whether
it's pending so whether we're waiting
for response whether we already have the
interview or
it was declined correct
and essentially we want to do that using
the status property so comma status
and then again it's going to be an
object it's going to be a string but
we'll use that enum remember
option where we can set up the array
with a possible values so let's say here
enum and as far as possible values like
i said we'll go with interview
then declined
declined
and then last one will be pending and
this is going to be the case again where
on the front end will just provide these
two values the company one and position
when we are creating the job
so these are going to be the values that
are required however the status one we
will manipulate when we are modifying
the job so therefore we'll go with
status these are our options and then
like i said lastly we'll go default and
we'll set it equal to pending that's the
setup i'm going to have and then
probably the most most important
property that we haven't set up
is the created by why well because in
here
we'll tie our job
to the actual user and the way it's
going to look like we'll go here with
created
by again the name is really up to you
but that's set up that i have created by
and then type is not going to be string
or a number in fact it's going to be a
mongoose then types and then we're
looking for object and id so this is
very very important so essentially now
we're tying our job model to the user
one so we have the user model over here
correct so this is where we're creating
a user so every time we'll create a job
we will assign it to one of the users
and as a result of course our
functionality will work
because every job that we will create
will be associated with a user so first
we have a type and we need to go
mongoose types and then object id that's
going to be the type for our property
and then we need to go with ref and we
need to specifically say well which
model are we referencing and in this
case we'll go with user of course so i
want to tie the job to the user
hopefully that is clear and then of
course we want to go with required as
well because we don't want to create a
job without a user we'll set it equal to
true
and then as far as the value again let's
just go with please provide
and user and then lastly
right after the schema object the first
option that we have over here i want to
go with comma
and we'll set up timestamps and true and
i'll showcase them once we actually
start sending requests from the postman
because you'll see the benefit of using
timestamps right in the response so
don't worry about them for now i'll show
you once we start getting back the
responses and of course eventually what
we want to do is just go with module
exports and we want to set it equal to
mongos
then model
and then as far as the name i'm just
going to go with
job
and then we'll pass in the job schema
and once we have all of this in place
now of course we can focus on routes and
i guess let's start with the create job
one nice we have the model so now let's
just set up the functionality for
creating the job and then one by one
we'll deal with the rest of the
controllers as well
and in order to set everything up first
of course
from the postman we need to send the
data
and what data are we looking for again
let's jog our memory we have the job
model and here i'm looking for the
company name
as well as the position
now let's not worry about the created by
yet since that one we will get from our
auth middleware
and in here let's just set up some kind
of values in the body so let's go with
raw and we're going with json of course
and then here let's say company
company and then i'm just gonna go with
google because why not
and then as far as the position well
let's just go with intern so position
and then we pass in the intern
now let's go back to our controller
where we have the jobs one create job
and instead of sending back the user i
want to send back the wreck that body
again just so we can test whether
everything works so i have create job
route i send it here and of course i
have invalid authentication because
i didn't fix my better one so let me go
back and let me just add that space and
now everything should work where of
course i'm getting the values for the
company as well as deposition
so now what's left to do is go back to
create job and of course in here we want
to import
finally our model correct and we want to
create a new one so let's do that we're
going to go at the top here
and we'll create our imports and
effectively we're looking for three
things i want to get the status codes i
want to get the job model
as well as the requests and for requests
we have two options we have bad request
error as well as not found one so let's
go with khan's job so that's going to be
my model so require
and of course we're looking in the
models here and more specifically job
then we want to get the status codes so
const and then status codes now that is
coming from our library of course
so require an http status code and then
lastly we have those two errors so let's
go here with bad
request
an error
and the second one will be the not found
one so not
found error
and both of them are coming
from
and of course the errors
so let's go two levels up and we're
looking in the errors folder
and once we have all the imports in
place we'll swing back to create job and
essentially the idea is following
where of course
at the moment i'm just passing in the
ragdot body e and the json response
correct
and if you remember what was the method
name to create new document well that
was of course create and of course in
this case we're looking for the job one
correct so the way the setup is going to
look like we're going to go with job
then we'll await of course and then we
go with model name and create and we
pass indirect that body but the moment
what we're missing is that user and
where is the user located of course it
is located in the rec dot user now what
are we really looking for is the id
correct so what we want to do here is
just go with rec dot body again if you
want a console log of course you can
definitely do so but i'm just going to
skip that part and we'll go with
reg.body then we want to create
onrec.body a new property by the name of
created by why well because
in our job model that's how i called my
property
so i add this property
onrac.body and where is it located it's
located in rec
user and the property name is user id
like so so now of course once we pass
indirect that body will still have the
validations but if everything is correct
we create a new job and now of course we
just need to handle that as far as
response so let's just set up
res.status now again this is going to be
the created one so let's go with status
codes
status codes then we go with comma or
i'm sorry d dot and then we go with
created and then as far as the json i
just want to send back the job so let's
go over here and let's test it out so
now i'm getting back the company and
position but if everything is correct i
should get way more than that and once
we send unfortunately
instead of getting back to job i get
back the error where it says
created by
and it is a validation error which
actually just showcases that our
validation still works which is really
really good and the problem of course is
in here where i went with reg.body and
it should be created by not created by
so let me save and let me test it out
one more time and once i send
now of course i'm getting back the job
and as far as the job i have the status
so like i said by default it's going to
be pending so this is going to be the
job id and this is very very important
that's why on the auth i set up that
user id and that's why also when i was
setting up djs and web token i prefer
using that user id once you start
building a bigger application you'll get
bunch of these underscore ids and it
gets confusing quite fast and therefore
i prefer setting up that extra piece of
code where i go with user id or job id
or whatever and if you keep looking at
it okay you can see the google you can
see the position
all that is nice but you're also
probably noticing the created by and
essentially this points to anna and of
course what that means is that now this
job will always always be tied to anna
so once i register and log in and get my
token and all that
i won't be able to modify look at it or
whatever and you're probably noticing
these ones as well
the created at and updated that and
effectively we get them by default once
we set up timestamps as true
so mongoose schemas have that timestamps
option that tells mongoose to
automatically manage create that and
update it at properties on our documents
so that means is that of course we don't
need to set them up manually and you can
probably already guess that this one
will always point to the time when the
document was created and this one will
change as we're updating and of course
we can use these properties for example
in filters and essentially this is
exactly what we'll do when we're getting
all the jobs and once we can
successfully get back our first job i
want to congratulate you on pretty much
getting over the biggest hurdle because
from now on everything is going to be
exactly the same like we worked in the
previous projects the only difference of
course as far as the controllers will
always always get that user id as well
because of course we'll need to use it
to search for jobs to update jobs and
all that cool stuff awesome and once we
can create the job now of course let's
worry about the rest of the
functionality
and let's do it one by one so next one
up we have get all jobs
now in order to get the jobs we already
know the method that is find which is of
course available on the model however in
this case when it comes to the filter
object of course we'll pass in created
by property and we'll set it equal to
the user because what we want
is to get only the jobs that are
associated with the user and i know that
i keep pretty much repeating the same
thing and my apologies for that but that
is very very crucial in this case we're
not looking for all the jobs like we did
in a task we're only looking for the
jobs that are associated with this user
and as far as the functionality it goes
something like this where we'll go with
jobs that is equal to a weight
and then we'll go with job find and
remember the filter object and remember
if it was empty then of course we're
just getting all the jobs but that's not
what we want
in here we want to say created by and we
want to set it equal to rec
user and user id again that user
property here is going to be on every
request since in the app.js
we placed our off middleware in front of
all of our jobs routes and then let's
also sort quickly and let's sort based
on creator that remember this property
the creator that let's sort based on
that
so let's say here dot
sort
and let's just pass in the property
created at
and as far as the response well let's
just go with res dot status
and as far as the status codes of course
we'll be looking for okay one still
status codes and then okay and when it
comes to json response
i want to send back the jobs as well as
the count because that's what i'm
looking for on my front end again this
is really optional you can of course
send just jobs but in my case i want to
send both and once i have all of this in
place
now of course we can go back to the
postman i'll save both routes the
register user as well as create job and
you know what why don't we create a few
more jobs
so in here we'll say apple
and we'll say front-end developer
developer and then let's create one more
and this one will be facebook
as far as the developer let's just say
backend one so let's send it here
and once i send i want to check my
database and there i have jobs okay
that's good
and as far as anna i believe i'm setting
up everything as anna i have the one for
google one for apple as well as the
facebook and once i have all of these
jobs in place now of course we can
create a new route so let me save it
over here
and let's just go with get route in this
case of course and we're looking for url
and this is going to go to the same one
as create job so we simply go with
forward slash
and jobs
and of course we just send it and if
everything is correct we should get
authentication invalid why because of
course we do need to include the header
so let me go back to the headers
let's go to authorization so now of
course we know that our middle works
we cannot just randomly access
all the jobs you can only access your
jobs and then let's go with bearer
and then let's pass in the token that we
have for anna again i'll show you in a
second how we can set this up
programmatically so we don't have to
copy and paste every time so let's say
here bearer let's send and now of course
i have jobs array with the count off
three and i can clearly see that all the
info is correct all right and once we
can create the job as well as get all
jobs
why don't we set up that token
dynamically in the postman because as
we'll be creating more users and of
course add more functionality it's going
to get annoying quite fast if we'll have
to copy and paste each and every time
that token value
and first what i did is saved the
request the get all jobs one and as you
can see that's the name and of course i
saved it in
jobs api and as far as the setup it's
going to go something like this where
we'll start in login user and then we'll
repeat the same in register but for time
being i just don't want to worry about
setting up those unique emails so let's
go over here where we have the login
user and we're looking for a test
and we just need to add a little bit of
code first we want to access the
response that we're getting back notice
of course if we're successful if we have
logged in then of course we'll get back
to token correct and in order to get
that we'll just set up some kind of
variable in my case i'm going to go with
json data and we need to go with pm so
postman and then dot and we're looking
for response
and in there we have a function by the
name of json and then let's just go with
our token value and let's set up our
global variable and notice here on right
hand side we actually have snippets so
if we want to set up a new global
variable we just click it and now we
just need to provide the values
and effectively the name is going to be
access token
and then as far as the value this is
where we go with json data dot and of
course i know that in my responses token
is going to be located in token property
so simply go with a token
and now of course once we send we should
see in the globals a new variable and of
course we do and the only thing that's
left to do is to go to either get all
jobs or create job doesn't really matter
we can go here and instead of
authorizing that manually
i'll unclick it and then we're looking
for authorization
then we want to go with bearer so
probably you have by default here this
inherit just go to better token one and
then as far as the value well this is
where you want to access that global one
correct so you just go here with access
token and now once we send we should
get back the job now of course i created
with the same values if i check the body
so i have facebook and backend developer
so if i take a look at my database
and if i refresh i should have two
values i'll have one that i created
before and the second of course was
created when we're testing this dynamic
setup and of course we can do the same
thing with get all jobs as well so let's
take a look we have the headers here and
i'm sorry i'm looking in the wrong place
so we have the headers here let's remove
it let's check the authorization again
we have better token we're using access
token and then once we send in the body
now we should get four jobs and in order
for everything to work we also need to
do that in the register user so let's go
back quickly to the login one let's grab
these two lines of code then we'll go to
register one again we have the tests
let's save it here as well and now let's
try to create another user so let's go
to i believe in the body right this is
where we were creating a new user
and i'm going to go back to my good old
peter
peter at gmail.com we send we get back
the token and now the moment of truth
if i create a job
and let's just say in this case netflix
and then it's still going to be a
back-end developer now this one should
be created for peter and again notice
how we don't need to worry about those
headers anymore so let's go back to our
database
let's refresh and if everything is
correct i should have a user by the name
of peter that i created of course
there it is there's my peter and if i
take a look at the jobs
peter should also have a job so i keep
scrolling and yes there is i have the
netflix one and of course it is a
back-end developer so if i take a look
at get all jobs now of course i should
get only one that is associated with
peter so let me go back to get all jobs
let me send and now of course i have
count of one so hopefully it is clear
that now we're dynamically setting that
access token so you don't need to
manually do that each and every time and
once we have all of this in place now of
course we can continue with our
application beautiful and once we can
set up the access token dynamically in
the postman now of course let's keep on
working on our routes
and next one up we have get job and i
think this is going to be the case where
i'll actually log in back in as anna so
where i have the login user out i'll
just go with anna now of course i get
this token just because she has more
jobs now let me save all of these routes
since i don't want to set up everything
from the scratch
and then once i have logged in as anna
let me just double check get all the
jobs yep i have four of them and then
remember for get job
what we'll need to pass of course that
is going to be the route parameter
correct this is where we'll provide the
id and if you want to double check that
just go back to the routes we're looking
for the jobs one and notice so the post
and get all jobs
is for the root and then we have the
forward slash and then colon and then
the eddy of course this is going to be
that route parameter which will get me
that single job
make sure that i can delete one as well
as update one
and in order to test it out whether our
basic functionality works essentially
whether we can get that silly string we
need to go back to the postman and i
think i'll just leave the login user one
and then i'll open up a new tab we're
looking for get request of course
then we go over here with our url
and then forward slash and this is where
i want to pass in the eddy so in get all
jobs as far as the response of course
will get back those ids correct and now
if i want that one single job i just
need to take underscore id again you're
not looking for the user here you're
looking for underscore id which just
signals a job id so copy this one then
go back to the get one the one will get
the single request and remember we still
need to go with authorization we need to
set up better token and of course we'll
use the access token and once we send if
everything is correct
of course we should get route doesn't
exist because i was pretty smart and i
forgot to add the jobs one so let's go
over here and let's say
jobs and then once we send now of course
we have get single job so we know that
this functionality works and of course
now we just need to go back to our
controller and in here i'm going to be
looking for two things in the request
first we need to remember that as far as
the jobs we can access it in the params
object that's going to be the job id
and when it comes to user of course that
one is located in the user object that
we're getting from the middleware so
let's destructure both of these things
because
as our functionality gets more complex i
think it's easier if we can clearly see
where we're getting those values from so
i'm going to structure my request object
and in there i'm looking for two things
i'm looking for the user object and
remember in the user object i have the
user id so now of course we're doing the
nested destructuring so i'm looking for
that first
and then what i want is the params so
this one of course is provided by the
express and then more specifically we're
looking for the id now why we're looking
for id because that's how i called it
over here and then since i want to have
more clarity on which one is which i'll
right away give it an alias of
job id like so so now we have both we
have the job id from the params
so this one is coming
from here and then since we have the
access token now of course we can also
access the id of anna
and then it's simply a logic of
finding that one job
where the id is the job id as well as
created by is equal to the user id and
if the job doesn't exist
then we'll throw this error because
remember
we have two types of error either we'll
get a casting error where the syntax
doesn't match to that of the mongoose
object id
or
simply we just pass in some kind of
wrong job id and then of course if
everything is correct then we send back
the job so let's try it out we're going
to be looking for the job and that will
be equal to a weight of course
then we go with our model name and then
we go with find one that's the method
name and then in here in the filter
object we pass in underscore id which is
equal to our job id first now of course
in here the order is not important
but we do want to check for both
otherwise somebody can just get the id
and then they can access the job so
let's go to created by
and we'll set it equal to our user id
and then like i said we have two options
for errors either we have a casting
error which will handle a little bit
later as far as the nice responses or we
simply have a case where we provided
some wrong id and we'll simply check
that by saying if there is no job then
we'll throw our new error and of course
we're looking for not found one
and then we'll pass in the actual text
with the job id so let's say no
job with id and since i'm using template
string i can right away access it and
i'm going to be looking for my job id
now if everything is correct then of
course we'll get back the entire job so
say here res dot status which we're
looking for are status codes then we'll
go with okay and then we'll go with json
and i'll send back the job now of course
we can just test it out in our postman
where instead of this get single job i
should get the job that matches that id
in this case i'm getting the google one
so now let me double check where i have
all the jobs
and i'm gonna be looking for well these
ones technically are both the same so
let me look for the apple one
and i'll grab the id that's the job id
again keep that in mind that is very
very important we're not looking for the
user id
and once i send of course i should get
back the apple and if you get the same
results then of course we can move on to
our next step awesome and up next we
have update job and essentially i can
tell you right away that a lot of the
stuff that we already wrote in get job
will repeat over here so therefore in
order to speed this up a little bit of
course i will do some copy and pasting
here as well
and in order to test it out
i'm just going to navigate again back to
the postman this is where i'll start
i'll save this one first the single job
one so get
single
job
single job
and then let's create one for patch
meaning one for update but of course the
method will be patch
and i'll leave get all jobs since i want
to keep using those ids of course
and i think i can close the login one
for now because we already have logged
in as anna
and then let's look for the patch method
and ascended i'm messing up the get
single job my apologies so let me open
up the new one
and i'm gonna go with patch we're
looking for the url one
and again we'll be looking for the jobs
and then we wanna go with that route
parameter
and of course this is going to be that
job id so let me get all the jobs and
you know what i'll work with that last
one since we have repeating values so
let me grab here this id
and then pass it here
and remember authorization we go with
better token and we have access token
and if i send and if i get update job
then of course we know that we can start
setting up the functionality and as far
as the logic
like i already said
i mean most of it is going to be exactly
the same the difference of course is the
mongoose method we're going to use and
the fact that i'll check for both i'll
check for company as well as the
position and i'll check whether they are
not empty and you'll see what i mean in
a second so where i have the update job
let's just start working and first
same deal i'm going to be looking for
the user as well as the params so that
won't change because remember in the
routes i mean all of them are looking
for that route parameter correct so
let's take this one
there's really no point to repeat
ourselves in this case so let's copy and
paste however the difference is that
in this case since we're updating also
in the body we'll provide some info and
in my case i'm going to be looking for
both
i want to get the company as well as the
position so let's go here with raw and
we'll go with json here and if you want
to speed this up you can actually go to
create job and just take these values so
that's going to be our patch one copy
and paste
and we just need to remember to add the
curlies here
and as far as the values well let's come
up with some kind of company and i'll
call this random and then it's not going
to be a backend developer so it's going
to be a full stack
and then
back in my controller we also want to
add it over here so i'm still the
structuring the request object correct
and in there i have params i have the
user now as well as the body because
remember in here we're sending that in
the body so let's go back and let's say
body and in the body we'll be looking
for
company
company
and position
don't forget to add the comma and right
after we structure everything
i also want to check whether the company
or the position
is empty and if that's the case i want
to send back the bad request so say here
company
is equal to an empty string or position
is equal to an empty string and if that
is the case i'm going to go with throw
new and we're looking for
bad request of course
so bad request error and we'll say
company
or
position
fields cannot
be empty let's save it here and then of
course we want to use our find one and
update
and remember we need to basically pass
in three things we want to pass in what
we want to update
we want to pass in which job we're
looking for and then of course we also
have options where i want to get back
the updated version as well as i want to
run the validators so let's do that
however there is a tiny bug over here
and essentially i'll come back to this
one why i prefer setting up the check in
the controller once we start talking
about the mongoose errors and let's just
go with cons job
and we'll set it equal to a weight
then job of course that's the model
find one and update
and then like i said first we want to
pass in well which job are we going to
update and the setup is going to be
exactly the same
where i want to look for underscore id
as well as who created it so let's go
here let's say
underscore id is equal to my job id of
course
job id then we want to pass in the comma
and we'll go with created
and then buy now that is equal to my
user id
and then of course we want to pass in
what we want to update so let's just go
here with the rack
and body and then we want to pass in the
options
and i'm going to go with new true so
we'll be getting back that updated job
and then i also want to right away run
my validators and of course the property
for that is run
validators and we'll set it equal to
true now if the job doesn't exist we
already know what we can do we can
simply throw a not found there and if
everything is correct and of course we
return the job so let's scroll down copy
and paste
and our functionality should be working
where if everything is correct i'll get
back the updated job if not then of
course i'll get back the error so let's
test it out right now in the postman so
i'm going to go with full stack
developer and you know before we send
the correct request
why don't we remove that last value in
the id let's send it here and now of
course we're getting back that massive
mongoose error that we'll work on a
little bit later and then if i just
change it around to four then of course
i'll get back no job with id such and
such so let me change it back to three i
think that was the correct one and now
once i send now of course i am the
company and the position is full stack
developer and with this in place we only
need to worry about remove job
functionality beautiful so now let's
just set up remove jump functionality
and i guess let's start by saving our
request in the postman
so again we go with save as or just
control or i believe command s
and then let's just write up the job
update job
and of course we want to set up the same
thing for delete job
and let's just start everything from
scratch again we have a new request
we're going to go with delete
and then the url is going to be our
global variable then forward slash jobs
and now back in get all jobs why don't
we remove that random one so if i go
with get all jobs i can clearly see that
i'm getting back the random job that's
the one that we just updated so why
don't we remove this one so again i'm
looking for underscore id i'll right
away set it up as my route param and as
far as the logic well we're not going to
be setting up anything in the body we
really don't need to what we're looking
for of course is the authorization again
want to go with pair token access token
awesome let's send we should get back
delete job and as far as the
functionality again we're going to be
looking for user and params both of them
are located in the request correct so
one is coming from auth middleware and
the second one is coming from the params
again i know this is a repetition but
it's very very important that we
understand that
then let's copy and paste so we have
access to both of these ones
then as far as the method name we're
looking for
find one and remove so let's go here
with const
and we'll set it equal to job
and we'll set it to a weight
and of course like i said job
and then find one
and remove that's one we're looking for
and as far as the filter object let's
just go again with underscore id
and then job id of course
and the same goes for the user id
created that or sorry created by
and then we set it up as user id and the
same deal if the job doesn't exist then
we send back the error and if everything
went smoothly then we simply want to
send back 200 that's all we have to do
and i'll do that by cheating a little
bit where i'll take this code from the
update one and just copy and paste so
we're throwing the error if there is no
job or if everything is successful we
don't need to actually send back the
json again that's really going to depend
on your front end but in my case
i'm just looking for that 200 so if
there's some kind of error then of
course i have one functionality on my
front end however if everything went
smoothly if i remove the job then of
course i'm just getting back that 200
that's it so now of course let's test it
out in our postman where we have the job
we want to remove it let's send it here
as you can see i'm not getting anything
back but i have 200 which is always a
good sign so now of course let's go to
get all jobs or you know what let's save
this one first let's say save as and say
remove or delete job it's really up to
you
delete job
save it and then when it comes to get
all jobs of course i can send it and
count is back to three when it comes to
anna and with this in place let's just
quickly try out to log in as peter so we
just simply want to change the name here
i'm going to go with peter the password
is still the same and of course i just
need to be correct with my email i send
it yep i get the token and now let's
take a look at all the jobs that peter
has
and of course it's only one so now let
me grab this id
and first i'll change it so first we'll
go with update
and as far as the body i'll just pass in
random and when it comes to your
position i'm gonna go back to the
internal one
in turn here so let's send it that's the
response i have company random and of
course i want to also see whether i can
delete it so when it comes to delete job
i'll take the same id
i'll go back here
i'll copy and paste and once we run get
all jobs for the peter now so let's go
back to all the jobs and once we run it
now of course we have jobs this empty
array and count is zero but keep in mind
this is still a successful response it's
just peter hasn't created any jobs or
in our case we created it and then of
course we removed it and with this in
place we're done setting up the core
functionality for our application
beautiful and before we worry about
deployment let's make our mongoose error
responses more user-friendly and before
we start let me just say that
just like our error classes we will only
do this once
and after that we'll bring it from
project project so if at some point you
get bored just remember we only need to
do that in this project and then for
remaining projects of course we'll just
reuse the code and the idea is following
where currently we have three mongoose
errors we have validation one remember
that is if the user doesn't provide one
of the values then we have the duplicate
issue where email is unique and of
course we also have the cast error and
if you remember that's when the id
syntax doesn't match exactly to what the
mongoose is looking for
we want to go to the middleware and more
specifically we want to go to the error
handler and of course at the moment
i'm logging the error and in here i'm
just sending back this generic response
so internal server error and i'm just
passing in the object and if i take a
look at the postman
i'm going to be looking for register
route and then if i have already a user
in this example susan so if i already
have that email and if i try to register
one more time of course i'm going to get
that duplicate error correct because i
already have the email in the system and
essentially the goal is following where
we want to send back more user-friendly
response and also we want to change the
status code because at the moment we're
just sending 500 but of course this is
400 this is bad request
and the way we do that we navigate back
to error handler material and we'll
start by creating a object a custom
error object and the reason we'll do
that because we'll set up multiple if
statements now technically you can also
manipulate this code and i'll show you
in a second why and how but in my case
i'll just leave it the way it is so if
our error is our custom one basically if
it's one of the classes then we'll just
right away send back the response if not
there's going to be a new custom error
object and then as far as the response
we'll send back that object instead so
let's start working on that and
essentially we want to go with some kind
of variable in my case i'm going to go
with let
just so i know that i'm going to be
manipulating those values and i'll say
custom error and that one is equal to
status code and the message so here i
want to set up two properties and
basically we want to set defaults so the
same idea if there's already something
provided then of course we'll send back
that
if not then there's going to be some
kind of default and effectively it's
going to look something like this where
we'll go with the property name so
status code and this will be equal to
error
and then the status code and eventually
there's going to be multiple if
statements
that will manipulate this value so in
here i'm just setting up the defaults i
say hey listen
if in the error i already have the
status code
then use that if not well then let's set
up the generic response let's say status
codes and we're looking for internal
server error
and that of course is going to be 500
and let's do the same thing with the
message so message property and error
and let's just say here message
and let's go with two vertical bars
and we'll say something
something went wrong
and let's say try again
again later and now of course what we
want to do is change this code around
where instead of sending this internal
server error and json and error of
course we'll use these values instead
now i will still leave this code meaning
i'll just comment this out so copy and
paste and comment down just because i'll
be sending those error object back to
the postman because i find it easier
than logging in here and chasing it
around the terminal again that is just
my preference
and essentially what we want to change
over here
is the error
now of course we're looking for
custom error and then we want to go with
status code and then as far as the json
well the same thing we're going to go
with message and we'll set it equal to
our customer dot and of course we're
looking for the message
and you'll notice that at the moment
there's really no difference so if i go
back and again
try to register susan
even though the email is already news i
see this one i see over here a message
and this is going to be that mongoose
one and of course i still have this 500.
so technically
nothing changed now of course this is
where we'll work on right now where
after our custom api instance we'll go
here if
and essentially if you want to check
we'll have to take a look at the object
one more time so this is why i'll keep
both of these responses because
it is hard to find that error over here
and essentially i'll be sending back the
object just so you can see what is
happening and i think for time being
i'll get the error so
let me just save it here
let's send one more time and what you'll
notice that of course if we have that
duplicate issue this is the error that
we're getting back
and effectively what we want to do we
want to check
if the error code exists and the code is
equal to this 11 and then three zeros
then we want to send back this value
this email one so then we want to access
this key value and then just come up
with some kind of message so it's going
to look something like this where we're
going to go with if
then like i said we're checking for
error code and keep in mind that i'm not
talking about custom error here
i'm saying yeah there is a error object
and now i want to check whether it has
the code property and if it has then i
want to check more specifically if the
value is equal to 11 and then three
zeros so go over here like this and then
if that is the case then i know that i
can access of course this key value
property and i just need to come up with
some kind of message now what we'll do
over here like i said we'll modify
these values over here so in here we
just set up the defaults if the error is
not going to match any of our conditions
then either we'll use the actual error
status code if it exists
as well as the message if not then of
course we'll have these defaults
hopefully that is clear
and let's just start by setting up the
message now how we can do that well we
can go with custom error so that's our
object and essentially we're overriding
the message correct i'm just saying the
message value will be equal and in this
case i'm gonna use the template literals
because i'll pass in the actual arrow
key value and as far as text i'm just
gonna say duplicate value
and third
four and now let's access the value
let's say error and again remember we're
looking for this property over here
correct so say here error and we're
looking for key value and then we just
want to continue with the text so field
please choose
another value
another value
and of course i also want to change the
status code so in this case i'll go with
custom error
and i'm looking for status code property
and i'll set it equal to 400 because
this is a bad request
and since we can clearly see the error
object
since we already have all of the code
that we need again i'm just going to hop
around here and i'll comment this one
out because i will use this one in a
later videos and then we'll go back to
this custom one and once we set
everything up now of course we can
navigate here we can send and of course
this is the response so now we have the
message we have duplicate value entered
for object object and we'll work on this
one a little bit later and what's really
cool that of course now we have 400 so
we can clearly see that it is a bad
request
now if we don't want to send this object
object which of course is not that
helpful we'll simply need to use a
little bit of javascript but of course
we have the object so our key value is
an object and in javascript we have
object dot and of course in our case
we're looking for keys so this will give
us a array of keys and of course in this
case we'll only have the email so it's
going to look something like this where
we go with object keys and then we'll
pass in our error and key value and as a
result we'll get back array of the keys
so let's send one more time let's go
back over here and now of course we'll
have duplicate value
for the email field please choose
another value and with this in place now
we're handling the
duplicate error and essentially we're
sending back
more friendly user response
awesome and once we check for duplicate
value now let's quickly talk about our
custom api ones so our classes
and we can actually remove this if
statement right now because remember in
the custom error we are checking for the
status code so if that property is on
the object then beautiful we set our
status code value and the same goes for
a message
and in order to showcase that i'm just
going to remove this if statement for
time being i'll just comment it out just
so i can always put it back if i'm wrong
and then as far as the route well let's
take a look at our auth chairs
and i believe we're using it in a login
correct we have our bad request error so
let's try it out
now of course i'm going to go to login
user and i'll try to get the token for
susan without providing the password so
let me remove it let me send it over
here and now of course i still have
please provide email and password and of
course the error code the status code is
also good it is 400 which simply means
that of course our logic works because
again we have this custom error one and
essentially we're looking for a status
code property on the error object that's
coming in because remember in here of
course we're setting up a new one and
the same goes for a message so you can
simply remove this code now i'll leave
this one for your reference just in case
you want to use it but effectively we
don't need to use this anymore and of
course with our new setup we don't need
to import the custom api our class as
well so you can remove it and the code
will still work not bad not bad in our
current setup we're nicely handling
duplicate values
as well as our own custom errors so now
of course we want to deal with those
validation errors which of course is the
case for example in the auth
when i'm registering the user and i'm
right away passing in direct.body so i'm
not checking for email or password or
name over here i simply let the mongoose
handle that and the way we do that is
pretty similar to what we have over here
we simply want to set up the if
statement again we'll have some kind of
condition in this case we're going to be
looking for
validation error and if that is the case
again we'll use one of the nifty
javascript methods
in this case we're not going to be
looking for keys we'll be looking for
the values and of course we'll send back
the nice response and in order to test
it out let's just go back again to our
postman now i'm not going to do that in
login because again in here we have our
custom one the bad request one what i
want to do is go back to the register
user
and here i want to remove both the email
and the password and yes i'm purposely
removing both
just so you can clearly see our
functionality in action and once we do
that once we send i mean we can still
see 500
so that just means internal server error
but the message is already more
user-friendly correct we already have
user validation failed password and blah
blah blah so let me show you the entire
object just so you can understand the
functionality we're about to set up
better and technically i don't even need
to comment this one out because if i
have my first return of course this is
what we'll send back so let me go back
to the postman send it one more time and
of course this is going to be that
giant object that we're getting back and
the structure is following where we have
this errors object and of course in here
we'll have all the values that are
missing so of course in our case that is
password and the email and this is very
very important because of course if you
have only one
then technically you don't need to worry
about multiple keys but that's not our
scenario so in our case we do need to
worry about multiple keys in that object
because
maybe the password email and name might
be missing and also in that object in
the error object not only we have errors
we also have the name
and essentially in our if block we just
want to check whether it is a validation
error so let's go back
and
i'm going to do that above the duplicate
one but of course the position doesn't
really matter where i'll say error name
if it is equal
to the validation error so let's go over
here with validation error and if you
need to copy and paste just so you don't
make some silly typos so essentially if
you're like me then of course you can do
that so let's copy and paste and if that
is the case
then what i want to do is get
all the values
for the keys in the errors object so
notice
of course i have the password correct of
course i have the email and what we want
to do grab this errors one and just get
the actual values
of these objects because errors is an
object itself then password and email
are object so i'm looking for the actual
values in there and you'll see what i
mean in a second so i have if error name
is equal to validation error then let's
just go with custom
error and we're going to be looking for
the message and like i said we're going
to go with object and values and then
we'll pass in the error
and errors
so in the error object of course there
is errors object and in there i have two
more keys we have password and email and
i want to turn them into array and then
i want to iterate over using map so
since we're getting back the area of
course i can use my map method and i'm
just going to call this item so each and
every item i'll call the item and then
i'll say item.message so in here you'll
notice that of course
in there in that values i have a message
property correct and then i want to
access it and send it back so let's say
here item
dot
message
and then we'll just join it back to the
string and we'll add a comma so that's
going to be our message now as far as
the status code again 400 so let's go
over here with custom error and we're
looking for status code and that will be
equal to 400 so once we save and once we
send it back now of course we should get
a better response but of course we don't
because i mean i left my first response
in there as well so let me comment this
sucker out and then send it here and now
of course i have please provide password
please provide email which effectively
is way more user friendly than the
object that we're sending back and also
notice the status code of course now
we're sending back 400 and if you're
confused about the code just go back to
the error handler and just log what
you're getting back from object that
values and it will make total sense so
essentially the map and join will make
total sense so let's try it over here
we'll go with console.log and then we're
looking for
object dot values and then here we want
to pass in error so the error object and
then more specifically the errors object
so let's save it and back in postman we
want to send it of course response
doesn't change but in my terminal i can
clearly see that what i'm getting back
from
object.values
is array of objects and then i'm
iterating over that array and then more
specifically in each object i'm
accessing the message and then i just
join all of them together so i set it
back to the string and then i just add
comma e in between and once we have all
of this in place
now of course we can worry about our
third instance and that's going to be
the cast error
and as far as the cast error of course
in the auth
we're not going to get it because we're
not using the ids but
in the jobs we should get it
so back in where i have the jobs
controller
if we take a look at i don't know get
single job of course i'm passing in the
job id that is coming from params
correct and here
if i cannot find the job
that has the job id with the user id of
course i send back the not found error
however there also might be a case where
the syntax doesn't match to whatever the
database is looking for and of course in
order to showcase that let me just go to
get all the jobs so this is going to get
me all the jobs that susan has and as a
side note
i think i logged out so let me log in
back as susan
so let's say over here password
and in my case while i'm testing and
pretty much setting everything up as
secret so let's send it here yep we have
the tokens so let me now send get all
jobs okay awesome i'm getting the jobs
and now of course whether that's for get
single job update job or deletion i will
have to provide that id and if i'll just
mess up the values that's one thing then
we'll get that 404
but we also might have that cast error
so let's go to i don't know get single
job
copy and paste the correct id send here
okay we should get back the correct
response but if i'm going to start
adding the values who are removing
we should see the
casting error now again in our case we
just see the string
so let me scroll down i know it's a
little bit annoying but it's important
for me to showcase those big objects
just so i can see where we're getting
the values from and once i send it of
course now i have error and the name is
equal to cast error and now we just want
to swing back to our error handler and
essentially set up the if condition
where i'm going to be checking for
cast error if that is the case then of
course i'll just send back some kind of
string
with 404 so again that's going to be not
found one and i'll just provide the
value just so user can understand what's
happening so let's go back over here
let's say if and i'll just say error
name
and if it is equal to a cast error and
if that is the case i want to go with my
custom error then the property name is
message and actually i want to set it up
as template string so no item found
with id
and then we're going to be going for
error and of course i'm looking for the
value one
so in the our object there's a valid
property and i'm looking for this id so
let's say here error
value
and then the next thing is that status
code and in this case we want to go with
custom error
so custom error here and status code and
that is going to be equal to 404 or not
found now of course
if you want to use the status quo here
as well
please definitely do so i just thought
that it's important for me the first
time to show you the actual number
status code and then if you want you can
use the library instead so let me send
it here
and of course i should get back the
proper response but problem is that i'm
still sending back the first one so now
let me remove it since we're not going
to use it let's save it and then once we
send now we have no item found with id
and we have the 404 and with this in
place of course we can move on to the
next topic all right so for all our apps
were nice and cute since we only use
them in local setup but with this
project things are about to get
interesting you see this app will
actually host on heroku basically
deployed on the cloud and what that
means that we also need to think about
security essentially how we can protect
our api from some bad actors
and the good news is that with the help
of community so think npm and more
specifically npm packages we really
don't need to do that much just install
some packages and add them as middleware
in our app and we're good to go yes it
is that simple
now is our app going to be safe from any
possible attack well no most likely not
remember our biggest security soft spot
is still our user
yes of course we should be protecting
our api but how are you going to stop
the user from storing a token in a
unsecure manner there's really no
package for that
and as far as the packages we're going
to use well first we're going to use
helmet arguably the most popular
security package out there which sets
various http headers to prevent numerous
possible attacks in fact helmet is so
popular it's actually used in many other
packages as a dependency after that we
want to implement coors library which
just ensures
that our api
is accessible from different domain if
you don't have cores installed you'll
only be able to access the data from the
same domain if you remember in the
previous project we did that in
javascript file located in the public
folder and if you try to access our
previous apis from any other frontend
apps you'll get a course error now coors
stands for cross origin resource sharing
and it is a mechanism to allow or
restrict requested resources on a web
server depending on where the http
request was initiated
by installing and implementing the
course package essentially we make our
api accessible to the public after that
we want to use xss clean library which
sanitizes the user input in reg.body
reg.query and reg.params and as a result
protects us from cross-site scripting
attacks where the attacker tries to
inject some malicious code and lastly we
want to limit the amount of requests the
user can make
and we'll do that with the help of
express rate limit library if you're
using the star all libraries already
installed and ready to go but if you
want to use it for your own project of
course just install them by running npm
install and then name of library and
also if you want to get more info on any
of them
a library docs is a very good place to
start in later projects we might use
some additional libraries or config
options but in general as far as the
standard security this setup is a very
good place to start
all right and once we have covered
general info about the security packages
now we simply want to go to app.js we
want to import them one by one
and of course we just want to invoke
them and in my case i'm going to do it
over here where we have
express.json and i'm going to start by
providing comment extra
and let's say
security packages
and then we're looking for helmet first
and we'll set it of course equal to the
package
helmet then the same for cores so this
is the course package and we have one
for cross-site scripting so require
and the package name here is xss clean
and last one is express rate limit and
i'm purposely setting this one up last
just because there's going to be a
little bit of configuration there as
well so let's go with require and
express rate limit
then let's save keep scrolling where we
have the json let's start with our
helmet so app.use
and like i said we just invoke the
helmet the same for rest of them so i'm
that use and of course in here i'm
looking for cores
i can just copy and paste
then i want to go for cross-site
scripting one so xss and again we invoke
it and then we add limit1 so again
app.use
then rate limit and you know what i
think i'm going to change the name here
i'm going to go with rate limiter not a
big deal
but just my preference and if we take a
look at the package docs
effectively what we want to set up
is the time
so in how long and how many requests and
as you can see here they provide an
object and properties are
window milliseconds so effectively we
get this in milliseconds and we just set
up time and as you can see this is
example for 15 minutes
and then how many requests
and also if you keep on scrolling you'll
notice their responses
so by default the message is going to be
too many requests
and the error response is going to be
429. and once we're clear on setup let's
implement it in our own app
so first what i want to do is move this
rate limiter up so i want to set it up
as our first middleware
and then in order to speed this up we'll
just grab the object here
with those milliseconds as well as the
max request
we'll invoke it here copy and paste
and our limiter is in place
lastly according to their docs if our
application is behind reverse proxy
which is going to be our case since
we'll push this up to heroku
we also want to implement this app.set
trust proxy so let's just take this
code and place it before the rate
limiter and with this in place
we have our security packages so now we
can move on to our next step just a
friendly reminder that we're about to
host our project on heroku
and if in the mongodb
you are using local ip address option
you'll need to switch to allow access
from anywhere one otherwise mongodb will
throw an error
and your app won't work
awesome and once we have the basic
security in place let's complete this
project by deploying it on a cloud so we
can start utilizing our api from any
front-end setup and while there are many
hosting providers out there during this
course we'll use the following two
heroku and digitalocean they both have
their pros and cons so just like in most
cases at the end of the day everything
depends on your own preference
and for this project we'll use heroku
and since it offers generous free tier
in order to follow along you'll only
need three things
an existing heroku account and of course
the sign up is free so just navigate to
heroku.com and look for signup option
second since heroku utilizes git version
control you'll need git installed on
your computer and since this is somewhat
of an advanced course my assumption is
that that is already a case my
assumption is that you already have git
properly installed and third you'll need
a heroku cli a tool to deploy our apps
right from our computer
and as far as the install for heroku cli
you can find the entire setup in the
heroku docs so once you sign up for the
account this is going to be your
dashboard and of course i already have
some apps in there and you can find the
cli install by clicking on the docs and
more specifically the heroku cli link so
let's click on a docs and then like i
said we're looking for roku cli and in
here just pick the operating system and
follow the steps once you're done with
an install make sure to double check
whether everything went smoothly by
typing heroku hyphen v in the terminal
and if you can see the version number
great feel free to proceed to the next
video if not if you don't see the
version number please troubleshoot since
you'll need a working heroku cli in
order to follow along with the
deployment so if i go back to my
terminal and if i type heroku hyphen v
of course i can see the version number
which means that i have a working cli on
my computer and lastly in the next video
we'll actually deploy our app and during
deployment we will utilize some common
standard git commands like init and and
commit
and since this is not a git course i'm
not going to dwell on them too much so
if you need to jog your memory as far as
the get basics please utilize the search
engine all right
and once you have installed heroku cli
now let's finally deploy our application
and in my case what i'm going to do
i'm going to look for the entire folder
so this is the entire course
and then for the jobs api and after that
i want to get the final one and
essentially i will make the copy just so
i can set it up on desktop now of course
in your case that is going to be your
current application however i do
strongly suggest following all the steps
and deploying the project as a separate
project and here's what i mean so i'll
make the copy of the final one here
and i'll rename it but before i do that
i'll just drag and drop and place it
on a desktop so here now it is on
desktop and then i'll call this jobs api
or whatever again the waste name is
really up to you and i suggest doing the
same thing essentially if you have been
working on starter
just make the copy
and set it up on desktop or somewhere
separately
because it's just going to be easier
otherwise
if you're working in the entire course
project in my opinion it's going to be
hard to navigate around and set
everything up and you also might run
into some bugs
so let me open up right now my text
editor i'll make this one a little bit
smaller
then i'll drag and drop my application
and effectively will follow these steps
so let me go back to heroku
we'll go to documentation here and then
we're looking for node.js
and then more specifically we're looking
for deploying node.js apps on heroku
so these are all the steps we're going
to take
plus some additional ones
that i find useful
and first what i want to do is go back
to my project and i always always always
start by
removing the existing git repo just in
case there is one and as far as the
magnet command is rm
then hyphen rf and then git
now if you're using windows if you take
a look at my twitter if you look around
you'll probably find one of my tweets
where i share both the command for
windows
as well as the mac again this is very
very important you always want to start
from the scratch after that we want to
check whether we have that process dot
env port variable and by the way by the
end of deploy i'll show you where we can
actually see the value that is on heroku
but this is a must again we can hard
code and it nicely works in a local
setup but when you deploy you always
want to go with process.nv and then the
port variable and then heroku picks that
port variable and of course spins up our
application on that port then we want to
set up a simple route so at the moment
we have the auth and jobs but what i
also like to do is just to set up a
simple
dummy get road so i know that everything
is fine and i have deployed my
application and in this case i'm just
going to go with app.get then forward
slash so of course that's my index and
then i'm looking for rec and res
and then here let's just send a silly
little response where we say res dot and
say send and jobs api that's it that's
all we have to do
and then we will navigate to
package.json and this is where we'll
take a look at the steps so let's keep
on scrolling and they suggest setting
the node version and in my case that is
node 14 because remember initially when
we started the course i installed note
14 but if you install different version
push set that one up and just to jog
your memory if you want to check your
node version just go to node dash nv and
again my case that is
14.15 but essentially we'll just go with
14. so in the package json keep
scrolling
then add a comma and then let's say
engines
and then inside of it let's go with node
and pretty much set up the same code so
in order to speed this up i'll just copy
and paste and i'm in good shape then
let's scroll up
and where we have start command we're
not going to go with nodemon app.js this
is of course only in development
effectively we'll go with
node
and app.js
then save it so that should do it for
package.json
and then lastly as far as the initial
setup we want to set up a proc file and
then add some values to it now if you
want to find more info about the proc
file
just keep scrolling here
blah blah blah
and i think i already went past it so
let me go up notice here specifying a
start script and if you click on this
profile you can find more info
but effectively what we want to do is
create new file now we don't add
extension here we just say
proc file like so and then inside of it
we'll go with web
and we'll set node and app.js so pretty
much this value is going to be the same
as our start command
and that should do it for initial setup
so now of course we need to start
working with git as well and first we'll
start by git init so we'll initialize
empty git repo
then we want to add everything to the
staging area so git add and then that
and then of course some kind of commit
message so essentially in this case i'm
going to go with initial
commit okay awesome and then this is
where the heroku comes in we want to go
with heroku and you know let me just
clear everything so you can clearly see
what's happening so we're gonna go with
heroku and login so if you have the cli
you'll be able to log in
just press any key like this suggest
over here
and then once you do that they'll ask
you to log in okay then of course we
want to create a
new heroku application and we do that in
the following way we go with roku and
again let me clear everything let's go
with heroku
then create and then we need to come up
with a name
and keep in mind that you cannot start
with a number so if you remember in our
course project of course i go
zero 0605 or whatever
in this case i'm gonna have to go with
jobs api and then this probably will be
taken let me double check yep notice
here he's already taken so we need to
start from scratch so let's say heroku
create and then i'm gonna go jobs iphone
api and then zero six again you cannot
go zero six and then jobs api it's not
going to work because you cannot start
with a number so let's set it up
now i'm creating that new application
awesome and as i said if you just run
heroku create
it will create a name for you
so if that's what you prefer i mean go
for it and then i just want to quickly
check
whether git remote
points to the actual repo so let's say
here git remote
and then hyphen v
and if you see these values then of
course we are moving in the right
direction
and before we can push this up
we need to of course deal with our env
variables correct because if you take a
look at the get ignore of course these
are ignored and that's how they should
be
and effectively we have two ways we can
do it using command line but i'll just
add one value using the command line
i'll just go with this lifetime one and
then i'll show you another way how we
can do that
e in the dashboard on the gory because i
find gui to be easier as far as setting
up the env variables now with that said
of course that means that initially when
we push our application to the github
it's not going to work because our
application is looking for all the nv
variables but i'm just going to show you
one the lifetime one because if you'll
try to do this secret essentially in the
command line it's just going to be
spinning back errors as far as the
secret value now of course you can
always switch back to string the i don't
know secret jwt or whatever but since i
want to keep this value i'll show you
both setups and after i've been rambling
and rambling for about half an hour
about it let's go with heroku then
config
config and then we want to go with a
colon and set
and essentially this is where we're
going to set up those env variables and
yes
for all the env variables you have
you'll have to type this heroku config
and send it by typing as always is
awesome so let's go with config and then
set more properly and then copy and
paste and by the way didn't copy this
one either
my apologies i'm literally on fire so
let's go back here and then copy and
paste and now of course we're setting
that config variable correct so now we
have one the jwt lifetime and 30 days so
without setting up these ones we'll push
this up to the heroku of course our
application won't work but then i'll
show you another way how we can set them
up so now let's go here and in the
command line let's clean everything and
let's just type git push
and heroku and then if you check the
docs
they say and by the way this is that
login screen and close it but if you
check the docs
they say that you should go with heroku
and main
now in my case if i type heroku and main
i'm basically going to be getting this
error if i go with get push
roku
and
master then everything works as expected
now our application is being pushed to
the github and from there of course the
heroical picks it up and now it starts
deploy but we need to go back to our
dashboard our gui
then in here we can refresh we should
see the application but again it's not
going to work if you go to application
if you open app of course you'll have
some kind of dummy screen or whatever
but i can tell you right away that our
application won't work because of course
those emv variables are not there
now in order to set them up in a gui
we'll go over here and we're looking for
settings
and we'll go with reveal config wires
and notice we have the lifetime one
correct and now simply what we want to
do is add the rest of the values as well
so essentially here i'm looking forward
to my [ __ ] uri that's going to be my
first one copy and paste and the same
goes over here
so i want to take the value of course
and copy and paste let's add this one
and the same will do with our secret one
and for some interesting reason in the
console it spits back errors but in the
gui when you add that secret one then
everything works like peaches so let me
go back here
let me grab the value
copy and paste and now of course we want
to add that var
and then in order to spin everything up
we just need to go here
more and we need to go with restart all
dinos so at this point i'll freeze the
screen i'll change back to my actual
password and then i'll restart dinos and
once we restart all the dinos yep that's
what we want to do
and if we take a look at the logs
you'll see how initially
our application was on port
43 710
so that was the port that the heroku
picked then we exited with a status of
143 so basically we had the issue
with our process.nv
and now of course we're back to
46 and then 97 so that's the port if we
open up the application notice i can
clearly see my
jobs api and of course i was just
showcasing the port variable so you get
the clear idea of how everything is set
up that's why we go here with this port
because then heroku picks the port where
our application is going to be located
and once i have my application up and
running we simply want to grab the url
and we want to test it out now i'm not
going to test it out with all the routes
but i definitely want to create or log
in the user and see whether i can see
all the jobs so in my case i'm going to
go to the postman
and since i don't want to mess up these
routes i'll actually create first a
global variable because in here of
course yes i have the url
but what is the actual url well it is
localhost 3000 correct now what do we
want to do we want to go with edit
then let's write here prod and then
underscore url
and then let's just copy and paste the
value so this is going to be the url for
your application now we're still looking
for api
and then version one
so
that's not going to change let's save it
here and then i can close my globals
and like i said i'll create a new route
and this is going to be a post route
and since i have that one susan user
i'll just try to log in and then see
whether i can see
all the jobs that susan has and in this
case we're looking for prod
and of course the url okay awesome then
we're looking for
auth
and then forward slash login so that is
going to be the url
now as far as the credentials well
where we have the login user first i
want to grab the body here
so let's take all of this
and again we're just doing that so we
don't have to type everything from
scratch
so json copy and paste okay we have
susan gmail password and all that and
then remember since i want to set that
token automatically
what do we need to do well we need to
look for tests correct and just take
these two lines of code
and then back in my production one copy
and paste and now i want to send
and if everything is correct which of
course it is i'm getting back my token
and i'm still setting it up in the
globals which is just awesome
and now of course we just want to create
another route now this will get all the
jobs that susan has so let's go and go
with get route and we're looking for
again the production url
then jobs and this is going to be the
get route that's correct and then in
here
i mean let's go with authorization of
course we're looking for better token
and access token and if everything is
correct i should see that susan has two
jobs one for netflix and one for google
and wonderful we have successfully
created our application and we have
deployed it on heroku as well okay once
our app is chilling on a cloud now it's
time to set up some nice docs using
swagger ui don't get me wrong there are
quite a few alternative api
documentation options out there
but it's hard to compete with a nice end
result you get with swagger with that
said setting up swagger manually aka
writing the code yourself from scratch
is no walk in the park it's not that
it's hard it's just really tedious and
takes somewhat long time
and since i don't want to spend three
hours on setting up the docs i'll show
you a nice shortcut where we can utilize
the post mandox and a third-party
library to essentially automate the
process and as a result
save ourselves a ton of time before we
continue please let me make it clear
this is not going to be tutorial on
swagger ui we just want to create
working docs and in fact i won't dwell
on any of the details if you want to
find out more about swagger ui syntax
and other options please utilize one of
the tons of nice tutorials and blog
posts out there and we're going to start
our documentation setup with a little
detour where i'll show you how to clone
an existing heroku app
needless to say technically it's
optional
if you don't want to do that you can
just keep using the project we used for
deployment
but if you're anything like me
essentially if possible you don't like
keeping the projects on your local
machine and instead you want to keep
them on a cloud i think you'll find this
video useful
and i want to start by navigating back
to my desktop i'm looking for my
terminal first i want to navigate to
desktop so let's say here cd desktop
then we want to go with heroku so that's
the cli then git
clone and hyphen a
and after that we need to provide the
name of that which in my case is jobs
api 0 6
so either you can copy and paste or you
can type it out and in my case i'm going
to go with jobs api
and 0 6 and now on my desktop i should
have the repo and what that means is
that the url is pointing back to the
heroku so every time we'll make some
change of course we'll push it back to
heroku and all the changes will be
applied
now what's missing of course is the node
modules as well as the dot env
because remember
if we take a look at our git ignore
this is not pushed up to the github now
in order to fix that we'll need to
create a file so go with dot env and
then we want to provide
all three values [ __ ] uri and rest of
the two for djwt now where you can get
them we'll remember
if we navigate to our application then
more specifically settings we have our
variables correct config vars so just
open this up
set it up in dot env install all the
packages and then you can run npm start
and once i'm done setting up my
environment variables
like i already mentioned we're gonna go
with npm install so install all the
packages and then let's go with npm
start
now since i want to make tiny changes
here there's not gonna be that much code
essentially
i will keep in the package just on node
objects please keep in mind that
if you want to add more changes to the
project it's probably more useful to set
up the command where you're using the
nodemon because if you remember it's
quite annoying would know that you have
to restart every time you make the
change
again we'll have only like i don't know
six lines of code so it doesn't really
matter in our case but in general if
this is what you're doing if you're
cloning the app back from the heroku
just remember to change the start
command or set up some kind of command
that you can use in dev where
effectively you are using nodemon right
from the get go and if i can see that
server is listening on port 5000 that
means that everything is correct and if
i navigate to the localhost 5000 in my
browser i should have that silly jobs
api and with this in place now we can
start setting up the docs once our
application is running on localhost 5000
we want to swing back to the postman and
we want to get the documentation and the
way we do that we look for our
collection and before you do anything
just make sure
that the global url variable is the same
in all the requests in my case i'm using
the production one but it doesn't really
matter since we'll change that value
later anyway so you can use the url just
make sure
that all the requests have the same
value otherwise you might get some weird
bugs and in fact postman offers
documentation itself the problem is that
once you publish it it actually goes to
a separate url
now what do i mean by that well
eventually in our api we'll have the
route api docs as you can see and this
is where the user will be able to access
the docs with postman once we publish
the docs they're automatically hosted
online but on a separate url and since i
want my docs to be on the same server
that's why we're doing all this swagger
stuff and in order to export
documentation just look for the
collection again jobs api make sure that
the urls are all the same in all the
requests and then the option you're
looking for is this export one
if for somewhere reason you don't see it
just sign up for a free postman account
it's not gonna cost you anything they're
not gonna charge your credit card you
just need to use the email and you'll be
good to go again this is the case if you
don't see the export option if you do
then smash the export option like
there's no tomorrow afterwards pick the
second option
then decide on the name and location and
in my case i'm gonna go with docs json
and i'll save it on a desktop and once
we navigate to the location and we can
see the json file then of course we can
move on to the next step awesome once we
have the postman json file we are
halfway there we just need to fix a tiny
issue you see we cannot pass postman
docs directly into swagger ui
effectively we need to format our data
first just so swagger understands what's
happening and in order to accomplish
that we'll have to sign up for one more
free tool
api matic important side note just like
other course resources it's free and i
have no affiliation to them so in order
to follow along the videos go to
apimatic.io
and sign up for free account assuming
that you sign up for the account this is
going to be your dashboard and you're
looking for the import option and we
want to import that docs json
in my case i'm going to be looking in
the desktop
and i want to import yes
now don't pay attention to those
warnings as long as you don't have any
errors we should be good to go so i'm
going to click on proceed and once you
have the api instance in place
before we can ship it to swagger ui
we'll need to edit a little bit so this
is the case where we'll add the proper
url we'll set up the proper
authorization and all that cool stuff so
we want to click here on edit api
and let's just start with basic settings
and as you can see we have tons and tons
of options but totally honestly we'll
just go with a bare-bones setup
since i don't want to waste too much of
your time and as far as the name i think
i'm going to go with
jobs api if you want you can add the
image that's not what i'm looking for so
i'll just save basic settings and this
is very very important make sure that
you save before moving on to the next
configuration options then we're looking
for server configuration option the
environment will be production server
name i'll just leave it as server one
and when it comes to url this is where
you wanna pass the url that points back
to your heroku project so in my case let
me double check i'm gonna go back to
heroku here i have my jobs api
open app
so that's going to be my route now one
downside with heroku is that yes it
takes time to spin up that dyno so
that's one thing that you need to keep
in mind and i'll just take the url
i'll navigate back to the api matic copy
and paste and then remember as far as
our routes we still want to go with api
and then version one and then we'll have
auth and jobs again make sure make sure
make sure make sure that you save the
config settings it's very easy to make
some changes and then just forget about
it
and when it comes to authentication yes
we'll use the better token so auth 2.0
that stays the same after that we want
to move on to the endpoints
and here in the endpoints you'll notice
that
all of them effectively have the
authentication and that's not what we
want because if you remember as far as
our api well these ones the actual
auth routes well we don't want to set up
the authentication on them correct these
are going to be the public ones and only
the jobs will be protected and will
require that token hopefully we're on
the same page we're looking for
register user and login user so let me
open up this endpoint here then we want
to change the group and i'll change it
to auth
and i want to skip the authentication
because by default the authentication is
going to be added to all of them so
let's save the endpoint
and now we should see the auth folder
and in there there's going to be a
register user and we're skipping
authentication this is very very
important
and the second route that i want to add
is the login one
so look for the login user and same deal
we want to skip the authentication
and we want to place it in our auth
folder so let's save the endpoint and
then for the rest of them we are not
skipping the authentication so don't
click here but what we want to do is
change the folder so for all the routes
one by one i'll add group and the name
will be jobs and once i say i have jobs
folder with create job wrote and i'm not
skipping the authentication and
essentially what you want to do
apply the same group to the rest of the
routes get all jobs all the way to
delete job and since it's not very
useful for you to watch how i do that
i'll pause the video and i'll just add
this jobs group to the rest of the
routes and once i'm done i will resume
the video and once you're done you
should have two folders the jobs folder
with all the jobs routes and again we're
not skipping the authentication and auth
folder where we are skipping the
authentication and we have two following
routes register user and login user and
if that is the case just navigate back
to the dashboard
then you're looking for this option
you're looking for export api
and this is very very very important
that you go with open api version three
as you can see by default we have
version two json you're looking for this
one and you wanna go with yaml option so
click here and then export documentation
and eventually this is what you should
see on a screen and if that is the case
now we can move on to our next step all
right and once our documentation makes
sense to swagger ui now let's test it
out in their online editor which is a
nifty tool that we can use to test out
our api docs right in the browser
and if necessary apply the changes and
as a result save ourselves a ton of time
so what i want you to do is go to your
search engine and you're looking for
swagger error or swagger ui error
doesn't really matter and then you can
open up two tabs because you'll notice
that they do provide some boilerplate
code which of course you can use in
order to understand the entire setup
and this is exactly what i'm going to do
so i have one tab open
and i'll open up the another one and in
there i want to copy and paste this
entire thing so let me select it
then go back
and i want to copy and paste
after that we can technically start
testing our api
but the problem is that we still have
the params unfixed and also we have this
extra tag and we'll start with the tag
where basically navigate to the bottom
where you have the tags and just remove
the first one
so that's done and then let's deal with
the query parameters because if you take
a look at our project notice we have
jobs
and then for single job the update job
and delete job these are query
parameters but at the moment
everything
is hard coded so how we can set it up in
swagger
z params well we'll use their docs this
is going to be the case where i want you
to again use your search engine and just
type swagger ui parameters a quick side
note if you can't be bothered going
through the swagger docs you can always
find the correct code in the project
readme you're looking probably for the
first link
then we'll keep on scrolling yep all the
details and all that
but what we're interested is common
parameters for all methods of the path
now i don't want you to take the path
part
but i want you to take everything
starting with the user
all the way to get
so take this code yes we'll modify but
this is just going to be faster if we
set it up this way go back to your error
and what you're looking for are those
single routes so go up here where you
have the patch remove the hard-coded one
including the column this is very very
important and the same for get
and once you remove the get part just
copy and paste this one in this case we
don't want to use the user because the
route is
jobs correct then we have the id yeah
that still stays the same
and instead of integer this is going to
be a string it's going to be required
and it's going to be a job id again if
you want to find more info
please just read their documentation but
essentially what we did right now
we added that id parameter in all these
three routes get single job update job
and delete job and once we have this in
place now we can start testing our api
and i'll start by registering the user
now i'm not going to try out all the
routes but i think i'm just going to go
with a register and maybe i'll try to
create a job and then take a look at a
single job just so you can see that
everything works
and the way we do that in a swagger we
look for try it out here notice these
are the values that we're sending and of
course once you already register user
you'll have to change these values
around but in my case i deleted the bob
from my database so i can execute notice
this is going to be the sample request
this is going to be the url and voila
this is the response so that's my token
but the deal again in here is that these
ones are protected so if i'll just try
to access the job or create job or
whatever i'm not going to be able to do
that so you want to copy the token
and you have two options either you can
set up in one of them and automatically
it's going to be added to all of them or
you can just scroll up and same deal
just copy and paste the value authorized
so now i set up my token so i can close
the register i'm good to go now we just
want to create a job so let's go to the
post request
again we're trying it out i'm going to
go with the same google and the
front-end developer we'll execute
we should get back the job the 201 and
now if i go to get all jobs
and we try it out we just execute we
don't need to provide anything we have
our jobs array with a counter one and if
i want to take a look at single job we
want to copy and paste the value
and as far as the setup
either of these is going to work so
either get patch or delete and my case i
think i'm going to go with get we want
to try it out again after that we want
to paste the job id remember as far as
the authorization we right away set up
the token at the very very start so now
of course we're authorized to make these
requests so once we execute
check it out
now i can see my
one job and once everything is working
now the last step
is just setting this up in our
application
so we'll still need this code so don't
remove it or mess it up but the good
news is that we're pretty much done with
the hardest part
so i promise it's going to be a smooth
sailing from here on out beautiful and
once we have tested our api in a swagger
editor
now we just want to add it to our
application and in order to do that
we'll need two packages we'll need yaml
js and the swagger ui express now if you
can see both packages
in the package.json then of course
you're good to go but since i added
these packages later essentially they
were not with initial star you might
need to install them yourself so if you
don't see them just run the command of
npm
and i or installed doesn't really matter
then go for yaml
js and swagger
ui
ui
and express
so this one will convert the yaml one to
something that the swagger ui can
understand and swagger ui express just
adds swagger to our application so i'll
install both packages even though i have
them and i'll start by creating a new
file and in my case i'm going to call
this swagger and yaml now the name is
really up to you just make sure
that the extension is yaml
and now you want to take this entire
thing again this is a little bit
different than what we have from api
matic this is already a working
documentation copy and paste and back in
our app.js we want to do two things we
want to require the swagger ui express
the yaml js and then load the yaml file
and then we want to pass it on to the
swagger ui so i'm gonna go below the
extra packages we'll add comment here
i'll say
swagger and let's just start by grabbing
the swagger ui
again we're just coming up with some
kind of name
and this will be equal to require
then we're looking for the swagger ui
express
and since i have yaml file i also want
to do that
and that will be equal to
require and we're looking for the
package and then we want to load the
file
so in here let's just come up with some
kind of name i'm going to go with
swagger
document
and that will be equal to yaml that's
the variable
then dot and the method you're looking
for is load and in here you want to
point to the file which of course is in
the root so we simply go with swagger
dot and yaml and once we have all of
this code in place now we just want to
scroll down
and where we have here the app.get above
it below it it's really up to you we'll
go with app.use then we need to come up
with a path and in my case i'm going to
go with forward slash api docs and you
know what actually changed my mind i'll
place it after the forward slash so
let's go here let's say api docs as you
can see we're using
app.use so it will be a middleware and
then as far as the code we want to go
with swagger so that's our variable and
we're looking for the serve property and
then we want to get that yaml file so
again we go with swagger ui setup method
and in this case we want to pass in that
swagger
document once all of this is in place
now i just want to go to app.get and
instead of sending back jobs api
what i want to do is send back the
heading 1 let's say jobs
api i'll close the heading 1 and then
i'll just set up some link that goes to
api and for some reason
i went with api use should be api docs
my apologies
so let me go here i'm going to go with
href
and we're going to set it up as forward
slash
api docs
and then let's close the link and let's
just say documentation and once we have
all of this in place
now let's run npm start but i can tell
you right away
that if you'll try to test this
on a local machine it's not going to
work basically you'll get a bunch of
errors so everything is going to work
once we push this up to the get up for
now i just want to see whether the basic
setup work so let me look for localhost
and then i'm looking for 5000 i should
see the documentation and once we
navigate here voila we have our
documentation in place now the only
thing we need to do is just go back
and then add those three commands we
want to look for git add
so this is going to add to the staging
area then we'll go with git commit let's
just say
swagger docs
added
and lastly remember the command
get push heroku main or master so in my
case it's master now we're pushing
everything to the heroku and if there
are no weird bugs
we should be in good place
and the nice swagger door condition
should be added to our project and to
answer your question yes when you are
setting up manually basically when
you're typing this yourself you do need
to provide all these properties and i
just thought that it's much easier to
show you how to do that automatically
because you need to keep in mind that
as we're progressing with the course our
projects are going to get more complex
and i really don't want to spend five
hours on a project and then another five
on the documentation because it seems
like a big waste of your time so now let
me navigate back to my web browser i'll
close all of my tabs since i have 10 000
of them
open
i want to go to heroku i want to open up
the app i have my documentation awesome
and now let's test it out so
before we do anything why don't we
remove that bob user because i think
that that way i don't have to waste too
much time on changing the values i'm not
going to test every route but i want to
test out the major ones so let me delete
the user just so i can see that
everything works we're looking for a
register user option
i want to go with try it out of course
and we want to execute we should get
back the token which is just awesome now
let's quickly authorize the route
so let's add here copy and paste
authorized we'll close it
and then let's create a job so let's go
here we're going to go with tryout
and we'll execute yep we're creating a
job and lastly let's just get all the
jobs try it out and execute
i can see that i have my jobs array with
a counter one so that's how we can add
swagger ui documentation to our api
without typing any of the code ourselves